Die WM in Kanada, USA und Mexiko bestimmt natürlich aktuell das Geschehen, aber wie kam es eigentlich dazu, dass genau in diesen drei Ländern die WM ausgeführt wurde? Wie hat sich eigentlich so die Beziehung zwischen FIFA und zum Beispiel den USA verändert in den letzten Jahren und auch untereinander unter den Ländern? Wir wollen all diese generellen Aspekte dieser Weltmeisterschaft der Männer jetzt besprechen. Hier im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch und das tun wir mit Arne Steinberg. Er ist freier Journalist genauso wie Eva-Lotta Bohle und so wie Jürgen Kalwa. Ich stelle sie euch gleich nochmal vor. Jetzt würde ich sagen, legen wir erstmal los.
Verehrte Hörerinnen und Hörer, der Rasenfunk.
Die USA, Mexiko und Niederland haben sich für das WM 2026 der FIFA World Cup gewählt. Danke. Die Zahlen sind absolut verabschiedet. Dieses WM hier in Nordamerika hat für FIFA die Doppelrevenuen der letzten Zeit. Ich habe eine tolle Beziehung mit dem Präsidenten Trump, der ich wirklich ein klares Freund ist.
Alles zur WM der Männer.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Hier ist der Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Ich freue mich sehr, endlich mal wieder Arne Steinberg hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Arne, wie schön, dass du mal wieder da bist.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung und Hallo an alle da draußen an den Endgeräten.
Ist jetzt schon eine Weile her. Das letzte Mal haben wir glaube ich über Schmerzmittelmissbrauch im Amateurfußball gesprochen, glaube ich. Du kannst dich auch nicht mehr erinnern.
Kann gut sein, nee, das ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen her, ja.
Das ist schon eine Weile her. Inzwischen bist du frei unterwegs und aber auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer können quasi direkt von dir frische Post bekommen, auch zur Weltmeisterschaft. Willst du uns mal erzählen, wie das geht?
Ja, das geht über den Newsletter B-Note auf Steady. Das ist ein Projekt, was ich im vergangenen Jahr angefangen hatte, noch während der Elternzeit, weil ich mich da mit verschiedenen Themen beschäftigt hatte, auch hauptsächlich politischen Themen. Und dann kommt der Sport dann natürlich auch immer noch dazu. Und den könnt ihr gerne abonnieren. Und gleich die Info, wenn das Spiel von Kanada ansteht am Freitag gegen Bosnien, dann ist es auch mal wichtig, auf Bosnien und Herzegowina zu schauen. Also darüber wird der nächste Text sein und wird behandeln, welche Probleme das Land hat, aber auch welche Probleme der Fußballverband dort hat.
Also ich würde sagen, die Deckungsgleichheit von Menschen, die sich jetzt gerade für diese Sendung hier interessieren und für die B-Note, dein Newsletter, die dürfte sehr hoch sein. Also flutet ihm das Postfach, liebe Leute, da draußen. Es wird natürlich in den Show Notes verlinkt. Dann ist natürlich auch Eva-Lotta Bohle wieder hier. Also wenn ich Eva jetzt noch vorstellen müsste, dann habt ihr zu wenig Rasenfunk gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Eva, wie schön dich mal wiederzusehen.
Ja, Max, wir machen hier zwei von zwei in dieser Woche voll. Ich freue mich sehr.
Absolut. Und genauso ist es ja mit Jürgen Kalwa, mit dem ich ja schon ganz viele Sendungen gemacht habe. Jürgen, ich habe ja unter dem letzten WM-Penne, das wir am Montag aufgenommen haben, da habe ich ja nochmal alle unsere Tribünengespräche verlinkt. Ich musste schon welche weglassen, weil ich glaube, es waren acht Stück und dann dachte ich mir, na gut, acht links ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel, dann klickt dann doch wieder keiner mehr drauf. Also ich freue mich, dass du so ein regelmäßiger Gast im Rasenfunk bist.
Das liegt ja nur an dir. Ich habe ja, im Grunde lebe ich ja von deiner Generösität und von deinen Ideen und deinen Einfällen. Und wenn ich dabei sein darf, ja, gerne.
Also es ist sehr nett, dass du so ein Geber- und Empfängerverständnis hast, was es dann doch, glaube ich, nicht so, dass ich dann von deiner Expertise profitiere. Aber das werden wir jetzt ja gleich auch alles feststellen können. Also was erwartet euch in diesem Tribünengespräch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Es soll nochmal der allgemeine Blick auf diese Weltmeisterschaft werden. Nochmal einmal wollen wir das gründlich aufarbeiten. Wie kamen die Wm in die USA nach Kanada und nach Mexiko? Was sind die Interessen der einzelnen Länder? Wie hat sich das Verhältnis zwischen FIFA und den USA vor allem verändert in den letzten Jahren? Und wie sieht es eigentlich finanziell aus? Also welche Geldströme fließen? Was ist da zu erwarten? Und einige der Dinge, die wir hier besprechen, die werden nämlich auch viel erklären über dieses Turnier, warum es in dieser Art und Weise stattfindet. Das heißt, es ist euer genereller Überblick zu diesen Weltmeisterschaften. Und mit dem ersten Thema, da gehen wir tatsächlich dann direkt an den Anfang, nämlich zur Wm-Vergabe. Und interessanterweise beginnen wir damit aber nicht dort, wo ihr vielleicht glaubt. Hört mal genau zu, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Die Wiener, die die WM 222 FIFA Weltcup organisieren, ist Katar.
Ich hab gar nicht drüber nachgedacht, wie lange wir sie jetzt jubeln lassen, aber ihr habt's gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir sprechen gar nicht als erstes über die Wm-Vergabe 2026, sondern Jürgen, um zu verstehen, wie es zu dieser drei Länderbewerbung kam, muss man tatsächlich in den Zyklus vorhergehen, also zur Wm-Vergabe 2018 und 2022, die beide zum selben Zeitpunkt vergeben wurden. Warum ist das wichtig, da nochmal drauf zurückzublicken?
Erstmal nur, wenn wir in der Geschichte der FIFA und wie sie Weltmeisterschaftsvergaben organisiert und Beschlüsse darüber fasst, ist das die letzte Entscheidung eines sehr kleinen Gremiums gewesen, eine Eliteeinheit, die sich auch relativ locker mit Geld zubuttern ließ, weil da musste nicht so viele Leute was in die Tasche stecken. Die nächste Vergabe war ja dann schon eine auf dem Kongress, wo jeder Mitgliedsverband eine Stimme hatte. Wahrscheinlich ist das hier weniger geschmiert worden ist, aber bei diesem Laden kann man eigentlich von nichts wirklich ausgehen. Aber die Figuren sind auch, die zentralen Figuren sind auch andere. Also wir hatten hier gerade die Stimme von Sepp Blatter, dem langjährigen Präsidenten der FIFA, der immer so tat, als wüsste er von ganz wenig, was da unter seinen Mitstreitern los ist. Man konnte ihm lieb beweisen, dass er selber auch mit Geld zugeschmissen worden ist. Er hat auch viel verdient bei der FIFA. Und er hatte auch ja nur eine Stimme für den Fall, also eine entscheidende, wichtige Stimme für den Fall, dass das Gremium, also ohne ihn, zu einer Abstimmung kommt, wo also kein Sieger oder kein Austragungsland festgelegt wird. Dazu kam es aber nicht, weil die Dynamik dieser Entscheidung lief halt in mehreren Abstimmungen, aber die lief weg von, und ich glaube, darauf müssen wir zu sprechen kommen, die USA gehörten damals zu den Kandidaten für 2022 und wurden halt noch mit dem Öl oder dem Gas, mit Öl und Gas wahrscheinlich, aus Katar ausgebotet.
Und wir sind jetzt quasi im Dezember 2008, da wird quasi beschlossen, dass eben diese beiden Weltmeisterschaften gemeinsam vergeben werden und diese Vergabe findet dann eben auch später statt, aber eben unter den Mitgliedern des Exekutivs-Komitees. Es war damals so, dass wir hatten schon die Rotation, d.h. zwischen den Kontinentalverbänden rotierte das Turnier, ein Kontinentalverband, auf dem innerhalb dessen die eine der letzten beiden Weltmeisterschaften stattgefunden hat, der konnte sich erstmal nicht bewerben. D.h. man kann eigentlich seitdem, das wurde 2007 eingeführt, konnte man immer so ganz gut schon mal ausschließen, auf welchen Kandidatenpool es sich wahrscheinlich beschränken würde. Das hat damals auch dazu geführt, dass sich wirklich einige Kandidaten für 2018 zurückgezogen haben, weil sie alle davon ausgegangen sind, dieses Turnier wird in Europa landen und wir gehen eher lieber auf 2022. Und da das dann auch die Wm ist, für die sich die USA damals beworben haben, lohnt da eben noch mal ein genauerer Blick drauf. Man kann es sich kaum noch vorstellen, aber damals gab es richtig viele Mitbewerber. Also wir hatten Australien, Japan, Südkorea, Katar und eben die USA, Mexiko sogar ursprünglich auch. Die haben sich aber aus Finanzierungssorgen dann doch noch zurückgezogen, bevor sie am Ende dann mit in der Verlosung drin waren. Und die USA waren der härteste Konkurrent von Katar und jetzt glaube ich, muss man...
Nee, nee, nee. Katar wurde komplett als die schlechteste Bewerbung dieser ganzen vier oder fünf eingestuft, von den Leuten, die sich auskennen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Und die wurden halt mit unglaublichen Lügen, haben sie da gearbeitet. Also die Behauptung, dass man im Hochsommer in Katar unter freiem Himmel Fußball anbieten kann, die wurde zum Beispiel einfach wegargumentiert. Das ist gar nicht so wichtig. Folge, im Laufe der Zeit wurde dann dieses Turnier zum ersten Mal in eine andere Zeit des Kalenderjahres gesetzt, damit man diesen Problem, das Problem lösen konnte. Also Katar war absolut nicht geeignet, um diesen Wettbewerb, um wer kann am meisten bieten, wer kann es am besten hinkriegen, zu gewinnen. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, wie Katar das dann am Ende auch gelöst hat und was daraus für eine Wm geworden ist, das kann man dann eben später auch besser beurteilen. Aber in der Phase, die USA waren so was von besser im Angebot, was die Stadiongrößen anging, was die Sponsorenseite des Themas angeht. Gut, Katar hat auch ein paar Sponsoren mitgebracht, aber diese Coca-Cola, McDonalds-Ebene im amerikanischen Sport und so. Und die Hotels, die man braucht, um die Leute unterzubringen, die ganze Infrastruktur und so weiter. Also das, das war, das hätte so nicht passieren sollen, wenn man also alle, wenn die FIFA-Exekutiv-Komitee-Mitglieder logisch an ihre Aufgabe angegangen wären oder rational.
Ja, da hast du recht. Ich habe quasi schon vom Ergebnis her gedacht. Eigentlich waren die Favoriten England für 2018. Die haben krachend gegen Russland verloren. Das wiederum hat in England so einiges an Untersuchungen und journalistischen Recherchen ausgelöst, weil die sich die Frage gestellt haben, wie konnte denn das bitte passieren? Und das zweite war eben Katar, bei dem im Nachhinein auch bekannt wurde, also acht der 22 Exekutiv-Komitee-Mitglieder haben die Bewerbungsunterlagen von Katar nie angefordert. Also haben sie es sich nicht mal angeguckt. Und dennoch war es da dann aber wie durch ein Wunder so, dass Katar von der ersten Abstimmungsrunde an die meisten Stimmen bekommen hat, von eben jenen 22. Und dann wurden eben nacheinander Australien, Japan und Südkorea vielen raus. Und am Ende hatte es sich aber unterschieden. Und so kam ich eben auf diese Fehlformulierung zwischen den USA und Katar. Und Katar hat sich aber mit 14 zu 8 Stimmen durchgesetzt. Kannst du, du hast es ja damals auch schon begleitet, noch mal zurücknehmen, was hat denn das ausgelöst bei den USA? Sie wussten es wohl schon. Also Sepp Latter hat Barack Obama angerufen, hat gesagt, das sieht gerade nicht so gut aus. Sie haben trotzdem noch Bill Clinton mit rübergeschickt zu dieser Entscheidung. Wie wurde das damals aufgenommen und was hat es ausgelöst?
Also das war erstmal einfach Business as usual. Die Amerikaner sind ja nicht so Fußballverrückt, dass man ihnen, wenn man ihnen eine WM nicht gibt, quasi sie erniedrigt oder so. Das wird auch dann von dem damaligen Präsidenten so als fairer Fight verkauft an die Amerikaner. Also Sunil Gulati, der Fußballverbandspräsident damals. Und man hat das einfach so akzeptiert und nach dem Motto, es wird ja wieder eine WM geben und wir können ja dann wieder uns nochmal bewerben und im Grunde ja auch den internen Prozess, also wie man in einem so großen Land wie den USA wirklich Leute ins Boot holt, also verschiedene Städte, verschiedene private Besitzer von Stadien und so was alles. Das hatten wir ja schon mal alles durchgespielt und auch die Argumente mussten nicht erneuert werden. Das war eben, wir geben euch ganz viel Geld. Ihr könnt ja ganz viel Geld verdienen. Insofern war, glaube ich, die Zuversicht durchaus berechtigt, dass man für die USA noch eine weitere Gelegenheit finden wird, um die Wm zu bekommen. Und noch ein kleiner Nebenaspekt, wenn die US-Mannschaft selber vernünftig mithalten könnte, wäre das Interesse auch an dem Turnier viel größer. Das ist ja miteingebaut. Da wo Hoffnung und Keimen, dass eine Mannschaft mindestens ins Halbfinale kommen kann, was ja auch bei der Wm von Heimmannschaften öfter hinbekommen wurde. Schweden im Endspiel, in Schweden, Chile im Halbfinale, in Chile. Und ja, also deshalb unterm Strich war das erstmal keine große Melancholie, die da entstanden ist. Umso überraschender dann, als etwas später so richtige Geschütze aufgefahren werden aus Brooklyn.
Da kommen wir gleich noch zu. Ich würde aber gerne die anderen beiden hier an der Stelle auch mal kurz reinnehmen, weil ich denke, wir alle erinnern uns daran, also jetzt nicht direkt, wo wart ihr, als die WMs nach Russland und Katar vergeben wurden. Also ich weiß es noch, ich war in der Redaktion von Spox. Es war aber auch ziemlich einfach, sich das zu merken. Lang ist es her. Aber das ist ja schon so ein bisschen der augenfälligste Sündenfall der FIFA damals gewesen. Und Arne, das hat ja auch damals gerade eben in England für Recherchen gesorgt. Übrigens schon im Vorfeld dieser WM-Vergabe. Also wir sind hier im Dezember 2010 und schon im Oktober haben zwei Journalisten der Sunday Times zwei Exco-Mitglieder mitgefilmt, wie sie ja ihre Stimme quasi feilgeboten haben und gesagt haben, na ein bisschen mehr Geld müsstet ihr schon geben. Und es gab also quasi schon journalistische Berichterstattung, die gezeigt hat. Also die Art und Weise, wie hier diese Mitglieder entscheiden über Weltmeisterschaften, die ist eben oft Eigeninteressen getrieben und jetzt nicht in den Interessen des Fußballs. Welche Erinnerungen hast denn du an diese WM-Vergabe und das, was da dann journalistisch auch passiert ist?
Ich kann mich tatsächlich auch noch dran erinnern, wo ich war und was ich gemacht habe an dem Tag. Ich habe es mehr oder weniger live im Fernsehen gesehen. Und natürlich hat das damals, als ich jetzt zum Beispiel noch nicht als Journalist gearbeitet habe, eine gewisse Fassungslosigkeit hervorgerufen. Und ich kann mich dann auch noch daran erinnern, sehr genau, dass das nicht nur ein England-Thema war, sondern in der Rückschau auch in Frankreich. Weil in Frankreich ja parallel zu der Vergabe der Ausrichtung der Wm nach Katar auch PSG übernommen worden ist vom katarischen Sportsfonds. Und das waren eben so Sachen, die parallel passiert sind. Und ich meine mich daran zu erinnern, dass es damals ein Treffen gegeben hat im Elysee-Palast zwischen Michel Platini und Nicolas Sarkozy, also dem damaligen Präsidenten Frankreichs. Das war dann auch schon relativ früh Thema. Also ich meine, wir wissen dann alle, was dann später passiert ist mit diversen Recherchen, mit diversen Momenten wie 2015, die Festnahme der FIFA-Funktionäre in der Schweiz und so. Das kommt ja dann später noch. Aber ich glaube, in der Öffentlichkeit hat sich relativ schnell auch durch die Berichterstattung das Bild verfestigt, dass die FIFA eben nicht das ist, was sie eigentlich sein sollte. Also ich glaube, nach schweizerischem Recht hat sie ja eigentlich erst mal so verglichen mit dem deutschen Vereinsrecht die gleiche Funktion, die gleiche Rolle, die gleichen Rechte und Pflichten. Aber da sind wir natürlich jetzt 2026 noch weiter davon entfernt als damals. Und wenn wir jetzt zurückschauen, das sind jetzt 16 Jahre seit dieser Vergabe. Und die Frage ist, was war jetzt so der letzte Punkt, bevor das alles gekippt ist? Also zu welchem Punkt war das Projekt FIFA und war das Bild der FIFA zumindest in der breiten Öffentlichkeit und jetzt abseits von den Personen, die sich beruflich damit beschäftigen, noch halbwegs positiv? Da werden jetzt viele wahrscheinlich antworten mit der Wm 2006. Vielleicht gibt es auch einige, die sagen, die Wm 2010 in Südafrika war genauso. Aber was ich auch immer im Hinterkopf habe, ist, dass wenn man über jede Wm spricht, ob das jetzt 2014 in Brasilien ist, 2018 Russland oder Katar, es gibt immer diese Frage, ja, früher war ja das auch schon so. Also wie dann so eine Wm vergeben worden ist, welche Bedingungen geherrscht haben in dem Ausrichterland. Und das zieht sich ja quasi seitdem durch. Und seitdem sind wir, glaube ich, als JournalistInnen, ich glaube, da kann ich jetzt mal stellvertretend sprechen, für die meisten mehr oder weniger desillusioniert, was auch jetzt die Reformfähigkeit der FIFA angeht. Das heißt damals hat das aus meiner Sicht begonnen und jetzt kulminiert das quasi in der Wm 2026, so wie wir sie jetzt gerade besprechen.
Wobei mein Eindruck auch so ein bisschen war, es hatte schon damit zu tun, wie Engmann die FIFA vorher schon journalistisch begleitet hat. Also jemanden wie Jürgen, Jens Weinreich, Thomas Kistner, die hat das glaube ich viel weniger überrascht.
Andrew Jennings.
Andrew Jennings natürlich unbedingt zu nennen. Ich habe auch hier, es ist lustig, weil mir ist inzwischen aufgefallen, dass ich eine sehr negative Bibliothek habe zu diesem ganzen Komplex. Also die Bücher heißen Red Card, The Dirty Game oder The Ugly Game. Das ist natürlich die letzten beiden Anlehnungen an The Beautiful Game. Genau, aber da haben wir eben schon die entsprechenden Journalisten. Die waren damals schon nah dran. Ich weiß auch, dass Jens Weinreich mal irgendwann in einer ARD-Doku erzählt hat, er sei Monate vor dieser Wm-Vergabe in Russland gewesen. Und die hätten schon wochenlang gefeiert, weil die eben schon wussten, ja, die Wm kommt nach Russland. Und das war zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo England sich noch wirklich öffentlich zumindest sehr große Hoffnung auf dieses Turnier gemacht hat. Also sprich, diejenigen, die schon vorher nah dran waren, die haben gar nichts von der FIFA erwartet. Vielleicht aber Eva sind wir dann auch so Beispiele dafür. Also ich weiß noch, bei mir war das wirklich so ein Punkt, wo ich mir gedacht habe, also was ist denn in diesem Laden los? Denn man wusste ja, die Bewerbung von Katar war die schlechteste und hatte auch die meisten Probleme eigentlich mit sich. War es bei dir ähnlich, dass du da dann quasi näher hingeguckt hast?
Also ich war da zwölf.
Ah.
Okay. Ich möchte jetzt gerne sagen, ich hatte als Simplesslerin.
Das ist aber eine gute Zahl, ist eine gute Zahl.
Aber wo warst du denn, als die WM vergeben wurde? Ich habe Biologieunterricht.
Zweifel in der Schule als Simplesslerin.
Nee, das war abends. 18 Uhr.
Ja gut, vielleicht irgendwo bei Ihnen, da weiß ich nicht. Aber deshalb musste ich gerade die ganze Zeit lachen, weil ich dachte, also ich würde jetzt gerne behaupten, ich hätte mit zwölf oder in der zweiten Klasse schon so voll das Politikverständnis und irgendwie moralischen Kompass. Aber das ist halt einfach eine glatte Lüge. Also ich glaube, das muss man bei mir auch sagen. Je mehr ich mich mit, ich sag mal, meiner Fußballfan-Identität beschäftigt habe, in erster Linie, weil das kam bei mir, also natürlich an erster Stelle und das war meine Entwicklung, dann kam halt erst irgendwann auch mal so dieses okay, dieser moralische Aspekt, was erwarte ich eigentlich vom Fußball. Also auch diese Dissoziation von der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, die dann irgendwann bei mir auch eingetreten ist. Das hat sich ja auch alles entwickelt, ne. Also von daher bin ich da, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Außenseiterin in der Gruppe, weil also inzwischen kenne ich die Geschichten auch, weil irgendwann hat man sich dann informiert und versucht zu verstehen, was passiert da eigentlich. Aber also im Dezember 2010 habe ich es nicht verstanden. Also wenn hat mein Vater vielleicht zu Hause geschimpft, was der Mist jetzt schon wieder soll. Aber das ist so mein Input dazu.
Jürgen?
Darf ich eine Lanze für Zwölfjährige brechen, die jetzt 28 sind? Und warum das, was wir heute machen und versuchen, nochmal aufzuarbeiten oder nochmal anzupacken? Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass der klassische Fußballfan von heute in derselben Situation steckt. Der war sehr jung oder viel zu jung, um zu verstehen, was da vielleicht in den hintergründigen Entwicklungen dieses Fußballverbandes und seiner Geldmaschinen passiert. Also, du hast ja auch gesagt, du hast nachgearbeitet, aber möglicherweise hast du auch immer noch Fragen und dadurch lassen sich heute diese Dinge auch gut vernetzen. Also wir sind hier, glaube ich, auch deshalb in einer guten Situation, mit jemandem wie dir. Also, das wollte ich nur sagen. Also ich empfinde das nicht als Mangel oder Defizit oder so. Vielleicht ist es ein richtiger Plus.
Ich kann es eh nicht ändern, auch. Also.
Nee, das ist schon sehr gut so. Du bist gut für die, um die jungen Menschen zu erreichen, Eva. Brauchen wir dich unbedingt. Wir sind hier wie so ein Funk-Format. Oh Gott. Arne, du wolltest noch was sagen.
Ja, auch anschließend daran, ich kann es auch nur präzisieren, aber das ist natürlich eine Generationenfrage. Die Vorarbeit von den Journalisten in dem Fall, dem Team, muss man natürlich auch sehr, sehr hoch bewerten, weil ich glaube, wenn man sich in der Rückschau die Vergaben anschaut und die Austragungen der Weltmeisterschaften an sich, dann weiß ich nicht, dann würde das natürlich heute das Format springen, wenn man das jetzt jedes Mal so genau in den Blick nehmen würde. Das heißt, was die Sozialisation angeht, bevor man angefangen hat, sich journalistisch damit zu beschäftigen, das wollte ich eben sagen, dann sind es wahrscheinlich so die WMs 2006 und 2010, bevor das Ganze dann aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen gekippt ist.
Und ich meine, 2006 war ja auch die einzige saubere WM. Da sind wir uns ja hoffentlich eh alle einig.
Ja, eben.
Kaiser wusste doch gar nicht.
Aber gut, das kam ja auch im Nachgang.
Ja, das ist auch alles schlimme Verleumdung. Aber lasst uns bei der Vergabe 202822 bleiben. Ich habe schon gesagt, Jürgen, es ging schon vor der eigentliche Vergabe los, dass man eben die ersten Medienberichte darüber hatte. Also hier gibt es Anlass von Korruption auszugehen. Und jetzt im Nachhinein wissen wir, dass gar nicht so lange später, also Monate nach dieser Vergabe, ein knappes Jahr danach, es auch so war, dass eben US-Behörden, nämlich das FBI und das IRS, also die Steuerbehörde in den USA, die dann tatsächlich einen Kronzeugen, bzw. man muss ihn fast eher Faumann nennen, dann für sich gewonnen haben, Jack Blaser, nämlich tatsächlich. Wir haben das alles in unserem Tribünengespräch zu den FIFA-Prozessen ja auch schon mal aufgearbeitet. Glaubst du denn, dass es da auch einen Zusammenhang gibt, dass die USA übergangen wurden bei der Wm 2022, dazu geführt hat, dass US-Behörden sich mit diesem Fall dann auch so befasst haben, dass dann Ermittlungen intensiviert wurden, die ja dann 2015 in einem großen Knall erst mal geendet haben?
Also ich kenne keine offiziellen Erklärungen von den Leuten, die das in die Wege gebracht haben, in diese Richtung. Die haben gerne so getan, als seien sie einfach ethisch-moralisch dazu in der Lage, sich mit solchen Fragen zu beschäftigen und haben natürlich, dass diese Entscheidung zum Nachteil der Vereinigten Staaten ausging, im Hinterkopf auch benutzen können, um also interne Diskussionen zu führen, bei denen ich jetzt nicht dabei war. Aber wenn Leute budgetieren müssen in solchen Behörden und sagen, was machen wir jetzt als nächstes? Dann müssen die ja auch bestimmte Rechtfertigungsmechanismen pflegen. Also, dass das nicht in den USA gelandet ist, war sicherlich im Hintergrund ein Aspekt. Aber ich glaube, Loretta Lynch und auch andere, die da bei der Steuerbehörde waren oder auch die Doping-Geschichten, die auch schon mit angepackt hatten und geguckt haben, wie kann man im Sport ein bisschen aufräumen. Also, es gibt einfach eine ganze lange Geschichte, muss da kurz rüber springen, eine lange Geschichte, dass man im Kongress zum Beispiel, wo man eben Verantwortung hat für die Gesetzesrahmen von Sport in diesem Land und das auch ernst nimmt, immer wieder gemerkt hat, der Sport selber kann sich in solchen Situationen gar nicht helfen. Also, es gibt ja die große Vorgeschichte, war ja der Bewerbungsskandal, Korruptionsskandal um die Olympischen Spiele in Salt Lake City, wo man also Juan Antonio Samaranch in den Kongress gebeten hat, er ist auch angetreten, sehr unwirsch. Also, da gab es schon immer auch diesen klimatischen Teil. Also man merkt, der Sport kann sich nicht selber wirklich so regieren, wie das Blatter mit seinen komischen Formulierungen immer gerne verkauft hat. Also, was wir in der Familie hier machen, das muss alles in der Familie geregelt werden. Was natürlich eine totale Mafia-Vorstellung davon ist, wie man Dinge regelt, also sich jeglicher normaler demokratischer Verantwortung und auch Rechtfertigungssysteme entziehen möchte. Und die Regie, die ja unter der Zeit in der amerikanischen Politik und dann auch in den Behörden, weil die Politik bestimmt auch, wer sitzt in, also wer ist da Chefstaatsanwalt in einem Distrikt und später ja auch die Ministerin Lynch. Also dieser Hintergrund, glaube ich, verstärkt meine Aussage, dass man irgendwie die Nase voll hatte von solchen Leuten, die immer nur kommen, um Geld abzuholen oder so, aber nicht wirklich sauber arbeiten. Und dann war es halt die Frage, das ist natürlich dann eine ermittlungstechnische Frage, was kann ich diesen Leuten nachweisen und kann ich also eine sattelfeste Anklage auf die Beine stellen? Und da hat man halt, du hast ja Chuck Blazer, ohne ihn jetzt namentlich zu nennen, erwähnt. Also der Ansatz dann über so einen Typen, der also unglaublich viel Dreck am Stecken hatte, dann erst mal das Fass aufzumachen und reinzugucken, wie wird da gearbeitet oder wie wird da geschindeludert. Und Blazer hatte also keine Steuererklärungen abgegeben, hatte also Geld quasi in einen Bar irgendwo hingeschoben und so. Und glaubte offensichtlich, der kommt da ewig davon. Und als er dann konfrontiert wurde, als man also wissen wollte, sagen sie mal, warum reichen sie keine Steuererklärungen ein, nicht nur für sich selber, sondern auch, er war ja Generalsekretär des Kontinentalverbandes CONCACAF, der domiziliert war in den USA, oder wahrscheinlich immer noch ist, bin ich ganz sicher. Also da hatte man den idealen Menschen, und ich glaube, Kronzeuge ist die bessere Vokabel, weil in dem System der amerikanischen Justiz, gibt es einfach diese Rolle, also den Kronzeugen, den Menschen, den man umdreht, den man auch sagt, du wirst weniger bestraft, oder du kriegst vielleicht gar keine Strafe, wenn du jetzt auspackst und wenn du uns jetzt hilfst. Also das hat er nur nicht mehr erlebt, weil er eben früh gestorben ist, aber in den Prozessen, die da noch anstanden, als er gestorben ist, hätte er auch als Zeuge aussagen müssen, was sehr wichtig war für die Arithmetik dieser Anklage. Anklagen, man braucht Menschen im Gerichtssaal, die als Zeugen die Dokumente erklären und bestätigen und so weiter. Es reicht nicht nur einfach ein paar Scheckbücher oder ein paar Kontoauszüge vorzulegen. Da muss jemand dahinter stehen und die Hand heben und sagen, ich weiß, wovon was hier los ist. Das sind alles so amerikanische Interna. Ich hoffe, das konnte man noch halbwegs nachvollziehen. Zurück zu Chuck Blazer, also zu dieser taktischen Meisterleistung, den Kandidaten rauszufischen, der am optimalsten helfen kann. Den haben sie da gefunden.
Wir spekulieren jetzt gerade darüber, ob es da einen Zusammenhang gibt zwischen dieser Vergabe und Chuck Blazer als V-Mann. Jürgen, Frage an dich. Wenn du jetzt auf die verschiedenen US-Regierungen seitdem zurückschaust, dann ist es ja schon so, dass es wirtschaftspolitisch und innenpolitisch Schwerpunkte gibt, wo man sagen kann, wir schauen jetzt auch über die eigenen Landesgrenzen hinaus, auf Organisationen, bei denen zumindest der Verdacht besteht, dass sie sich Korruption schuldig gemacht haben oder dass sie von Skandalen gebeutelt sind. Und das ist ja schon eine Sache, die dann je nach Regierung aus meiner Sicht unterschiedlich gehandhabt wird. Also ich glaube über die zweite Amtszeit von Donald Trump und das Thema Korruption, da braucht man nicht reden. Ich denke, es ist allen bewusst, dass das nachweislich zu Korruption kommt, gerade mit dem engen Familienkreis. Aber es ist ja auch so, dass unter Obama und auch unter Biden solche Sachen immer wieder auch Thema waren, wie weit man da geht. Dann gab es den Rodchenkov Act über den russischen Whistleblower zum Thema Doping. Glaubst du denn, dass das nicht vielleicht doch eine politische Strategie gewesen ist, wo man dann gesagt hat, ja, wir knüpfen jetzt daran an und machen das jetzt mal und schauen uns über die Konka-Cuff die FIFA an?
Also ich glaube, man muss das schon isolierter sehen, weil ich glaube, genauso wie in Sachen, also andere prominente Fälle aus dem Sport wie Marion Jones Doping, die im Gefängnis gelandet ist, wie Lance Armstrong, gegen den auch eine Anklage in Los Angeles auf dem Tisch lag, im Grunde aber dann von dem dort damals entscheidenden Distrikt Bundesstaatsanwalt nicht eingereicht wurde. Da wird auch immer wieder isoliert überlegt, kann ich hier mit meinem Material eine Jury, Geschworenen, überzeugen? Und klar gibt es da im Hintergrund immer eine philosophische, politische, moralische Frage. Aber es gibt eben auch diese reine Justiz zur Mathematik. Er kann nicht damit wirklich durchkommen. Und da müssen wir jetzt ja nicht drüber reden. Aber all diese Urteile werden wahrscheinlich jetzt im Laufe der Zeit kassiert. Warum? Weil der Supreme Court an einer bestimmten Stelle in einem nicht damit involvierten Bereich zum Korruptionsrecht der Vereinigten Staaten im Grunde gesagt hat, dieser Typ von Anklage und Gerichtsverfahren, den dürfte es nach amerikanischem geltenden amerikanischen Recht gar nicht geben. Also das ist ja nochmal die allergrößte Ironie der Geschichte. Vielleicht kommen wir ja nachher noch da nochmal drauf, dass das also quasi sowieso gar nicht hätte stattfinden sollen. Wobei eben, ich hoffe, das verstehen Leute, das amerikanische System ist manchmal unglaublich langsam und kompliziert und wird durch verschiedene gerichtliche Instanzen getestet und so. Und man kann eben immer in dem Moment, in dem Dinge dann auch losgetreten werden oder stattfinden, gar nicht immer sicher sagen, wie das dann am Ende tatsächlich auch ausgeht. Aber weil es da um formal juristische Fragen geht, nicht weil es um das Prinzip geht, jeder ist gegen Korruption, aber vielleicht nicht gegen jede Korruption oder so was.
Ja, und es ist halt auch schwierig, immer die FIFA zu packen. Und ich glaube, das war das, was aber damals am 27. Mai 2015, als es dann diese Festnahmen gab, was das so wirkmächtig gemacht hat. Es schien so zu sein, als hätten die USA einen juristischen Weg gefunden, nicht nur über so ein paar Konstrukte, also dass sie sich auf gewisse Teile der Korruption beschränkt haben, die dann die USA betreffen, dass sie erst einmal quasi nationalstaatlichen Zugriff haben, sondern eben auch dann in einer Zusammenarbeit und das schafft nicht jede Justiz, Schweizer Behörden zu einer Zusammenarbeit zu bekommen. Und deswegen glaube ich, war das so wirkmächtig, was damals passiert ist. Und man hatte damals auch glaube ich noch den Eindruck davon, die haben das so lange vorbereitet und die haben jetzt, die FIFA hat so zwei, drei Fehler gemacht, da waren sie zu packen. Und über den RICO Act, also das erklären wir alles in einem anderen Tribünengespräch, es geht quasi darum, dass die FIFA wie eine Mafiasstruktur behandelt hätte werden sollen. Genau das ist jetzt aber im Nachhinein das Problem gewesen. Aber man dachte damals, ach krass, die haben es tatsächlich geschafft, einen in Schweiz ansässigen Non-Profit-Organis, eine Organisation, die zu packen. Und das hat sich ja auch quasi in der Rhetorik ausgedrückt. Also wir werden noch über Loretta Lynch sprechen, die damals Generalstaatsanwältin, Justizministerin. Ich bin gerade im falschen Bereich hier.
Das ist identisch. Ach so, sowas. Also der offizielle Titel ist Generalstaatsanwältin. Aber die Behördenarbeit ist die Spitzenposition im Justizministerium. Und insofern, hier sagt man halt nicht Justizminister, aber man sagt auch zum Außenministerium nicht Außenministerium, sondern State Department, was auch wieder ganz komisch ist.
Zum Verteidigungsministerium sagt man jetzt immer Kriegsministerium. Das ist ganz komisch.
Genau. Also, leider ist man, wenn man über die amerikanischen inneren Verhältnisse reden muss, kommt man immer leicht in solche Erklär-Beer-Situationen.
Aber bitte, ich würde gerne mal einen Ton von ihr einspielen, von der Pressekonferenz an diesem Tag. Also wir haben zu früher europäischer Zeit diese Festnahmen, auch mit spektakulären Bildern, irgendwelche Luxus-Hotel-Mitarbeiter versuchen noch mit Bettlaken, die armen FIFA-Exekutiv-Komitee-Mitglieder, die da festgenommen wurden, vor den Blicken der Öffentlichkeit zu schützen. Und dann tritt eben unter anderem Loretta Lynch vor die Mikrofone und sagt eben zum Beispiel das hier.
This Department of Justice is determined to end these practices, to root out corruption and to bring wrongdoers to justice.
Also ich übersetze es nochmal ganz grob für alle diejenigen, die des Englischen nicht so mächtig sind. Sie, die angeklagten und damals eben vorherst erstmal dann inhaftierten für eben Befragungen. Von ihnen wurde erwartet, dass sie eben Regeln einhalten, um den Fußball sauber zu halten und die Integrität des Spiels zu schützen. Stattdessen korruptierten sie das Geschäft des weltweiten Fußballs, um ihre eigenen Interessen zu bedienen und sich zu bereichern. Dieses Justizministerium ist entschlossen, diese Praktiken zu beenden, die Korruption auszumerzen und die Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen. Wumms, das war quasi die Ansage und das hat eben auch zu einigen Veränderungen geführt in der FIFA. Denn Sepp Blatter, der ja irgendwie auch so ein bisschen mit gemeint sein könnte, ist ja auch seine Organisation. Der hat zwar noch so Dinge gesagt, wie zum Beispiel das hier.
Etwas ist schief gelaufen, ist auch mein Fehler. Wer nie etwas macht, macht keine Fehler. Wer viel macht, macht ab und zu Fehler.
Wer kennt es nicht? Da macht man einfach sehr viel. Und auf einmal sind sie alle korrupt geworden. Und er hat auch Dinge wie das hier gesagt. Das ist aus einem Interview damals.
Ist FIFA nun eine klare Organisation? Ist es eine honeste Organisation?
Ich denke, dass die Organisation immer ehrlich ist. Ja, die Organisation von FIFA. Aber die Individuen sind nicht ehrlich.
Also das war das Problem?
Das war das Problem, ja.
Aber du warst für 17 Jahre in Bezug, als diese Individuen unverzüglich waren?
Ja, ich war in Bezug, aber ich bin nicht von diesen Individuen beteiligt. Sie sind von den Konfederatoren beteiligt und nicht von dem Kongress von FIFA.
Also ich übersetze es nochmal ganz kurz oder Eva möchtest du gleich dein Unverständnis äußern.
Also ich möchte einfach nur fragen, ob das so Fischkopf, also was stinkt da denn jetzt?
Naja, er wird gefragt, ist die FIFA eine ehrliche Organisation? Er sagt, die Organisation ist super, aber halt einzige Individuen in der Organisation, die sind das Problem und dafür kann ich aber wiederum gar nichts, weil dann sagt der Interviewer, ja aber sie waren jetzt ja 17 Jahre FIFA-Chef, das ist nicht auch irgendwie schlecht für sie. Und er sagt, ja nee Moment mal, ich hab die ja gar nicht berufen. Das haben ja die Verbände gemacht, da kann ich ja gar nichts für. Und das war vom Beginn an die Taktik der FIFA. Die FIFA hat auch an diesem 27. Mai 2015, damals war ihre Öffentlichkeitsstrategie, dass sie gesagt haben, das ist ein guter Tag für die FIFA. Jetzt werden endlich diese korrupten Einzelfälle, die armen Einzelfälle, die werden jetzt hier mal zur Rechenschaft gezogen und das macht die ganze Organisation besser. Wir müssen jetzt nicht alles aufarbeiten, was am Ende aber steht dieser Entwicklung ist. Sepp Latter musste dann doch zurücktreten, bzw. er wurde suspendiert. Da gab es eine Geschichte mit Michel Platini, das wird auch jetzt wieder hochgekocht, denn da gibt es ganz brandneu eine Strafanzeige, die Platini erlassen hat, unter anderem eben gegen Gianni Infantino, denn der hat es über verschiedene Dinge geschafft, sich eben dann zu positionieren als Übergangspräsident und da spielt dann auch später nochmal der US-Fußballverbandchef eine Rolle. Aber das ist jetzt eben Jürgen so die lange Rampe, die wir nehmen mussten, um zu zeigen, das war damals der Status quo. US-Behörden hatten scheinbar FIFA-korrupte FIFA-Mitglieder am Säckel und wir hatten gleichzeitig einen US-Verbandchef, der sehr früh schon darüber nachgedacht hat, ja wann holen wir denn dann jetzt die Weltmeisterschaft zu uns und dann aber dann eben zu der Schlussfolgerung kamen, die Chancen, sie werden besser, wenn wir das nicht alleine probieren. Und so kam es dann letztlich auch zu dieser Dreierbewerbung.
Ja und weil auch hier das Argument wahrscheinlich immer am meisten zählt, nicht in jedem einzelnen Fall, aber oft, dass man höhere Einnahmen erzielen kann. Und diese Einnahmen gehen in die Taschen der FIFA, hoffentlich sauberes Geld, das dann auch sauber verwaltet wird und sauber an zum Beispiel Mitgliedsverbände weitergegeben wird. Aber ich glaube, damit konnte man zu der Zeit auch irgendwie ein bisschen glänzen. Und sicher auch, wenn man als Verband, US-Verband, das Gefühl verbreiten kann, man hat mit dieser korrupten Seite des Geschäfts gar nichts zu tun. Wir sind, und das ist auch so, die Veröffentlichungsverpflichtung zum Beispiel einer amerikanischen Not-for-profit-Organisation, also einer Stiftung oder karitativen Einrichtungen, oder wie auch hier Bildungseinrichtungen, die müssen ihre Zahlen aufdecken. Die können jetzt nicht hinter den verschlossenen Türen arbeiten. Also es gibt eine gewisse Grundehrlichkeit in bestimmten Bereichen der amerikanischen Gesellschaft. Und das kann man natürlich auch in solchen Phasen als Münzer und Tischblättern und sagen, guck mal, wenn wir das jetzt über uns machen, dann wird das eine saubere Wm. Und da ist das mal so stehen, den Gedanken. Und wenn ihr wollt, sprengt drüber das Jahr 2026. Und wie diese Wm, die vielleicht also als dieses Kontrastprogramm einer sauberen Wm an die Wand gemalt wurde, was doch ausgeworben ist, also den Bogen kriegen wir vielleicht insgesamt in unserem Gespräch heute noch hin. Also da wird wieder, da wurde wieder mit Behauptungen hantiert, also Marketing-Sprech und so weiter, was sich nicht einhalten lässt. Und dann würde Blatter sich an die Organisation sagen, die ist ja sauber, die hat eh Leute.
Die sind das Problem.
Diese Leute.
Erstmal hatten sie aber kein Problem mit den Leuten. Also es war so, Canada, das hatte schon im Sommer 2012 seine Bewerbung angekündigt, hatte bisher allerdings nur die FrauenwM 2015 und einzige einzelne Jugendturniere veranstaltet. Für Canada war dann allerdings früh klar, diese Wm 2026, die sollte mit 48 Teams stattfinden und das wäre infrastrukturell nicht stemmbar. Mexiko, ich habe es ja vorhin schon gesagt, die hatten sich ursprünglich auch mal für 22 beworben, aber dann schon frühzeitig zurückgezogen aus eben Finanzierungsproblemen. Die waren ja bereits Wm-Ausrichter 1970 und 86 und haben aber früh dann signalisiert, naja, gemeinsam mit jemandem würden wir es schon tun. Und dann haben wir eben die USA, die eben die Wm 94 schon ausgerichtet haben, dass bis heute oder bis zu dieser Wm das Turnier mit dem höchsten ZuschauerInnen Schnitt. Und gleichzeitig einen extrem einflussreichen Verbandspräsident hat, nämlich genau jenen Sunil Gulati. Und die drei kamen dann in welcher Reihenfolge auch immer zu der Erkenntnis, wenn wir gegeneinander antreten, beziehungsweise Kanada hatte das ja auch gar nicht vor, dann nehmen wir uns gegenseitig Stimmen weg. Wenn wir gemeinsam antreten, dann können gewisse Blöcke für uns stimmen, denn aufgrund der ganzen Russland- und Katar-Vergabe wurde jetzt nämlich das Verfahren geändert. Nicht mehr ein Exekutivkomitee mit 22 Mitgliedern, nein die FIFA-Vollversammlung mit allen 211 Mitgliedsverbänden. Die würden jetzt darüber entscheiden, wohin in Zukunft Weltmeisterschaften gehen würden. Das war zum ersten Mal eine Dreiländerbewerbung im Männerfußball und hat natürlich auch bedeutet, die USA mussten hier etwas abgeben, nämlich Spiele. Und es gibt das Zitat, es ist übermittelt, dass Sunil Gulati gesagt hat, I'd rather have a 90% chance of winning 75% of the World Cup than a 75% chance of winning all of it. Also ich habe lieber eine 90% Chance, 75% der WM-Spiele zu bekommen, als eben eine 75% Chance, alle Spiele zu bekommen. Und das zeigt auch schon vielleicht ganz gut, Jürgen, wie Sunil Gulati tickt. Können wir hier vielleicht mal kurz über ihn sprechen? Kannst du ihn uns ein bisschen näher bringen? Denn er ist im Grunde die Figur des US-Fußballverbandes.
Ja, also im Laufe der Jahre, ich habe ihn erlebt, ich habe ihn nie interviewt, aber ich habe ihn erlebt. Im Laufe der Jahre zeichnete sich ein unglaubliches Bild eines sehr erfolgreichen Verbands-Karrieristen ab, der also mit in jungen Jahren bereits sich um alles gekümmert hat, das irgendwie Leute bräuchte. Also ich meine, in den normalen Vereinsstrukturen kennt man das ja, also die, die da helfen sollen, die müssen sich auch oft wegducken oder so, da müssen andere einspringen, um bestimmte Sachen zu erledigen. Und so war es natürlich auch zu der Zeit, als Udine Gullati in dieses Fußballmilieu gekommen ist, da war er Mitte 20, da gab es auch dringend Leute gebraucht, die irgendwie was machen. Und so die Geschichte, wie er dann als Betreuer der amerikanischen U16, da die schmutzige Wäsche der Spieler einsammelt und sich um alles kümmert und auch den Platz abkreidet und ich weiß nicht was. Also das ist dieser Typ von, wo steht das Klavier, obwohl der also als Figur persönlich, das ist nicht groß, der ist eher klein und der ist auch eher schlank und so viel Muskelkraft wird er nicht haben. Aber er hat relativ viel Brainpower, ist ja Professor geworden in der Columbia Universität, was also in Amerika zu den Top Bildungseinrichtungen gehört. Und der hat sich dann halt so durchgeschlängert. Und als der Generalsekretär wurde, da war gerade jemand gestorben, da brauchten sie auch jemanden. Und der stand schon irgendwo in der Nähe und dann okay, das kann man so nie übernehmen. Und als es darum ging, einen neuen Präsidenten zu finden, irgendwann war er die alte Garde, die so aus dieser Wm 94-Phase gekommen war und die MLS-Gründungsphase, da war er dann auch da. Aber er war halt immer überall dabei. Er hat schon an dem Papier gearbeitet, mit dem der amerikanische Verband der FIFA vorgelegt hat, um die Wm 94 zu bekommen. Also die strategischen Aussagen, also da war er schon dabei. Und ja, und solche Leute werden unentbehrlicher, je weiter sie nach oben kommen. Und je mehr können sie natürlich auch Dinge beeinflussen und mitunter auch sehr komische Dinge. Also zum Beispiel, er war der größte Fan von Jürgen Klinsmann im amerikanischen Verband. Und ohne Sunil Gulati wäre Jürgen Klinsmann nicht Nationaltrainer in den USA geworden. Weil es hat ihn nicht so interessiert, weil damals wurde relativ wenig bezahlt. Es waren immer noch mehrere Millionen im Jahr. Aber er ist dem also jahrelang hinterhergelaufen, bis Jürgen Klinsmann dann in der Stimmung war, den Job zu übernehmen. Weil er dachte, jetzt kann er mal so richtig zeigen, was er kann, was er in Deutschland ja dann auch gar nicht so richtig probiert hat. Das ist ja ja gleich nach zwei Jahren Dienstzeit oder so ist er ja ausgeschert. Und ja, und der ist im Rahmen dieser Karriere, also wird er zum besten Freund von Chuck Blaser, tut aber sowas, wüsste der gar nicht, wie der lebt. Die haben teilweise auch zusammengesessen in einem Büro nebeneinander. Ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass diese beiden Leute nicht ganz viel voneinander gewusst haben.
Im Trump Tower übrigens. Da hatte der US-Fußballverband damals ein Büro.
Und auch die Sache mit Jack Warner, also einem der größten Langfinger in der FIFA, der also jahrelang als Präsident der Conca Cuff in seiner Heimat Trinidad, Tobago, Port of Spain, die FIFA aus ausmanövriert hat und Geld aus den FIFA-Töpfen herausgeholt hat, die er dann in ein Projekt investiert hat, das sein eigenes Projekt war, das war kein Verbandprojekt oder ein Konfigurationenprojekt, eine ganze Sportanlage mit Hotel und allem und am Ende stellte sich heraus, das kann man ihm auch nicht wieder wegnehmen, weil das Grundstück darunter gehört ihm auf jeden Fall und das andere kann man dann auch nicht einfach abreißen oder so. Es wurde von der FIFA auch nie eingefordert, das Geld oder so. Auch da war so Neil Goulart ganz nah dran und dieser Mann schaffte es dann, als die von uns ja schon skizzierte Aktion des Justizministeriums der USA und der Staatsanwaltschaft in Brooklyn da irgendwie nicht aufzutauchen. Der tauchte weder als unindicted co-conspirator, was so eine Formulierung ist, dass man da jemanden nur eine Nummer gibt und den Namen nicht veröffentlicht und aber auch nicht anklagt, aber vielleicht irgendwann doch. Da tauchte er nicht auf und wenn es darum ging, auszusagen, nach dem Motto, was wissen Sie, da fand er auch Wege, sich wegzudrücken und wegzuducken. Als er im Senat in einem Untersuchungsausschuss aussagen sollte und dafür eingeladen wurde, hat er das ausrichten lassen. Ich habe mit meinem Anwalt gesprochen. Der hat mir gesagt, ich sollte hier nicht auftauchen. Diese Figur wurde aber nie so richtig angepackt in Amerika. Er hat es geschafft, sich als dieser Wheeler-Dealer, dieser Typ, der Sachen organisiert und Dinge hinkriegt, zugunsten der USA oder des amerikanischen Fußballs. Es gibt zig andere Beispiele. Wie die MLS heute funktioniert im Rahmen des Weltfußballs und im Rahmen des amerikanischen Fußballs, als Sonderkategorie mit allen Merkwürdigkeiten, hat Sunil Bunnati immer darauf geachtet, dass da möglichst nichts passiert, dass die FIFA eventuell da durchstartet und sagt, Leute, so geht das hier nicht. Das gehört alles zu dem Bild von dem Mann, der durchaus mit schmutziger Wäsche zu tun hatte. Wir wissen nur definitiv, dass es in der Umkleidekabine der U16 war, aber die andere schmutzige Wäsche müsste man ihm auch irgendwie vielleicht vorhalten können. Aber Sunil ist ja übrigens der Name eines Waschmittels in Deutschland. Also war mal eins, ich weiß nicht, ob es das noch gibt. Ihr seid zu jung. Als ich aufgewachsen bin, also Dash, oder Dash, wie man auf Deutsch sagt, Omo Persil. Und Sunil war also eine Qualitätsmark. Und dann kam noch irgendwie die...
Mit dem Fuchs oder...
Ich habe gerade gegoogelt, da steht direkt bei einem Drogerietes-Counter steht Sunil, Waschmittel, das wirkt.
Ja, das hätte dann...
Ja, das ist praktisch....
Gullati auch gebraucht. Beziehungsweise er ist irgendwie durchgekommen. Und vielleicht liegt das auch da dran, weil er es letztlich geschafft hat, sowohl über die Bewerbung 94, er war dann ja auch Vorsitzender der MLS, und später, 2006, wurde er dann eben Verbandspräsident. Aber ich glaube, zumindest wenn ich so amerikanische Porträts über ihn jetzt noch mal in der Vorbereitung gelesen hab, die wirklich zum Teil triefen vor Ehrfurcht und Begeisterung für diesen Menschen. Ich glaube, das hat auch damit zu tun, dass in seiner Zeit und vielleicht auch über ihn der US-Fußballverband an die großen, großen Tische kam. Also er war eben Mitglied im Exekutivkomitee von 2013 bis 2021. Also da sehen wir auch schon, warum er zumindest manche Dinge auch mitbekommen haben muss. Übrigens hat er sich mit einer Stimme mehr gegen einen mexikanischen Konkurrenten damals durchgesetzt. Und er war letztlich auch, ja ich weiß nicht, ob es zu viel gesagt ist, Jürgen, aber der Königsmacher von Gianni Infantino. Also die USA und auch die CONCACAF, also die Konfederation dahinter, hatten eigentlich einen anderen Kandidaten, nämlich Jordaniens Prinz Ali bin al-Hussein. Damals in der Wahl eben Gianni Infantino oder er. Wer würde eben FIFA-Präsident werden, nachdem Michel Platini ausgeschaltet wurde von Gianni Infantino. Das ist dann nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Und als ich dann nach dem ersten Wahlgang rauskristallisierte, also hier gibt es keine Möglichkeit, dass es wirklich al-Hussein werden kann, dann war es Gullati, der die anderen überzeugt hat, so jetzt alle Stimmen für Gianni Infantino. Und mit diesen Stimmen wurde dann Infantino auch der FIFA-Präsident. Und ich glaube, dass das so nicht vorhersehbar war. Auch damals kann ich mich noch erinnern, dass schon einige gefragt haben, seit wann entscheidet denn der US-Fußballverband, was hier im europäischen und südamerikanischen Fußball so passiert. Vielleicht, sehr zu meiner These Jürgen, kommt daher eben auch tatsächlich dann die Ehrfurcht ihm gegenüber und vielleicht auch in manchen Teilen die Kritiklosigkeit.
Ja, also, schwer zu beurteilen, auch für die anderen Außenstehenden, die anderen Berichterstatter, die auch nicht bei solchen Terminen dabei sind, wenn da gekungelt wird zum Beispiel oder so. Aber es gibt zumindest noch mal eine Belegstelle, wenige Monate nachdem Infantino im Amt ist oder so, ist auf jeden Fall Gulati einer derjenigen, der dabei hilft, die Aufpasser aus dem Weg zu räumen, die sich die FIFA vorher durch neue Statuten und so weiter eigentlich gegönnt hat. Und das waren zumindest zwei sehr kritische Menschen, denen man hätte zutrauen können, dass sie dem Infantino von Anfang an auf die Finger klopfen, weil zum Beispiel er ja auch dieses Amt missbraucht. Also geht ja schon intern, ging es ja schon los. Eigentlich ist der, in dem Fall war es ja eine Frau, Generalsekretärposition, ist verantwortlich für fast alles, was geschäftlich in der Fifa abläuft. Der Präsident ist laut Statut eher so ein Steinmeier oder so was. Der darf dann halt irgendwo Schlüsselübergaben oder Grüßen oder so. Das ist nicht vorgesehen im Statut, dass jemand als Präsident der Fifa das macht, was Infantino alles tut. Also diese Anmaßung, die hätte sicherlich nach den Erfahrungen von vorher, nach dem Motto, wir müssen ja aufpassen, da gucken Leute zu. Die haben auch Staatsanwaltschaften und Polizei und so. Bankenaufsichten. Das wurde sofort mit Hilfe von Sunir Gulati gewaschen, dieser erste Schritt. Daraus folgt auch, weil das kann ja nur mit Infantinos Zustimmung passiert sein, daraus folgt auch sicherlich Teil eins der Geschichte, die du vorhin erzählt hast, die Königsmacherrolle.
Und wir haben diese Schleife jetzt auch deshalb gebunden, nicht nur weil es interessant ist, mal darüber zu sprechen, was eigentlich so wichtige Köpfe getan haben damals, sondern weil man, glaube ich, auch so verstehen kann, wie dann letztlich die Wm in den USA gelandet ist. Wir haben für 2026 nur einen Konkurrenten und das ist Marokko. Marokko bewirbt sich zum fünften Mal um eine Weltmeisterschaft bei den Männern. Es gab allerdings große Unterschiede zu der Dreierbewerbung von USA, Kanada und Mexiko. Inzwischen gibt es eine Bit Evaluation Group oder Taskforce der FIFA, also sprich eine Kommission, die die Bewerbungen um Weltmeisterschaften bewerten sollen nach verschiedenen Kriterien. Man hat hier versucht, transparenter zu werden. Wie gut das gelungen ist, da könnten wir jetzt nochmal ganz tief reingehen ins Rabbit Hole. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr darauf Lust habt, aber wenn man sich die Besetzung dieser Bit-Task Force anguckt, dann sitzen da schon sehr viele Leute, die Infantino entweder zur FIFA geholt hat oder dort reingesetzt haben oder die so viel über die FIFA wissen, dass sie eigentlich jeden innerhalb der FIFA in der Hand haben könnten. Grüße an Marco Villegas da zum Beispiel. Über den wird auch gerade gesprochen. Was aber jetzt glaube ich für uns jetzt erstmal wichtig ist, zu wissen neben diesen Einzelpersonen, die da drin saßen, wie sie eigentlich die Bewerbungen bewertet haben. Und das war sehr, sehr deutlich. Am 1. Juni 2018 veröffentlicht eben genau diese Task Force, dass ihre eigene Bewertung und nur wenige Tage später findet dann eben auch im Plenum in der Generalversammlung die Abstimmung statt. Und von 500 möglichen Punkten erhält Marokko 275 und die Bewerbung aus USA, Kanada und Mexiko 402 Punkte. Das hat ganz wesentlich mit der Infrastruktur zu tun. Also Marokko hätte neun Stadien neu bauen müssen, fünf wären umgebaut worden. In den USA, Kanada und Mexiko hätten wir mit bestehenden Stadien operieren müssen. Und was aber sicherlich auch erwähnenswert ist, ich will jetzt nicht die ganze Bit Evaluation mit euch durchgehen, auch wenn es wirklich sehr interessant ist, sich auch zu gucken, was wurde davon eigentlich umgesetzt. Also z.B. Thema Nachhaltigkeit und Klimabewusstsein. Ganz schwieriges Thema. Aber ich glaube, einer der allerwichtigsten Punkte, und deswegen wollte ich das eben hier nochmal kurz erklären, war die Einnahmenprognose, die es damals schon gab. Und da liegen nämlich die USA, Kanada und Mexiko fast 100% über Marokko. Also der Unterschied, Marokko, 7,2 Milliarden US-Dollar wurden als Einnahmen vorhergesagt. Die USA, Kanada und Mexiko 14,3 Milliarden. Und ich glaube, dass neben allen, also man kann hier auch ins Detail gehen, Jürgen, wenn du magst, können wir das auch noch machen. Aber wenn man dann, glaube ich, wissen möchte, warum entscheiden sich dann die Mitgliedsverbände in der Vollversammlung für die USA und warum entscheiden sich zum Beispiel auch manche afrikanische Staaten, die ja eigentlich vielleicht ein Interesse haben, so hinten, dass dieses Turnier auf ihrem Kontinent stattfindet. Warum entscheiden die sich gegen Marokko und für die USA? Weil ihnen damit eben mehr Geld sicher war.
Also ich würde jetzt gerne auch mal andere Stimmen hören, weil ich höre mich jetzt schon länger reden. Vielleicht kann ja jemand anderer an dem Punkt auch mal kurz ein reingrätschen. Eva, vielleicht hat sich ja auch ganz gut reingefummelt in den Stoff.
Das ist jetzt aber hier wirklich.
Ich wollte dich nicht auf den Top setzen, okay, gut, geil.
Ich war eigentlich sehr froh, dass ihr das übernommen habt oder du, weil ich muss ehrlich gesagt immer gestehen, bei mir geht da immer irgendwann so eine Leuchte an und ich checke einfach überhaupt nicht mehr, was passiert und wann war wie viele Bits. Das ist immer so für mich einfach super komplex zu verstehen. Deshalb, ich bin einfach mal richtig fies, weil ich weiß, Arne hat sich viel auch mit der WM, also in Bezug auf die USA, auch so beschäftigt. Vielleicht kann er das beantworten. Ich bin richtig gemein, aber das gebe ich jetzt einfach weiter.
Danke für die Überleitung. Also, wenn man einen Schritt zurück tritt, ist das natürlich eine Sache, die im nationalen und internationalen Sport und gerade bei den Organisationen immer wichtig ist. Dass man versucht, Objektivität herzustellen, mit der man gewisse Entscheidungen legitimieren kann. Also, ich habe jetzt zuletzt relativ viel dazu gemacht, was die Deutsche Olympia Bewerbung angeht und die Regionen und Städte, die sich da ins Spiel bringen wollen. Das sind ja jetzt NRW mit Köln und München plus eventuell Berlin. Hamburg hat ja schon Nein gesagt dazu und da mussten die jetzt die Städte und Regionen, die sich dafür interessieren, die mussten ja auch bis Anfang Juni dann ihre Konzepte einreichen. Und da wird es dann auch eine hochkomplizierte Bewertungsmatrix geben, wo dann eben draus hervorgeht, welche der Städte jetzt oder Regionen sich am besten dafür eignet. Und ich habe mir die ganzen Punkte dazu in der Vorbereitung auch angeschaut, was jetzt die Vergabe in die USA, Kanada und Mexiko anging. Und warum nicht Marokko? Ich meine, man muss ja schon mal sagen, das ist sehr, sehr komplex. Auf jeden Fall. Da geht es sehr stark in die Tiefe. Aber die Frage ist natürlich, was davon ist tatsächlich dann am Ende greifbar und was ist davon am Ende die Realität? Das kann man natürlich jetzt nicht schon sieben, acht Jahre im Voraus betrachten. Aber was man denke ich zugute halten muss, jetzt auch aus relativ neutraler Perspektive, dass hier zumindest der Versuch unternommen worden ist, das auf eine Art zu legitimieren. Ob das jetzt richtig so ist oder nicht, ist die andere Frage. Das kommt ja dann auch dann auf die Personenkonstellation an. Also welche Personen das letztendlich dann entschieden haben. Aber es ist denke ich schon so, dass die FIFA unter Gianni Infantino, der ja dann 2016 nach Blatter kam, der hat sich als großer Reformer gegeben und präsentiert. Es war ja immer so, dass er gesagt hat, er möchte jetzt sinngemäß den Laden so ein bisschen aufräumen. Und das war ja dann das erste Mal, dass eine WM-Vergabe komplett, also von der Vergabe bis jetzt zur Durchführung in den nächsten sechs Wochen, das lief ja unter seiner Ägide quasi ab. Und so hat das Ganze eben begonnen. Und ob jetzt da das Ergebnis so wie es ist, letztendlich verdient ist oder nicht, ja, da müssten wir glaube ich nochmal richtig in die Tiefe gehen. Aber mein Punkt ist, dass das ja jetzt in der Nachvollziehbarkeit schon mal anders ist als vorher.
Also ich glaube, an diesem ökonomischen Argument kommt man nicht vorbei, weil wir werden später noch drüber sprechen, wer verdient eigentlich was durch diese Weltmeisterschaft, die ja auch ökonomisch die erfolgreichste bisher gespielte ist. Gleichzeitig finde ich es aber wichtig, eben einmal darauf hinzuweisen, also ich werde jetzt nicht nochmal ganz tief reingehen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wer diese fünf Mitglieder dieser Bit Evaluation Task Force sind. Aber es ist schon wichtig zu wissen, es war ein eindeutiges Ergebnis dieser Task Force, dass eben die Dreierbewerbung Marokko vorzuziehen sei und viele Dinge davon sind nachvollziehbar. Ich würde allerdings auch wirklich nicht ausschließen wollen, dass auch von Beginn an die hier eingesetzten fünf Personen dann doch ein klares Ziel hatten. Denn dass Gianni Infantino ein großer Freund dieser Dreiländerbewerbung war, das ist relativ gut belegt. Und es sind eben so Dinge passiert, wie eben Thomas Wessel und Marco Filliger. Das sind so zwei, die mit dabei sind. Also der eine war früher mal Präsident des slowenischen Rechnungshofes, der kennt auch Alexander Czeverin, hat eine sehr enge Beziehung zu dem, überhaupt die Verbindung Czeverin Infantino. Noch mal ein ganz eigenes, interessantes Thema, hat sich auch ganz schön gewandelt. Also Thomas Wessel, der hätte eigentlich gar nicht in die FIFA reingedurft, aber sie haben da ein paar Regeln ein bisschen gebeugt, und dann hat es eben doch geklappt. Und Marco Filliger ist derjenige, das der einzige, der bleiben durfte, nach Blatter, also Blatter. Infantino hat eigentlich alle aussortiert, als er übernommen hat anstelle von Blatter. Und Marco Filliger, der ist ganz lange, ganz lange geblieben. Und es gibt das Gewort von jemandem, der bei der FIFA gearbeitet hat, der gesagt hat, also kein Vertrag, den die FIFA abgeschlossen hat, ist nicht über den Tisch von Filliger gegangen, weil er eben Leiter der Rechtsabteilung war und dann unter Infantino stellvertretender Generalsekretär. Und die beiden haben in diesem Evaluation-Prozess, nachdem sie in Marokko auf einer Reise waren, haben sie eine Beschwerde bei der FIFA-Ethikomission eingerichtet gegen Fatma Samura, weil sie behauptet haben, sie sei verwandt mit dem Bewerbungsbotschafter Marokkos El-Haji Jouf, der ehemalige Fußballspieler. Das war komplett aus der Luft gegriffen. Das kommt einfach nur daher, dass Fatma Samura Jouf auch als einen ihrer Nachnamen trägt. Aber tatsächlich war da gar nichts dran. Das hat auch die Ethikomission dann so gesehen. Also es wurde quasi...
Die kommen ja auch gar nicht aus Marokko. Die kommen aus einem ganz anderen Land.
Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, warum machen die das? Warum machen die das auch mitten in dieser Reise? Also sie waren in Marokko und dann ging es eben rüber nach Kanada, Mexiko, USA, um sich da alles anzugucken. Das war der Prozess, während sie quasi diese Evaluation gemacht haben. Und wir können es nicht genau sagen, aber die BBC hat später berichtet, die beiden seien von Infantino angewiesen worden, etwas zu finden, dass der marokkanischen Bewerbung schaden könne, weil er eben ein Freund der drei Länder Bewerbung war. Wie gesagt, wir wissen es nicht genau, trotzdem ist das ein extrem skurriles Vorgehen und übrigens auch komisch, dass das nie irgendwelche Konsequenzen hatte, denn in den FIFA-Strukturen steht eigentlich auch drin, dass wenn jemand haltlose Vorwürfe macht und vor die Ethikkommission bringt, dass derjenige oder diejenigen dann auch belangt werden könnten, ist komischerweise bei denen nicht passiert. Also sprich, wir haben hier mehr Transparenz und es gibt auch wirklich viele Gründe, die auch infrastrukturell und so weiter das Dreilanderturnier versus Marokko bevorzugen. Aber ganz so unkommentiert darf man es dann auch nicht stehen lassen, denn es gibt zumindest Indizien dafür, dass hier schon wirklich alles auch in eine Richtung geschoben werden sollte. Diese kleine Schleife wollte ich hier noch machen.
Dazu kommt ja auch noch, dass man, wenn man sich für Marokko zumindest ernsthaft interessiert, das Konzept, das mal auf dem Tisch lag, von einer ganzen Weile, dass man versucht, den Fußball in Teilen des Globuses zu fördern, wo man erkennen kann, dass die FIFA wirklich helfen kann. Also für mich wäre jetzt das Paradebeispiel Australien als Ausrichterland, weil die haben Geld, die haben eine Infrastruktur, die haben eine unglaubliche Sportbegeisterung und können sich auch hinter ihr eigenes Team hinein denken, auch wenn sie vielleicht bei anderen Sportarten noch ein bisschen lauter schreien würden. Ist aber nachdem diese eine Bewerbung gescheitert ist, wurden also auch nicht mehr verfolgt diese Ideen und wie kann man... Das wurde noch mit, als die USA zum ersten Mal Ausrichterland wurden, wurde das noch benutzt. Wenn wir jetzt in den USA was machen, dann kriegen wir da auch die Liga an Start und dann wird der Fußball in den USA endlich irgendwie respektabel. Und das gab es ja dann auch mit Südafrika zum Beispiel, als man schon in der Bewerbung der Deutschen 2006, war ja Südafrika ein Kandidat, dass man gesagt hat, okay, wir können das nicht einfach ausblenden, dass wir einen großen Kontinent haben mit enormen Talenten und mit einer Sportbegeisterung, auch wenn da vielleicht insgesamt der gesellschaftliche Reichtum nicht mit den westlichen oder den alten Kolonialmächten mithalten kann. Das ist dann auch irgendwie verloren gegangen und ist auch weiter verloren gegangen. Also die Länder, die jetzt ausgewählt wurden, da wurde das, also gut, jetzt kriegt man ja mit dieser Spanien, Portugal, Marokko, mit diesem Spagat kriegt man nun Marokko irgendwie mit ins Boot. Aber gleichzeitig hat man eben diese Fußballmächte, wie Spanien und Portugal, und die brauchen eigentlich keinen Rückenwind, die können auch alleine. Also, aber es ist nur eine Beobachtung, die jetzt nichts weiter erklärt. Was ist da los? Ich bin sicher, die Australier haben erst mal die Lust verloren, sich mit diesem Mist zu beschäftigen. Und da hat sich dann keiner gefunden, der jetzt intern in Australien die Leute überzeugt, die das dann voranbringen müssten. Und das wird überhaupt einmal abge... Wie auch immer. Also, das reicht uns erst mal. Aber gut.
Ich finde ja sowieso sehr spannend auch, also das wird dann ein Tribünengespräch in vier Jahren sicherlich, aber bei der, du hast es gerade angesprochen, Jürgen, die Weltmeisterschaft 2030, da kommen dann ja noch jeweils ein Spiel in Argentinien, Paraguay und Uruguay dazu, weil 100-jähriges Jubiläum der ersten WM. Und da ist, wenn ich mich... Also, du hast eben schon mal über diese Rotation gesprochen und ich glaube, es ist ja sobald ein Spiel stattfindet, sind sie erst mal aus der Rotation raus. Von daher, dass wird ja auch nochmal für die nächsten Jahre ein sehr, sehr spannendes Thema.
Und 2038 ist da das Thema. Weil nämlich rein theoretisch 2038 ist nämlich der Europäische Verband, der Südamerikanische Verband, der Afrikanische Verband und der Asiatische Verband sind draußen. Und wer bleibt dann noch übrig? Ozeanien, also da hätten wir jetzt nämlich Australien und komisch, nochmal die USA könnten daher möglich sein. Haben wir da nicht sehr gut Geld verdient, 2026? Also das wird auf jeden Fall noch Thema werden. Das glaube ich auch.
Wo ich auch die ganze Zeit dran denken muss, auch bei den ganzen Namen und so, also ich bin sehr dankbar, dass das erstmal bei euch liegt, sage ich ganz ehrlich. Ich habe immer dieses It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia-Meme, wo dieser, es tut mir leid, ich kann mir keine Charakternamen merken, aber vor diesem Board steht mit Pippe Silvia und diesen roten Faden spannt und so komme ich mir immer so ein bisschen vor, wenn man versucht, so FIFA-Machenschaften und Co zu erklären und also ja, ich glaube, ich hätte schon, müsste ich versuchen, das alleine zu verstehen, ich hätte diesen roten Faden irgendwie schon fünfmal fallen gelassen und hätte mich dreimal drin eingewickelt. Also bin ich auch, also ich lerne auch super viel gerade.
Stell dein Licht mal nicht so unter den Scheffel. Aber vielleicht sollten wir dann zur Bekanntgabe oder zur Wm-Vergabe 26 dann auch langsamer kommen. Was noch einmal kurz zu erwähnen ist, das war die Vergabe im Januar 2018, die, nee, war nicht Januar, Entschuldigung, es war im Juni 2018. Die war schon während der ersten Amtszeit von Donald Trump und völlig untypisch für ihn hat er mit öffentlichen Statements vermeintlich diese Bewerbung torpediert, indem er eben in einem internen Meeting noch Haiti und andere afrikanische Länder als Shit-How-Countries bezeichnet hat und indem er auch im Grunde unverhohlen gedroht hat, wie diese Wm denn vergeben werden würde. Also er hat unter anderem eben in sozialen Netzwerken gepostet. Ja, also wir haben hier eine sehr, sehr starke Bewerbung gemeinsam mit Canada und Mexiko aufgestellt. Es wäre ja wirklich eine Schande, wenn Länder, die wir ansonsten unterstützen, da jetzt gegen lobbyieren würden und weil dann würden wir uns ja die Frage stellen, warum wir überhaupt diese Länder noch unterstützen. Und er hat gesagt, er wird das genau verfolgen, wer da wie abstimmt bei dieser Wm-Vergabe. Also damals war es schon Thema, was macht eigentlich Donald Trump in der Öffentlichkeit? Und ich weiß, dass die US-Delegation da auch ein bisschen nervös geworden ist, denn es gab damals auch die Möglichkeit, sich zu enthalten bzw. zu sagen, keiner von beiden soll dieses Turnier ausrichten. Also weder eben die Dreierbewerbung noch Marokko. Und wenn das die Mehrheit der FIFA-Vollversammlung gemacht hätte, hätten im nächsten Schritt auch alle anderen Kontinentalverbände, auch solche, die eigentlich nach Rotationsprinzip ausgeschlossen waren, ihre Bewerbung abgeben können. Und ich weiß noch, jetzt im Nachhinein wissen wir, das kam nicht so. Es hat nur einer für keiner von beiden gestimmt und das war der Iran. Sie wussten es damals schon. Drei haben sich enthalten. Das waren Kuba, Slowenien und Spanien. Slowenien hier übrigens ein interessanter Fall, aber ich habe ja schon mal angedeutet, dass es da gewisse Connections auch innerhalb der FIFA dann gab. Aber am Ende kam es nicht so weit. Die Aufregung war allerdings groß. Es war dann in Moskau der Fall, dass eben dann die Wm vergeben wurde. Vor dem Eröffnungsspiel, also im Jahr 2018, befinden wir uns da. Es war am Ende eindeutig 134 Stimmen pro Kanada, Mexiko, USA. 65 für Marokko. Auch einzelne Länder des afrikanischen Kontinents haben für die Dreiebewerbung gestimmt. Und tatsächlich, obwohl sich eigentlich der südamerikanische Verband auf die USA und Kanada, Mexiko festgelegt hatten, Brasilien hat allerdings für Marokko gestimmt. Ist auch ein sehr schönes Rabbit Hole, kann ich empfehlen, da noch mal reinzukriechen, wenn ihr wollt, liebe Hörer und Hörer. Denn bis heute weiß man eigentlich nicht, warum. Die wahrscheinlichste Variante ist, dass der Delegierte damals dachte, es war ja zum ersten Mal so, dass in der Vollversammlung abgestimmt wurde, er hat wohl gedacht, seine Stimme würde geheim bleiben. Und es gibt dann ganz private Collections, weshalb er es wahrscheinlich Marokko eher gegönnt hätte. Aber bis heute weiß man eigentlich nicht, und das war damals aber ein Riesenthema. Also ganz, ganz große Aufregung im Südamerikanischen Fußballverband und auch im brasilianischen Fußballverband, weil sie ihm quasi gefragt haben, was hast denn du da gemacht? Und wie gesagt, genauer wissen wir es nicht. Aber eine der Theorien ist, dass er sich an den USA gerecht hat, weil sie die Karriere seines Mentors damals beendet haben. Also es ist einfach ein Traum, sich mit diesen Themen auseinanderzusetzen. Und so landet aber am Ende dann die Bewerbung tatsächlich eben bei diesen drei Ländern, die jetzt auch 2026 dieses Turnier ausrichten dürfen. Ich erspare uns, glaube ich, die Verkündung von Janin Infantino, denn wir haben es im Grunde gerade gehört. Es lief genauso wie bei Sepp Blatter nur noch ein bisschen dramatischer, mit mehr Tambere in der Stimme. Bevor wir jetzt aber dann gleich auf das gucken, was sich seitdem dann eigentlich so getan hat im Verhältnis zwischen FIFA und USA. Jürgen, und wenn du magst, ihr anderen auch, wenn ihr mögt, was würdest du denn für ein Fazit ziehen unter diesem Bewerbungsweg? Ist das Turnier dann letztlich am richtigen Ort gelandet, am zwangsläufigen Ort? Gab es eigentlich eine faire Chance für Marokko?
Also, wenn ich jetzt doch dann wieder was reinwerfe, ich finde, es war die logische Reaktion auf die Nicht-Vergabe. Angereichert mit all dem, was wir schon gesagt haben, also die Erwartungen an die Einnahmemöglichkeiten. Und auch so dieses, was man sicherlich teilweise in den USA und auch jemand wie, die Trump lebt das ja jetzt auch aus, diese Inszenierung selber von Fußball oder von Turnieren oder so von weltumspannenden Ereignissen. Da ist man natürlich auch in den USA ganz gut aufgehoben, weil man immer auch sich aufbauen kann. Also Fernsehmoderatoren bauen sich auch vor Hintergründen wie der Freiheitsstatue oder der Golden Gate Brücke oder andere sehr ikonische Hintergründe in den USA. Und das kann man so in Marokko auch nicht richtig hinkriegen. Nicht, dass ich sage, das ist wichtig, aber das sind alle so Facetten von heute. Also dieser mediale Aspekt von Inszenierung ist so viel wichtiger geworden. Und da kann ich mir einfach auch gar kein anderes Team vorstellen. Kein anderes Land vorstellen. Was mich wundert ist, aber ich nehme an, das ging dann auch über die Geldabrechnungsdenken. Warum man das nicht einfach sagt, Leute, USA reicht doch, ein Land reicht doch, das wäre doch groß genug. Also warum man gerade, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt, dass das jemals wirklich diskutiert worden ist. Also als wäre das einfach gesetzt gewesen und von niemanden infrage gestellt worden. Das hätte man auch intern irgendwie wieder runterfahren können. Zumal ja auch zu der Zeit schon Trump seine Feindseligkeit gegenüber Mexiko klar positioniert hat. Und da, wie nennen wir das? Also wir nennen das die Wall, ich weiß nicht, wie wir das auf Deutsch nennen, diese Grenz einrichtet. Mauer. Mauer klingt eigenartig, weil es...
Kennen wir ja in Deutschland.
Ja, aber die wurde ja aus Beton und so weiter gemacht. Aber egal, da wurde schon ganz stark an dieser Hass auf Mexiko und dieses Grenzthema wurde da schon ja abgestellt in der ersten Amtszeit von Trump. Also, dazu kann ich nur leider keine Antwort geben. Ich kann das nur als Verwunderung wiedergeben, dass man nicht gesagt hat, okay, ein Land reicht, also ein Land wie die USA. Reicht doch, macht die Sachen unkomplizierter. Selbst wenn man also auf 48, hat man da schon auf 48 Länder abgestellt?
Es war schon, sie sollten schon entsprechend die Bewerbung abgeben. Das war ja eigentlich sogar für Katar schon eine Überlegung, aber da war es infrastrukturell nicht umsetzbar.
Ja, aber auch 48 allein, also die USA alleine könnten auch, wenn die all die irrensten Städte mitmachen, könnten sie das auch alleine stemmen und so. Also, werfe ich nur mal rein.
Ich könnte mir fast vorstellen.
Ja, Arne hatte sich glaube ich gemeldet.
Eva bitte, du warst zuerst.
Ja, ich könnte mir einfach vorstellen, weil es halt, also wenn du es so als Bid einreichst und wir haben ja, ich glaube Max du hast eben zitiert, was da gesagt wurde zur Bewerbung und ich glaube es wäre ja fast schwieriger gewesen, wenn ich das allein recht kriege, das einfach wieder zurückzuziehen. Natürlich würde es, das werfe ich jetzt an der Stelle einfach schon mal rein, gerade anhand der Versprechungen, die die FIFA im Zuge des CO2 Footprints und des Klimaschutz gewesen, dann doch am Ende vielleicht die klügere Idee gewesen, weil man will ja glaube ich bis 2030 da deutlich reduzieren und das jetzt mit einer Freiländer-WM, die laut Experten ja die klimaschädlichste oder sogar das klimaschädlichste Sportereignis aller Zeiten werden soll, kann man in Nachhinein sagen, also vielleicht brauchen wir noch mal so ein FIFA-Bit-Re-Evaluation, was nicht passieren wird, weil da müssten da genug Leute sitzen, die sich mal kritisch unterfragen. Aber ja, also am Ende gehe ich natürlich Jürgen mit dir mit. Also rein historisch gesehen, sage ich mal, ergibt es schon Sinn, welches Problem man sich aufgemacht hat mit dieser Dreier-Vergabe. Auch in den kommenden Jahren haben wir eben auch schon mal kurz angesprochen. Von daher, ja, weiß ich noch nicht so ganz. Ich glaube so richtig, die Folgen, was generell diese Vergabe, also diesen Modus der Vergabe hat, das werden wir wahrscheinlich dann nochmal auch in den nächsten Jahren, wie gesagt, wie eben schon angesprochen, nochmal merken. Und sorry, Arne, jetzt darfst du natürlich auch reingritschen.
Ja, natürlich wirtschaftliche Aspekte, historische Aspekte, politische Aspekte, würde ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ausklammern, weil wir hier immer noch im Rasenfunk sind. Und es geht ja dann letztendlich auch immer noch ein bisschen um Fußball. Und das ist natürlich komplett irre. Ja, also 48 Mannschaften für ein solches großes Turnier, eine ellenlange WM-Qualifikation für Mitgliedsverbände mit sehr, sehr vielen Spielen, wo einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man sich qualifiziert, auch mit wenigen Siegen relativ hoch ist. Eine wahnsinnige Anzahl an Spielen, 104 Spiele, eine Vorrunde, die komplett, ich sage es jetzt, bis es langweilig werden würde, wahrscheinlich. Also ich werde mich wahrscheinlich auch sportlich eher so Anfang Juli damit beschäftigen, wenn dann eben so die K.O.-Runde beginnt.
Rosinen, Pika.
Zusätzlich, ja, es ist ja eine freie Entscheidung. Es ist ja ein freies Land. Ja, ja. Und also die Flugdistanzen, die Hitze, die Anzahl der Spiele nochmal, ja, die Profis kommen alle aus einer sehr, sehr langen Saison und sollen jetzt ja auch noch im Idealfall so viele Spiele spielen. Also auch rein aus sportlicher Sicht hätte es gereicht, 32 Mannschaften in einem großen Land wie den USA, Western Conference, Eastern Conference. So ist der Turnierbau und das führt irgendwie zusammen. Das wäre so meine Idee gewesen, aber mich hat ja auch keiner gefragt.
Ja, und man muss aber auch so ehrlich sein. Also natürlich haben auch, hätte auch eine WM in Marokko wirklich ihren Charme und wir werden es sehr indirekt auch 2030 bekommen. Aber viele der Argumente, die wir jetzt gerade genannt haben, die gegen so eine große Dreierbewerbung gesprochen hätten, die hätte man bei Marokko schon auch anführen müssen. Also an dem Faktum, dass dort eben einfach die Stadioninfrastruktur und auch sonstige Infrastruktur nicht so bestehend ist. Also zum Beispiel großer Teil dieser Bit Evaluation war zum Beispiel eben auch die Bewertung, wie viel können die Flughäfen vor Ort eigentlich leisten? Wie viele Passagiere pro Tag können die abfertigen? Und da waren die USA bei allen Städten und das waren damals noch nicht die jetzigen Städte, sondern das waren, glaube ich, 50, glaube ich, insgesamt sogar, die einfach so auf so einer Liste standen, die rein theoretisch vielleicht sich dann als Host-City bewerben würden. Alle davon hatten einen entsprechenden Flughafen. Da hätte quasi kein einziges Rollfeld neu gebaut werden müssen. Und allein das wäre schon bei Marokko anders gewesen. Plus eben Stadien und so weiter und so fort. Es hätte auch nicht die Hotelkapazitäten gegeben. Und all das hätte ja auch errichtet werden müssen. Wird jetzt vielleicht in Teilen auch für 2030 gemacht und hätte dann auch einen negativen Einfluss gehabt auf eine Klimabilanz und eben auch die Gefahr weißer Elefanten. Also was wir eben gesehen haben, gerade bei der Wm in Katar. Stadien, die danach nicht mehr genutzt werden. Die Wm in Brasilien auch ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür. Südafrika natürlich auch. Also es ist schon ein Für und Wider. Und gleichzeitig bei der Frage, warum hat man dann nicht doch noch mal diskutiert, das alleine durchzuführen. Also dieses Dreierprojekt, das war auch so ein bisschen das Vorzeigeding von Gulati damals und dann aber auch später von Cordero, seinem Nachfolger. Man wollte das genauso. Man dachte auch, naja, die Trump-Zeit, die geht ja schnell vorbei. Die eine Amtszeit, die schaffen wir schon. Naja, little did they know. Aber deswegen hat man das damals auch alles versucht klein zu halten. Das ist wirklich auch eben gerade mit dem, was Trump damals in sozialen Netzwerken gepostet hat. Man hat versucht, ohne ihm zu sehr auf den Schlips zu treten, zu sagen, ja komm, der Typ ist ja dann weg, wenn das Turnier stattfindet und dann machen wir eine riesige Party. Was ich allerdings interessant finde, also ich habe mir dieses ganz lange Bid-Evaluation PDF durchgelesen, wirklich interessant, eine kleine Perle möchte ich noch rausziehen, denn bei den Human and Labor Rights, da haben beide von den drei möglichen Kategorien, also wie ist das Level of Risk, das Risiko, ist es hoch, niedrig oder mittel, haben sie beide ein Mittel bekommen. Bei Marokko lag es daran, dass sie sich zu Menschenrechten im Bereich LGBTQ. Haben sie sich gar nicht geäußert, deswegen haben die da ein Medium bekommen. Und auch die Dreierbewerbung hat hier nur ein Medium bekommen und nicht ein schwaches Risiko. Unter anderem steht da bei den Kommentaren dazu, dass vor allem das höchste Risiko eigentlich ist, dass man wegen der US-Legislation, also der US-Gesetzgebung, nicht sicher sein könnte, dass es eine Discrimination-Free Entry zu den US geben würde. Also eben eine diskriminierungsfreie Einreise. Und da muss man sagen, lagen sie nicht so weit neben der Realität, die wir jetzt sehen. Also, und es zeigt auch, sie haben nicht alles positiv gewaschen in dieser Evaluation. Ich glaube schon, dass sie im Zweifel immer ein bisschen pro drei Länder Bewerbung waren. Aber es wurde schon auch versucht, auch kritische Dinge anzusprechen, die es vielleicht auch bei dieser drei Länder Bewerbung geben könnte. Dann belassen wir es doch mal dabei und versuchen, die Frage zu beantworten. Also im Jahr 2015, da arbeiten noch US-Behörden gegen die FIFA und scheinen der große Antagonist zu sein, zu diesem kompletten Verband. Der Verband mit Gianni Infantino gibt dann vor, um transparenter und weniger korrupt zu werden. Das sehen wir eben unter anderem auch in der Vergabe der Wm 2026. Aber trotzdem ist die Frage, wie haben sich denn eigentlich dann die Beziehungen zwischen den USA und der FIFA verändert? Denn jetzt wissen wir ja, die sind ja quasi best friends forever. Also, dass Donald Trump und Gianni Infantino nicht schon Freundschaftswändchen ausgetauscht haben. Wahrscheinlich hat Gianni Infantino schon die Schuhe von ihm geschenkt bekommen. Da musst du immer drauf achten beim nächsten öffentlichen Termin. Wer die kleine Episode nicht kennt, googelt das mal. Es ist einfach brutal.
Darf ich kurz? Freundschaftsbänder natürlich nicht, weil das ist immer noch was, was von Taylor Swift vor allem ins Leben gerufen wird und die hasst Donald Trump ja nachweislich. Also von daher, das machen sie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Dann eben doch diese super hässlichen Schuhe. Aber gut, Arne, du hast dich ein bisschen mit den Beziehungen zwischen den FIFA zwischen der FIFA und den USA auseinandergesetzt. Wie hat sich denn das so krass verändern können in diesem Zeitraum von elf Jahren, von eben Enemys zu jetzt zumindest die entscheidenden Köpfe sind sehr, sehr eng miteinander?
Das, was bei mir am meisten jetzt hängen geblieben ist, ist im Prinzip die Person Loretta Lynch. Also der Nachname alleine ist ja schon erstmal Grund genug, sich das näher anzuschauen. Sie war ja damals, das hatten wir eben schon, verantwortlich dafür, dass sich mit den verschiedenen Institutionen, mit dem FBI, IRS und so weiter die USA quasi mit der FIFA auseinandergesetzt haben. Und das hat sich ja dann auch schon so gewandelt, dass sie dann später Anwältin geworden ist für eine Kanzlei, die die FIFA vertreten hat. Das war dann ungefähr so 2019, 2020, glaube ich. Und jetzt hatte Gianni Infantino ja vor kurzem sein 10-jähriges Amtsjubiläum. Und da wurde eine Videobotschaft über die sozialen Medien verbreitet, in der eben verschiedene Wegbegleiter ihm gratuliert haben. Unter anderem eben auch sie. Und das alleine verdeutlicht da schon, was davon Weg gegangen worden ist. Also ich glaube, es ist nochmal wichtig, sich vor Augen zu führen, dass das für die FIFA 2015 natürlich schon der Worst Case war, dass sich die USA so stark damit auseinandergesetzt haben, welche Formen der Korruption jetzt innerhalb der FIFA und auch innerhalb der Kontinentalverbände nachweisen lässt. Und gleichzeitig war es natürlich auch so, das dürfte auch Sepp Blatter vorher schon erkannt haben, dass die USA ein riesiger Markt sind, also was Sponsorengelder angeht, was Fernsehrechte angeht. Und das war dann natürlich auch Gianni Infantino bekannt. Und gleichzeitig ging die Rolle für ihn als FIFA-Präsident quasi so los, dass er erst mal schauen musste, auf welche Ebene stelle ich mich denn jetzt mit den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, weil er natürlich da erst mal dem Ermittler sozusagen gegenüber stand. Und es gab einen Text dazu, ich weiß nicht mehr genau von wem der war, aber da ging es darum, dass es wohl einen Trip gegeben hat von Gianni Infantino nach New York, der sich getroffen hat mit Offiziellen, um eben so ein bisschen auszuloten, welche Rolle er denn in den Ermittlungen spielt oder spielen könnte. Das hat sich ja jetzt dann im Nachhinein nicht so wahnsinnig konkret herausgestellt. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, sind ja viele Sachen auch schon insofern abgebügelt worden, dass gewisse Urteile gefällt worden sind, gewisse nicht, gewisse jetzt vielleicht schon zurückgenommen werden können. Und das zeigt schon so ein bisschen, wie schnell das dann auch letztlich gegangen ist. Zentral in der Betrachtung der ganzen Geschichte ist natürlich auch das Jahr 2016, wo Gianni Infantino sein Amt angetreten hat, aber eben auch Donald Trump gewählt wurde als US-Präsident. Und ich glaube, auch da erinnern wir uns alle noch daran, wo wir waren, was wir gemacht haben. Und dann ging das 2017 los. Es ist jetzt vorhinein mir nicht bekannt, da könnt ihr gerne dann später ergänzen, welche Rolle der nationale und internationale Fußball für Donald Trump gespielt haben. Das war mehr oder weniger sehr wenig, würde ich sagen. Aber trotzdem ging es dann eben ab 2017 los, dass so ein bisschen die Bande schon enger geknüpft wurden zwischen Gianni Infantino und Donald Trump, weil eben damals schon klar war, die Wm 2026 wird vielleicht in den USA stattfinden. Und da sprechen wir natürlich dann auch wieder dafür, dass die FIFA und Gianni Infantino etwas wie ein Symbol brauchen. Und da ist er, glaube ich, sehr, sehr stark, ob ich das jetzt gut finde oder nicht. Aber es gelingt ihm ja immer recht gut, die Sachen sehr euphemistisch darzustellen, sich immer an bestimmte Wörter zu klammern. Er spricht häufig von der Magie des Balles oder so und Football Unites und sowas. Das hört man von ihm ja relativ oft. Und die USA waren da für ihn, glaube ich, von Anfang an der ideale Boden, ohne jetzt Mexiko und Kanada zu sehr auszuklammern. Aber wirtschaftlich so oder so, großes Interesse daran, die WM dort auszurichten. Aber trotzdem war die Lage für ihn, bevor Donald Trump ins Amt kam und auch danach für ihn fand Tino natürlich relativ heikel, sodass er dann versucht hat, mit Donald Trump die Verbindungen zu den USA ein bisschen zu stabilisieren, ein bisschen Ruhe reinzukriegen. Und gleichzeitig hat Donald Trump dann eben auch das Potenzial des Fußballs erkannt und auch das Potenzial einer Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft wahrscheinlich erkannt. Wobei ich jetzt nicht so weit gehen würde und sagen würde, dass das, was er jetzt heute in seiner Sports Policy, das hat er ja auch irgendwann zu Papier gebracht und er hatte dann Politiker darüber berichtet. Ich glaube nicht, dass es da jetzt einen tiefergehenden Plan zugegeben hat. Jürgen, da kannst du vielleicht noch was zu sagen. Dass Sport und Fußball insbesondere als Soft-Power-Instrumente begriffen werden, Max.
Lass uns mal kurz noch bei Loretta Lynch bleiben, weil also dann Infantino da auch wunderschöne O-Töne mitgebracht, indem man eben sieht, wie er es auch geschafft hat, einfach auf einer persönlichen Ebene Donald Trump zu packen. Das ist wirklich, aber Loretta Lynch, das ist so absurd. Also 2015, da ist sie Chefanklägerin gegen die FIFA. Ich habe schon vorher diesen Ton gespielt, wo sie gesagt hat, also wir werden diese Korruption zum Ende bringen. Und ich spiele mal noch einen zweiten ein. Da hört man einfach, das war der Duktus, in dem sie damals gesprochen hat. Und ich werde das gleich kontrastieren mit einem Zitat, was ich dann vorlese, was sie jetzt über die FIFA sagt.
Die 14 Verwaltungen, die in der Bewerbung, die wir heute aufsteigen, sind hochgründige Offiziere der FIFA, Regierungsleiter und andere Regierungsbewerber unter der FIFA-Bestellung und Sportmarkteregisse, die, nach der Bewerbung.
Also sie hat eben damals die Angeklagten, das waren damals 14, später kommen noch mal 16 dazu. Das waren eben FIFA-Funktionäre für Anführer von eben oder eben die Vorsitzenden, Präsidenten von Kontinental-Verbänden und anderen Dachverbänden sowie auch Executives aus dem Sportmarketing-Bereich. Immer so ein unterbeleuchteter Aspekt, aber die hingen da auch ganz, ganz tief mit drin. Also mit dem ist sie angetreten und hat dann eben auch diese Prozesse in die Wege geleitet. Jürgen und ich haben es in mehreren Sendungen auch begleitet. Und dann, vier Jahre später, da ist sie gerade eben Partnerin geworden in der Großkanzlei Paul Weiss. Ungefähr um diese Zeit lässt sich auf einmal auch die FIFA von dieser Großkanzlei vertreten. Offiziell, auf deren Seite, hat Loretta Lynch noch nie in irgendeinem FIFA-Fall mitgearbeitet. Das ist auch wirklich eine sehr große Kanzlei. Also es ist rein theoretisch möglich. Aber im Oktober 2019, also sprich vier Jahre und ein paar Monate, nachdem, wie sie das, was wir gerade gehört haben, hält sie die Keynote beim Compliance-Gipfel der FIFA. Und sie sagt, ich zitiere sie jetzt, leider gab es davon nicht den O-Ton, komischerweise steht das nicht im Netz, konnte ich nicht finden, auch mit allen Tricks nicht. Sie sagt, ich übersetze es dann gleich noch, since then, also seitdem Johnny Infantino dort übernommen hätte bei der FIFA, together with all of you, FIFA is an organization that has made great efforts to educate, train and promote a culture of compliance. I am heartened to hear of FIFA's renewed commitment to transparency and ethical behavior and its desire to improve the compliance environment throughout all of football with the important objective of safeguarding this sport. Also seitdem Johnny Infantino übernommen habe, habe die FIFA als Organisation eben große Anstrengungen unternommen, um eben eine Kultur der Compliance, also sprich, das sind eben solche Strukturen, die verhindern sollen, dass Korruption und Bestechung stattfindet, unter anderem zu etablieren. Sie sei tief davon bewegt, eben davon zu hören, wie eben tatsächlich die FIFA jetzt auch nochmal das bekräftigt habe im Rahmen dieses Compliance-Gipfes, sich eben für Transparenz und ethisches Verhalten und Agieren einzusetzen. Und es tut mir leid, dass ich, Arne, da musste ich jetzt einfach nochmal reingehen, weil... Also krasser geht das ja nicht. Das ist ja schwarz und weiß. Und ich frage mich, nicht nur, wie das passieren könnte, das kann ich mir noch fast so ein bisschen herleiten. Jürgen, da wird mich auch gerade deine Meinung dann gleich nochmal drüber interessieren. Aber ich frage mich vor allem, warum das so selten auch besprochen wird. Also, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das jetzt common knowledge, Grundwissen ist unter Fußballfans, die sich ein bisschen für diese Themen interessieren. Ja, ich...
Jürgen, willst du dir noch was sagen dazu?
Ne, ne, ich leg mal los.
Bin ich denn der Einzige, der sich da drüber aufregt? Also, ich find das so krass.
Darf ich, bevor jeder wissenschaftlich oder reingeht, ich dachte so ein bisschen, kennt ihr diese Verschwörungstheorie? Oh Gott, dass Evel Lavigne gestorben ist und ersetzt wurde. Weil, und so stelle ich mir das so ein bisschen. Also, das war so dieses, da wird's passen. Würde mir da jetzt jemand sagen, die wurde halt irgendwo zwischen 2015 und 2019 einfach ausgetauscht, sitzt aber, sieht genau gleich aus, hat den gleichen Namen, würde ich sagen, herzlichen Glückwunsch, glaube ich, weil das wird passen. Bei Evel Lavigne glaube ich es nicht, sage ich nur kurz und zu. Das ist mein popkultureller Take. Also, ich lerne hier übrigens auch viel, Eva.
Ja, noch nie von gehört. Aber werde ich danach der Sendung mal googeln. Ich weiß nicht, Arne, Jürgen, ob er dazu einen, einen Take hat?
Also, ich kann noch zum etwas, das macht es ein bisschen schwieriger, das zu verstehen, aber ich hoffe, es hilft auch. Nummer eins, die Frau hat nicht nur in ihrer Rolle als Generalstaatsanwalt oder Generalstaatsanwältin diese, dieses Thema vertreten, sondern sie war die Bundesdistriktstaatsanwältin in Brooklyn, also in der Staatsanwaltschaft, die das Ganze überhaupt erst mal aufgegleist hat. Und sie hat also sicherlich intern mehrere Jahre, bis also die, die große Aktionen stattfanden, auch für dieses Thema gekämpft. Also das mal nur als Beobachtung. Und dann kann sie sich auch dann in der Situation vor die Kamera stellen und diesen Coup, auch mit den Schweizer Polizisten. Das ist ja schon, man reicht ja schon sehr weit, also weltpolizeilich gesehen. Und dann kommt noch was anderes dazu, dass in der Zeit, nachdem diese Anklagen, es gab ja mehrere, auch dann ergänzende Anklagen und so weiter, und das wurde ja immer größer, ist aber immer klarer geworden, dass die, dass das Vorgehen selber okay war, weil die meisten Leute haben ja Geständnisse abgegeben, die wurden konfrontiert mit Dokumenten und anderen Zeugenaussagen und haben dann also beschlossen, wahrscheinlich kommen sie am besten weg, wenn sie irgendetwas eingestehen. Und der einzige Grund, spekulativ von mir, warum das Ding überhaupt so lange weitergelaufen ist, war weniger, dass es ein paar Leute gab, die gesagt haben, ne, also ihr müsst uns schon hier einen Prozess machen, also Naputh und Sermarin und andere, was sich natürlich auch noch mal hingezogen hat, sondern dass man an den Jack Warner ran wollte. Es gibt ein, es ist nur was für Genießer, für John, diesem Thema. Es gibt ein faszinierendes Detail. Der Name auf der ersten Anklageschrift, der ganz oben steht, ist der von dem Jungen aus den Kamen Islands. Der Nachfolger von Jack Warner als Conker-Cuff-Präsident und dann auch als Exekutivkomitee, Vertreter der Conker-Cuff war. Max ist meistens schlauer mit Namen als ich. Vielleicht kannst du da helfen. Aber der Name spielt erst mal, außer dass er da steht, auf dieser Anklageschrift keine große Rolle. Der wurde festgenommen in Zürich, gehörte zu den Ersten, wurde ausgeliefert, hat dann lange gebraucht, hat seine Bereitschaft signalisiert und eingestanden und auch Schadensersatzleistungen zugesichert. Er wäre der wichtigste Mann gewesen, um einen Prozess gegen Warner in den USA durchzukämpfen. Speziell, nachdem auch noch Chuck Blaser gestorben war. Aber Warner hat in seinem Heimatland, bis neulich, bis vor wenigen Monaten, da hat er dann endlich gewonnen in der Justiz in seinem Heimatland, Trinidad, Tobago, hat er gekämpft gegen die Auslieferung, obwohl es ein Auslieferungsabkommen gibt, gegen die Auslieferung an die USA. Und meine These ist, wenn das alles irgendwie abgewickelt worden wäre, hätte man auch schon zu dem Zeitpunkt als Frau Lindstrom ja auch gar nicht mehr den Job hatte, weil die wurde ja auch, den verlor sie ja auch, als Trump Präsident wurde. Da werden ja solche Leute ausgewechselt. Da wäre das längst irgendwie abgewickelt gewesen. Und was immer in ihrem Kopf stattgefunden hat, wäre auch nicht mehr so kurios gewesen, hätte nicht mehr so kurios gewirkt wie jetzt. Da hätte man gesagt, okay, das Ding wurde abgearbeitet, fertig. Aber es hat sich ja immer noch weiter hingezogen. Und wird dann quasi wie ein Staffelstab an diesen korrupten Infantino weitergegeben. Der also nur eine andere Variante dieses Mafia-Spiels drauf hat. Also, dass man dann erkennen müsste, Frau Lynch, sagen Sie mal, gucken Sie noch genau hin oder so. Sie wissen doch ganz viel. Die weiß ja viel mehr als wir. Die hat ja alle Akten gesehen. Ja, das ist für mich das große Rätselraten. Und das schlägt auch der auf die Füße. Also, das ist eine Frau, die man nicht ernst nehmen sollte, weil die hat da abgedankt. Arne, bitte.
Da kann ich nichts hinzufügen. Ich glaube...
Nein, so war es nicht gemeint.
Das Instagram-Video und die beiden Zitate, die Max da eben reingeworfen hat, die sind ja dafür schon sinnbildlich. Das ist ja insgesamt betrachtet so oder so, Jahr für Jahr dann immer wieder auf eine neue Art und Weise spannend, was da genau passiert, weil du hattest jetzt gerade schon wieder Gianni Infantino genannt. Es gibt ja auch einen Zitat von ihm. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, von wann das ist, aber da sagt er sinngemäß, früher ist das bei der FIFA alles immer unter dem Tisch passiert, was die Geldzahlungen angeht. Und heute passiert das sichtbar für die ganze Welt. Und da hat er sicherlich nicht mit Unrecht gehabt. Und bis heute gilt das ja auch. Aber trotz allem, in der Beziehung Trump, Infantino, ist so das Jahr 2018 der wahrscheinlich bedeutendste Beginn, weil damals Gianni Infantino seinen ersten Besuch hatte im Oval Office. Und da gibt es diese Bilder, wo er dann ein Trikot überreicht, ein blaues Trikot in den Farben der FIFA. Das hat ja Infantino dann auch immer an, wenn er bei irgendwelchen Spielen Fußball spielt auf bescheidenen Niveau, muss man sozusagen, aber gut.
Aber sein Team gewinnt immer. Lustige Side Story. Komischerweise gewinnt das Team, in dem Infantino spielt immer. Ja gut, das kann das.
Wie das von Putin.
Das weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist so, wie Trump hier auch immer wahnsinnig weit unter seinem Handicap bleibt beim Gol spiel. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Aber Entschuldigung, Arne.
Ja und Trump aced auch alle Tests, die er macht. Also es ist ja bekannt, dass die einfach gut sind. Naja, er hatte dieses Trikot dabei und er hatte auch eine gelbe und eine rote Karte dabei und also Infantino und hat die dann an Trump gegeben und Trump hat das natürlich dann direkt.
Darf ich einspielen, Arne? Bitte. Es war wirklich, glaube ich, ein schlauer Zug von ihm. Also sie haben vorher ja schon mal miteinander telefoniert und da hatte da nach allem, was man heute weiß, hat Infantino da vor allem Trump klar gemacht, was wirtschaftlich quasi mit diesem Turnier passieren konnte und übers Geld, da kriegt man Trump, da war er auf einmal interessiert. Und dann aber sind es tatsächlich solche Gesten wie eben diese rote Karte. Wir hören es noch mal, wie er sie ihm übergeben hat.
Eine weitere Sache, die dir nötig sein könnte. Du weißt, in Fußball haben wir Refeater, und sie haben Karten. Jägerne Karten und rote Karten. Jägerne Karten sind eine Warnung. Und wenn du jemanden auskippen willst, wie das hier. Das ist wahr, das ist wahr. Das ist sehr gut. Also das könnte nötig sein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich mag das.
Denen dann nämlich die rote Karte zeigt und sagt, oh ja, das ist sehr nützlich, das nehme ich mit.
Ja, klar, natürlich waren es Medien, aber ich dachte jetzt eine einzelne Person, also ein einzelner Journalist oder so.
Nee.
Ja, nee. Also ich glaube damals, da waren wir alle noch einigermaßen immer noch in Schockstarre, also auch 2018, als Trump dann schon anderthalb Jahre in dem Sommer im Amt war und man immer noch nicht so richtig glauben konnte, was da passiert. Also Shithole Countries, Muslim Ban, verschiedene andere Dinge, Fake News. Ja, der Begriff, der fehlt ja dann auch sehr oft, wenn man über die Trump-Regierung gesprochen hat. Und in dieser Zeit lief es aber an, die Beziehung zu Infantino und da wurde da dann irgendwann klar, über 2019, über 2020, in sechs Jahren müssen die Vereinigten Staaten so weit sein. Man muss die Wärme ausgerichtet werden können. Und was ich eigentlich am spannendsten finde, in der Folgezeit ist der Kontrast zwischen Trump 1 und dann Joe Biden, der dann nachgefolgt ist, 2020 gewählt und 2021 dann im Amt. Und Biden und seine Administration, die haben komplett die Hände davon gelassen, irgendwas mit der FIFA zu tun. Es gibt, meines Wissens, keinen einzigen Auftritt von Infantino im Of-Love-Fest. Es gibt noch nicht mal ein Treffen im Rahmen der Wm 2020 in Katar. So wie ich das verstanden habe, wollte das Infantino sich zumindest treffen mit Anthony Blinken, also dem damaligen US-Ausminister. Aber selbst das hat nicht stattgefunden. Und ich glaube, die Beziehung dort zwischen dem Land, das die Wm ausrichten wird und der internationalen Organisation, dessen Turnier es dann letztendlich ist, das war auf einer formalen technischen Ebene allerhöchstens. Aber da gab es jetzt keine persönliche Bindung zu Joe Biden, wie dann später und auch vorher schon mit Donald Trump. Und die große These, die da für mich im Raum steht, ist, dass eben Biden und seine Leute das unbedingt vermeiden wollten, irgendwie mit einer korrupten Organisation, bei der ja gleichzeitig noch die Ermittlungen liefen, auch teilweise, und die Verfahren liefen, die wollten damit nicht in Verbindung gebracht werden. Und für Infantino war das dann natürlich trotzdem so ein bisschen eine Gratwanderung. Ja, wie halte ich mir das gerade mit Biden? Hoffe ich darauf, dass Donald Trump nochmal wiederkommt? Das wusste zum damaligen Zeitpunkt ja noch niemand. Und das hat sich ja dann eben insofern dann relativ schnell geändert, dass Trump dann wiedergewählt worden ist, aber Infantino gleichzeitig schon innerhalb der FIFA seine eigenen Projekte weitergetrieben hat. Er hat dann es natürlich geschafft, wiedergewählt zu werden. 2023, er hat dann seinen Club World Cup quasi ins Leben gerufen, der dann auch stattfinden sollte, 2025. Und die Aufstockung auf 48 Teams kam dann auch. Das heißt also, er hat wahrscheinlich so aus der Ferne betrachtet, was im Oval Office passiert. Gleichzeitig hat er seine eigenen Dinge da vorangetrieben. Und dann November 2024 wird Donald Trump wieder gewählt, tritt dann 2025 sein Amt wieder an. Und das ist dann natürlich die politisch interessanteste Phase. Ja, also da sind so viele Dinge seitdem passiert. Also ich habe.
Lass noch kurz bei der beiden Zeit bleiben, weil ich finde das nämlich auch extrem interessant, diesen Kontrast. Und da wird mich jetzt Jürgen mal deine Meinung von vor Ort interessieren. Woran lag das deiner Meinung nach? Es war ja auch so, also Trump und Infantino, die Beziehung wurde danach noch enger. Aber ich kann mich noch an den, ans Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos 2020 erinnern. Da haben die beiden sich schon in den höchsten Tönen gelobt. Und übrigens spricht da Infantino, damals hat er noch davon gesprochen, dass durch die WM eine Million Jobs geschaffen werden würden, allein in den USA. Das musste dann sogar er später mal runter korrigieren auf 184.000. Das ist die aktuelle Zahl, die es gibt. Aber kann das auch eine Rolle spielen, dass Infantino damals schon eben so sehr auf Trumps Seite war, dass auch deswegen dann die beiden Regierungen gesagt hat, also wollen wir jetzt erstmal gar nicht so in direkten Kontakt kommen? Oder wie interpretierst du das?
Also ich glaube, dass der das klassische amerikanische Politikverständnis, dass man sich aus der von der Regierungsseite oder von der staatlichen Seite her nicht einmischt in Privatangelegenheiten und dazu gehört jede Form von Kulturveranstaltungen. Es gibt hier auch keine Kultursubventionen, zum Beispiel aus Steuergeldern. Das Kulturbetrieb muss sich hier auch selbst finanzieren, durch Spenden oder durch Eintrittskarten. Und das zieht sich eigentlich in dem Verständnis, das wir alle von diesem Land entwickelt haben, so durch. Und da gibt es eine Distanz. Und nur wenn wirklich mal Feuer unterm Dach ist oder so, wie in Salt Lake City, und dann kommen halt die Politiker, also die aus der Gesetzgebenden, aus dem gesetzgebenden Bereich, nicht die Polizisten, sondern die Leute, die sagen, okay, hier ist irgendwas systematisch faul und vielleicht können wir über ein Gesetz da eingreifen und so. So sind auch Safe Act, solche Sachen entstanden. Da gibt es eben auch diese politische Ebene. Und im klassischen Verständnis ist halt diese Gewaltenteilung. Also es gibt die Justiz natürlich, also als dritte Gewalt. Und es gibt die gesetzgebende Gewalt. Und dann gibt es die Exekutive. Und das Exekutivdasein und das Verständnis davon ist relativ verhalten. Und man drängt sich auch nicht auf oder man mischt sich nicht ein. Und Trumps Politikverständnis hat ja nichts damit zu tun, wie man Politik macht. Es hat ja nur etwas damit zu tun, wie man selber das Theater an Politik ausnutzen kann, um sich selber gut zu inszenieren und möglicherweise auch über Geschäfte, die man dann über seine Familie abwickelt, um noch richtig viel Geld zu verdienen. Das ist ja nicht das, was in der beiden Zeit eine Rolle gespielt hat. Und ob es da jetzt persönliche, wie auch immer, Dinge gab, dass jemand wie Blinken sagt, da möchte ich jetzt auch nicht mit reingezogen werden oder so, das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass auch hier das Politikverständnis der Demokraten ist weniger fixiert auf Personen. Es geht wirklich mehr um Sache und um Projekte, um Maßnahmen, um langfristige Ideen, ideologisch manchmal angefüttert, aber trotzdem erst mal personenneutraler. Klar, das Wahlsystem fördert das, gerade weil wir diese Art von Präsidentschaft haben, verfassungsmäßig, fördert natürlich die Fixierung auf Personen ein bisschen und die Medien helfen auch dabei. Aber das ist das Einzige, was ich jetzt neben dem, was Arne bereits gesagt hat, was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, dass sich eigentlich auch eine Rolle gespielt hat. Mit diesem Verein müssen wir nun auch nicht unbedingt jetzt gerade irgendwie was machen, weil da ist ja die Wm im Land, im eigenen Land auch noch ein paar Jahre weit weg. Also da muss man jetzt nicht, also Infantino hat sicherlich ein Interesse gehabt, schon früh irgendwie alle möglichen Gleise zu legen, um dann darauf weiterzukommen mit seinen eigenen Ambitionen, um die FIFA zu verkaufen und den Fußball zu verkaufen. Aber die Leute, die rund um beiden für solche Dinge verantwortlich sind, die haben bestimmt erst mal gesagt, Leute, dass wir haben andere Sorgen und ja, warum Infantino und Trump sich so schön schon zusammen tun konnten 2020, warum das schon, das kann ich jetzt nicht erklären, weil vielleicht war Infantino nur einfach da und hat gesagt, okay, dann rede ich mal mit ihm. Er war ja schon, Trump war ja schon Kandidat, wenn er also gewinnt. Aber es gibt so viele, es gab und es gibt so viele Finessen an der Entwicklung, die nichts mit dem Fußball und nichts mit Infantino und Trump zu tun haben. Also Trump gehörte auf gar keinen Wahlzettel, wenn man die Verfassung der Amerikaner, der USA richtig auslegt, weil das sind Verbrecher. Und Verbrecher werden normalerweise nicht auf Wahlzettel, können nicht auf Wahlzettel kommen. Das wurde vom Supreme Court gekippt. Und es gab andere Sachen, wo man also versuchte, Trump den Weg zu verbauen. Und das wurde eben auch nicht genug getan. Und da war zum Beispiel der Nachfolger quasi von Frau Lynch als Generalstaatsanwalt und Justizminister. Der war ja natürlich auch eine schlappe Nuss. Und hat also nicht irgendwie angefangen, an dem Projekt zu arbeiten, Trump den Weg ins Weiße Haus zurück, ins Weiße Haus zu verhindern. Das kam ja auch erst ganz spät ans Laufen und so. Also diese Facetten sind da auch noch alle mit drin. Das heißt nicht, dass die jetzt für uns heute so wichtig sein sollten. Aber wenn du mich fragst, was ich so aus diesem Erfahrungsbereich so mit auch reinbringen möchte, dann differenziert da etwas. Wir sind heute sehr differenziert, aber es ist keine Beschwerde, aber so differenziert, wie ich eben kann, daran zu gehen. Gerade wenn ich auch keine klaren Aussagen habe oder Dokumente, die irgendwas bestätigen.
Vielleicht hat damals auch einfach Sunil Gulati gefehlt. Der war nämlich dann 2019 raus beim US-Fußballverband. Übrigens, wenn ihr euch fragt, wo sitzt eigentlich dieser Mensch jetzt? Der ist oberster Finanzkontrolleur der UEFA. Man fällt nie tief im Fußballbusiness, wenn man eine gewisse Stufe erst mal erreicht hat. Und was aber jetzt dann quasi für unsere Geschichte auch wichtig zu wissen ist, die FIFA-Prozesse, die versanden, also wir haben schon am Beispiel Loretta Lynch, haben wir das schon quasi an einer Person erzählt, aber tatsächlich mit Amtsübernahme von Trump 2, gibt er auch die Anweisung, also jetzt die Prozesse abzuwickeln. Es gibt allerdings auch einen Hintergrund dazu, den hast du, Jürgen, auch recherchiert, werde ich auch verlinken in einem FAZ-Artikel, nämlich durch eine Änderung in der Rechtsauslegung, also der Supreme Court hat beschlossen, dass eben Korruptionsgesetzgebung anders ausgelegt werden soll, als es im FIFA-Prozess der Fall war, oder in den FIFA-Prozessen, was ja enorme Folgen hat, also da müssen hunderte Millionen Dollar die schon gezahlt wurden. Darf ich kurz da rein?
Weil es geht, wenn man es sehr vereinfacht um die Frage, kann sich die USA juristisch aufgrund der existierenden Gesetze, weil die werden ja von den Richtern nur ausgelegt diese Gesetze, aber aufgrund der existierenden Gesetze, kann die USA Straftaten, die im Ausland, also im Korruptionsbereich jetzt speziell, die im Ausland stattgefunden haben, also zum Beispiel der Beschluss über die Vergabe an Katar, wurde ja in Zürich getroffen. Also das wäre ja erstmal der juristisch wichtigste Eckpfeiler in der ganzen Geschichte, wenn man da so, oder auch viele von den Taten, die man ihnen vorwarf oder auch belegt werden konnten, fanden nicht in den USA statt. Und der Supreme Court hat also diese, das enger gezogen, gesagt, okay, wir haben nichts dagegen, gegen Korruption vorzugehen, die innerhalb der USA angesiedelt sind. Und das ist nicht total konsequent, weil es gibt auch strafrechtliche Hebel, um Dinge, die im Ausland passieren, in den USA abzuhandeln. Aber da müssen dann oft zum Beispiel US-Bürger betroffen sein und vielleicht auch sich gemeldet haben. Also, nur mal da noch als Beispiel, ihr erinnert euch bestimmt alle an diesen grausamen Selbstmord mithilfe einer deutschen, einem deutschen Lufthansa Flugzeug oder Badaskondor, wo der Pilot in den Berg in Frankreich reingeknallt ist. Ja, und da waren zum Beispiel auch Amerikaner mit an Bord, nicht viele, aber einige, und da hat man auch gehofft, dass über diesen Hebel in den USA dieser ganze Fall und das Verhalten der Lufthansa zum Beispiel, glaube ich, die war da wirklich dran, wie man die also quasi unter Druck setzen kann. Und dann wurde aber in den Vorverfahren, die es hier immer gibt, wurde also das nicht akzeptiert, dass man über diesen Fall innerhalb der amerikanischen Justiz so wie der angelegt war, dass man da nicht in der amerikanischen Justiz damit umgehen kann. Also es gibt eine gewisse Zurückhaltung, wenn es um Dinge geht, und der Supreme Court hat das also konsequent in die Richtung ausgelegt und damit kommen wir an den Punkt, wo jetzt müssen natürlich alle Betroffenen selber nochmal wieder vor Gericht gehen und sagen, ja guck mal hier, also ihr müsst bitte unsere Geständnisse wieder zurücknehmen oder die Urteile wieder einstampfen oder so und die Strafen, die verhängt worden sind, wieder einkassieren. Aber da muss jetzt jeder Einzelne, der davon betroffen ist, muss da was unternehmen. Das wird jetzt nicht so eine große Amnestie oder so geben, wie das Trump ja nun auch schon gemacht hat mit anderen Leuten, wie zum Beispiel diesen Rebellen vom, ja. Also wie kommen wir da jetzt weiter? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe das jetzt nur noch mit reingebaut.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach nur wichtig zu wissen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Also diese FIFA Prozesse, sie starten als brüllender Tiger und sie enden als Bettvorleger. Und wahrscheinlich werden hunderte Millionen US-Dollar, die schon eingezogen wurden, die werden jetzt wieder zurückgezahlt und die Leute werden freigesprochen. Und die Chefanklägerin arbeitet jetzt in der Kanzlei, die die FIFA berät und spricht auf Compliance-Gipfel. Ich glaube, mehr muss man sich dazu nicht merken. Aber das wurde dann eben auch unter der Zeit von Donald Trump eben wieder angestoßen. Ab dann war eigentlich auch schon Infantino klar, okay, jetzt ist wieder mein Bully im weißen Haus. Jetzt gibt es wieder die engen Beziehungen. Und da hatte ich dich ja vorhin, Arne Rüde, unterbrochen, weil ich eben noch kurz unbedingt diesen Ton einspielen wollte von der roten Karte. Ich kann dir auch sagen, ich habe den Pokalton und den vom American Business Forum. Den habe ich auch mit dabei. Was war dann jetzt dann in Trump 2, also in der zweiten Amtszeit von Trump zwischen Infantino und ihm? Was ist da noch wichtig zu wissen?
Ich glaube, die Bilder, die es dann gegeben hat und die verschiedenen Aufeinandertreffen im Oval Office, auf die können wir dann gleich nochmal zu sprechen kommen. Ich würde nochmal kurz einen Schritt zurück ins Jahr 2018. Denn wir befinden uns ja jetzt heute zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme am Vorabend des Auftaktspiels. Und wir haben ja schon mitbekommen, was die Einreiseschwierigkeiten sind für konkrete Personen, die im Rahmen der Weltmeisterschaft in die USA müssen. Und Gianni Infantino sagte 2018, dass es der Gastgeber ermöglichen muss, eine problemlose Einreise möglich zu machen, weil sonst, Zitat, gibt es keine Wm. So, das nochmal noch als kleines Zitat. Da habe ich jetzt leider nicht den Ton. Ich bin nicht so gut vorbereitet wie du, aber stellt es euch einfach vor. So, und es war ja tatsächlich so. Fast Forward 2025. Ich glaube, es hat genug Aufeinandertreffen gegeben von den beiden. Und auch hier hat Infantino betont, dass es unverzichtbar ist, mit dem Präsidenten des Gastgeberlandes eine gute Beziehung zu haben, einen guten Bezug zu haben. Ich denke, das hat er auch vorher schon eindeutig unter Beweis gestellt, dass er das auch woanders kann. In Katar, mit Shaykh al-Zani, in Russland mit Wladimir Putin. Diese Nähe zu den Autokraten war ihm also nicht ganz fremd. Also er kannte ja da schon so ein bisschen die Spielregeln und die Art und Weise, wie man da miteinander umgeht. Und das ist jetzt eine These von mir. Ich sage nicht, dass Gianni Infantino qua Geburt und qua Sozialisation zum Autokraten geworden ist.
Aber man erkennt ja in seiner Sozialisation jetzt als FIFA-Boss, dass er da eine gewisse Nähe mitbringt, dass er da eine gewisse Offenheit für hat und dass er dann natürlich auch das Potenzial erkennt, dass er für sich daraus ziehen kann. Ja, also als glühender Demokrat wird jetzt nicht in die Weltgeschichte eingehen. Und er hat natürlich dann auch in der Beziehung zu Donald Trump sich gewisse Sachen zu eigen gemacht. Also sein Kommunikationskanal ist Instagram und das ist quasi der Kommunikationskanal der FIFA geworden. Was anderes gibt es ja da quasi kaum noch. Donald Trump kann mit einem Post auf Social Media, auf Truth Social, kann der den Stockmarket beeinflussen. Der kann politische Krisen hervorrufen und der kann theoretisch auch mit einem Post, den er jetzt heute Nacht auf Truth Social macht, kann der DWM irgendwie ins Wanken bringen. Ja, was auch immer der für Ideen hat gerade. Das ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Ich sage nicht, dass es passiert, aber es ist zumindest möglich. Und Infantino ist es dann natürlich gelungen, sich immer an den Tisch zu setzen, an den Donald Trump sitzt. Ich glaube, wir brauchen nicht im Detail reden über den sogenannten Friedenspreis. Wir brauchen nicht darüber reden, dass Infantino Teil des sogenannten Friedensrats ist. Wir brauchen nicht darüber reden, dass Infantino bei der Unterschrift des Abraham Accords hieß es auch, glaube ich, damals mit den arabischen Ländern, dass er da auch dabei war. Das heißt also, er hat es geschafft, sich selber als globalen Player zu inszenieren, sich selber die Rolle zu geben, als jemand, der im Rahmen der Geopolitik weltweit eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Und das führt für mich dann zu der Schlussfolgerung, dass es quasi keine Fußball-Wm mehr ist. Das ist es natürlich aus sportlicher Sicht schon, aber es ist ja abseits davon ein riesiges geopolitisches Event, über das man in zehn Jahren noch sich unterhalten wird, höchstwahrscheinlich. Und wenn man jetzt Interesse hat, Geopolitik zu studieren, warum auch immer, ich glaube, dann ist die Fußball-Wm, das ist schon pro Seminar quasi. Also mehr muss man dann nicht mehr tun. Dann hat man viele schon verstanden. Und Eva, du hattest einen Punkt, du hast auch keine Ahnung.
Ich wollte dir tatsächlich quasi so eine Frage stellen, aber mach erst zu Ende und dann stelle ich sie dir gleich auch.
Nee, kannst du gerne jetzt stellen. Ich bin gerade dabei.
Weil ich so interessant fand, weil du ganz am Anfang gesagt hast, ja für Trump ist es wichtig, sich mit dem, ja quasi Herrscher klingt, oder Anführer des Gastgeberlands klarzustellen. Aber es ist ja gerade bei dieser Wm nur ein. Also eins von drei Gastgeberländern. Und ich finde es schon interessant, so die, also wir sprechen ja nachher auch noch über Kanada und Kani und der Scheinbaum in Mexiko. Da sieht man ihn ja nicht irgendwie ein und aus gehen. Und deshalb hat er ja auch ganz bewusst, also wir hatten zum Beispiel in der Feedback zum Wm-Panel und generell ja auch immer versucht, ja wir dürfen das alles nicht so US-amerikanisch fokussiert machen, aber die FIFA, Trump und Infantino legen ja den Fokus da so drauf. Und deshalb gibt es da ja auch so viele Stories zu erzählen. Und ich glaube, deshalb ist ja auch die Berichterstattung da so eingefärbt, was es natürlich in der einen Seite schwieriger macht, über alles andere auch zu berichten. Aber es ist ja auch was, worüber man dann berichten muss, das vielleicht noch ergänzend. Aber deshalb, das fand ich nochmal interessant, weil man ist in der Formulierung schon, irgendwie hat man die USA als so als einziges Gastgeberland, weil sie einfach so in der aggressivsten Form vorkommt.
Ich habe noch die Zahlen dazu, ganz kurz. Es gibt sieben Besuche gab es oder Aufeinandertreffen von Infantino und Trump in ihren jeweiligen Funktionen. Also nicht der eine hat den anderen irgendwie zu irgendwelchen Friedensverhandlungen mitgenommen, sondern dass sie sich getroffen haben im selben Zeitraum. Offizielle Besuche von Gianni Infantino bei Kani oder bei Scheinbaum. Null. Das einzige Mal, dass sich alle drei Präsidenten der Gastgeberländer gleichzeitig getroffen haben, war tatsächlich bei der WM-Gruppenauslosung im Dezember. Also man kann das nicht unterbetonen, wie sehr auch Gianni Infantino diese WM zu einer WM von Trump macht. Sorry Arne, dass ich da kurz rein bin.
Darf ich noch kurz was einschieben? Dann bist du wieder dran. Ich glaube, dass Infantino, weil er das innerlich total versteht, dieses krankhafte, narzisstische Wesen von Trump, wahrscheinlich sind die auch verwandt in dieser Anlage, in dieser mentalen Problematik. Trump zerstört. Alles, was Trump anfasst, geht kaputt. Und die liebbedienerische Art von ihm gegenüber Trump war sicherlich eine Defensivmaßnahme und eine Taktik, um das zu verhindern, möglichst. Weshalb er auch keine wirklichen Konflikte anzettelt, wenn es darum geht, die Interessen der FIFA auch dann durchzusetzen, und Trump darauf pfeift.
Ja, anknüpfen dann das, was Eva eben sagte mit Mexiko und Kanada, kann ich jetzt natürlich nur geschickt dann auf den späteren paar Hinweisen. Die Beziehung Trump und Infantino, die hat ja mehrere Ebenen. Also ich glaube, privat und persönlich gibt es da wahrscheinlich schon, was die Charaktereigenschaften angeht, die eine oder andere Übereinstimmung. Es wurde sogar jetzt geschrieben darüber, dass Infantino sich ein gewisses Wording und eine gewisse Art der Formulierung von Trump wohl angeeignet hätte. Ich habe das jetzt nicht großartig analysiert, aber ich habe es zumindest gelesen. Ist interessant auf jeden Fall, wenn das tatsächlich dann so ist. Und die verschiedenen Bilder, die da produziert worden sind, die sind uns wie gesagt allen im Gedächtnis geblieben. Und alles, was Gold ist, alles, was glänzt, alles, was irgendwie das Scheinwerferlicht mit sich bringt, das ist für Trump erstmal wahnsinnig interessant. Und für mich wird jetzt schon einer der weirdesten Momente sein, Donald Trump, den wir im Pokal überreicht, an wen auch immer. Beim Club World Cup war es ja auch schon so, der Stand dann da, als er den Pokal an Chelsea überreicht hat, der Stand hat das Podium quasi nicht verlassen, hat das Scheinwerferlicht genossen und die Spieler standen daneben und haben sich gedacht, okay, was ist das jetzt hier? Also das ist für Trump einfach ein ganz, ganz zentraler Punkt, sich da im Scheinwerferlicht zu sonnen, was auch immer um was auch immer es gerade geht. Und das wird sich wiederholen in New Jersey im Finale oder nach dem Finale. Und die wirtschaftlichen Interessen, die für beide Seiten da in dieser ganzen Konstellation wichtig sind, ich glaube, auf die sind wir auch schon eingegangen. Das heißt also beide brauchen einander. Trump braucht die Bühne der Fußballweltmeisterschaft. Infantino braucht Trump als Gastgeber, um dort eben seine Sachen umzusetzen. In den elf Gastgeberstätten in den USA braucht er zumindest die Sicherheit von Trump, dass dort gewisse Sachen möglich sind. Und wenn wir uns dann anschauen, wie die FIFA reagiert auf die Verweigerung von Einreisen von Spielern oder von Schiedsrichtern oder von dem Schiedsrichter aus Somalia jetzt beispielsweise, die Kommentare der FIFA in den Presseberichten, die man jetzt gestern und heute lesen konnte, die sind absolut nichts sagen und die sagen quasi, ja, das ist Sache des Gastgeberlandes. Oder was Eis angeht und mögliche Razzien von Eis. Da wird auch gesagt, ja, das ist außerhalb des Einflussbereichs der FIFA. Aber eigentlich wäre es doch Trumps Infantinos, sorry, Aufgabe gewesen, das sicherzustellen, dass solche Sachen eben nicht passieren, gerade weil er es ja auch 2018 schon gesagt hatte, was jetzt die Einreise betrifft. Und andererseits auch, was die Sicherheit von Fans vor Ort betrifft, in den US-amerikanischen Austragungsstädten. Und da wiederum finde ich es auch sehr spannend. Und das ist jetzt für mich quasi einer der letzten Punkte in dieser Beziehung zwischen den USA und der FIFA. Die Städte und die Mayors, die da eine Rolle spielen, die sind ja überwiegend, ich glaube, von elf sind es neun, demokratisch geprägt. Also es sind demokratische Mayors. Du kannst mich gerne korrigieren, falls ich da falsch liege.
Ich hab das nicht durchgezählt, aber es dürfte auf jeden Fall die Größenordnung sein.
Große, größere Städte in den USA sind ja meistens demokratisch geführt. Jedenfalls, dort passiert ja auch was. Also wir hatten im Vorfeld der WM schon genügend Berichterstattung und Diskussionen darüber, was das Dynamic Pricing der Tickets angeht, was den legalisierten Schwarzmarkt angeht, den die FIFA da geschaffen hat. Und da gibt es ja jetzt in New Jersey und New York Vorladungen der FIFA. Das heißt, da sind wir wieder bei US-Ermittlungsbehörden, dieses Mal natürlich auf bundesstaatlicher Ebene, die sich das anschauen wollen. Das heißt, wir haben quasi einen Full Circle hergestellt, beginnend 2015 und jetzt 2026, bevor überhaupt das erste Mal ein Spiel angepfiffen worden ist bei der Weltmeisterschaft. Und wer weiß, wie das weitergeht. Also die FIFA hat quasi keinen großen Einfluss auf das, was Donald Trump macht. Und ich hatte es eben auch schon mal erwähnt. Das kann alles richtig, richtig in die Hose gehen, wenn da irgendwas noch passiert, was wir jetzt gerade nicht absehen können. Und in der Vorausschau betrachtet, was jetzt die innenpolitische Situation in den USA betrifft, glaube ich schon, dass es unter Berücksichtigung all dessen, was wir haben, Iran, die Epstein-Files, die anstehenden Midterms. Das Jahr 2026 könnte Trump schon erheblich schaden. Also die Midterms sind im November. Und ich glaube auch, dass die Wm jetzt nicht gerade dazu beitragen wird, dass er die niedrigen Zustimmungsraten, die er gerade hat, dass er die nochmal umdreht und das auf einmal doch wieder ansteigt. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Jürgen, da bist du näher dran. Aber ich glaube, in dem Ganzen, was wir jetzt da gerade besprochen haben, wird auch das Verhältnis zwischen Trump und Infantino wenig überraschenderweise nach dem letzten Spiel versiegen. Es sei denn, die beiden werden dann Golf-Buddies oder so. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, weil Infantino hat ja auch einen Wohnsitz da, glaube ich, in Mar-a-Lago. Aber gut, das ist nochmal was anderes.
Ja, und ganze Teile der FIFA ziehen um nach Miami gegenüber von Mar-a-Lago. Was übrigens auch schon zeigt, wie wenig sie inzwischen Angst haben vor der US-Justiz. Sonst würden sie nicht aus der Schweiz rausgehen mit ganzen Divisionen. Ich finde es aber nur nochmal wichtig, an der Stelle zu betonen, das was du gesagt hast, beide brauchen einander. Und es ist nämlich auch nicht so, dass es hier einen großen gibt, Donald Trump, und einen kleinen, der vor ihm abbückt, sondern die FIFA ist im Verhältnis zu Regierungen, Gemeinden, Städten und so weiter in ihrer Art des Auftretens ja radikal. Und dementsprechend musste Gianni Infantino auch sicherstellen, dass Donald Trump, der ja wie wir wissen auf Abmachungen und auf Gesetze viel, viel weniger gibt als alle Regierenden vor ihm, dass er da nicht drauf reagiert. Denn wir wissen ja, wer mit der FIFA ein Vertrag schließt, weil er eben zum Beispiel eine Host City sein möchte, also eben bei sich WM-Spiele austragen, der gibt grundlegendste Rechte ab. Von kommerziellen Rechten bis hin zu Demonstrationsverboten, also die Meinungsfreiheit wird eingeschränkt, bis hin eben dazu, da kommen wir später dazu, die Städte verdienen eigentlich gar nichts daran, diese WM-Spiele auszurichten. Und das ist jetzt dann die kommunale Ebene, die ist Donald Trump wahrscheinlich noch egal. Und er sagt eher, wenn die Demokraten so dumm sind, solche Verträge abzuschließen, sind sie selber schuld. Aber das betrifft ja auch die immensen Gewinne, die die FIFA durch diese Weltmeisterschaft macht und die sie auch machen muss. Der ganze Haushaltsplan der FIFA, der basiert immer auf diesem vierjährigen Turnier und alle Versuche mit anderen Turnieren, zum Beispiel der Club WM, eben sich aus dieser Abhängigkeit von der einen WM, der Männer, zu lösen. Die haben bisher so noch nicht gefruchtet. Aber die sind ja auch deshalb möglich, weil es eine fast vollständige Steuerbefreiung gibt. In Kanada und Mexiko ist es eine vollständige Steuerbefreiung. In den USA eine fast vollständige Steuerbefreiung. Und ich glaube, das darf man wirklich nicht unterschätzen, denn Donald Trump wäre der allererste, der bei einem Sport, der ihm völlig fremd ist, mit dem aber wahnsinnig viel Kohle verdient wird, der dann sagen würde, ja Moment mal, wo ist denn eigentlich mein Share hier raus? Mein Anteil. Und der bekommt einen Anteil, da kommen wir später mit dazu. Es gibt so einen Krypto-Partner der FIFA, die unter ganz seltsamen Umständen, der kurzfristig vor dem Turnier nochmal Sponsor wurde. Und die wiederum hängen dann mit dem Krypto-Fund der Trump-Familie zusammen, mit der die ja schon eine Milliarde verdient haben, Stand Juni 2026. Aber auch das musste, glaube ich, Johnny Infantino verhindern. Und das darf man eben nicht komplett unten runterfallen lassen. Und wie er es dann gemacht hat, ist glaube ich über diese persönliche Ebene. Aber er hatte auch dieses Interesse. Denn es ist eigentlich untypisch, dass Donald Trump hier so einen schlechten Deal vor seinen Augen durchgehen lässt. Und ein bisschen partizipiert er davon. Aber vor allem kriegt er gerade Aufmerksamkeit. Jürgen, du hattest gerade Luft geholt.
Ja, ich möchte gerne... Also klar, Infantino tut so, als ob er sich inzwischen mit dem auf Augenhöhe trifft. Und als ob die FIFA wirklich Macht hätte. Wenn auch eine Soft-Power-artige Macht oder so. Infantino müsste sich überhaupt nicht mit Trump beschäftigen. Das nur mal als kleine Anmerkung. Weil juristisch hat die FIFA, was die Wm angeht, so gut wie gar nichts mit der Bundesebene zu tun. Also das betrifft mal gerade die Einreise in die USA. Das ist halt eine Bundeszuständigkeit. Und alles andere betrifft den Bund überhaupt nicht. Die können sich zwar über bestimmte Konstruktionen des vorhandenen Gesetzesrahmens bei Dingen einbringen. Also wenn es um Terrorismus geht, wenn es um Kidnapping geht, wenn es um größere, sagen wir mal, Schwarzmarktgeschichten geht oder irgendwie so Transaktionen, wo nicht viel Betrug läuft. Aber im Prinzip hat die FIFA nur Verträge mit den Bundesstaaten und den Ausrichterorganisationen. Das heißt also Infantinos Versuch, sich mit Trump auf dieses Thema einzulassen und Trump da rein zu ziehen, ist im Grunde das absurdeste Element überhaupt. Das ist natürlich showmäßig alles irgendwie interessant. Aber da holt sich jemand wirklich den größeren Bruder herunter, auf seine Ebene, weil er das Gefühl hat, das reicht ihm nicht als FIFA-Präsident, eine hoffentlich erfolgreiche Veranstaltung zu präsidieren oder so. Und selbst damit hat er persönlich ja gar nichts zu tun, weil ich ja schon auf Aufmerksamkeit gemacht habe. Es ist nicht seine Verantwortung, sich um diesen Scheiß zu kümmern.
Ja gut, das macht die White House Task Force, in der Andrew Giuliani die Verantwortung hat.
Das ist so eine Erfindung von Trump, der erkannt hat, so kann er da seine Hebel reinbringen und auch Infantino quasi notfalls vorführen oder so. Fazit jetzt, Zwischenfazit von mir. Aber Arne hatte noch an der Stelle gleich noch was zu sagen. Ich glaube vielleicht sogar Widerspruch.
Nee, ich würde es nur konkretisieren an einer Stelle. Und zwar ist es ja auch interessant, sich anzuschauen, welche Verbindungen zwischen Infantino und den Mayors in den Austragungsstätten bestehen. Ja, also da kann ich mich jetzt auch nicht dran erinnern, dass er da durch die Lande gereist ist und quasi allen mal einen Besuch abgestattet, Besuch gemacht hat vor Ort, um sich anzuschauen, wie weit sind wir denn überhaupt. Eben auch, weil er weiß, da sitzt jemand im heißen Haus, der sitzt auch tatsächlich dann am längeren Hebel notfalls. Also Trump hat ja auch mal damit gedroht, demokratisch geführten Städten die Spiele zu entziehen, was natürlich juristisch nicht möglich ist. Aber trotzdem hat das hohe Wellen geschlagen und wieder mal gezeigt, was für eine propagandistische Art und Weise des Kommunizierens da auch teilweise stattfindet. Und ich glaube, es ist dann immer noch auch spannend, sich die einzelnen Städte anzuschauen. Also ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass ich in einem Text im Newsletter mal geschrieben hatte, welche Städte sich wie positionieren, ob die sich mal konkreter geäußert hatten zu den Äußerungen von Trump damals, als er gesagt hatte, er entzieht den Städten die Spiele. Und da waren einige relativ zurückhaltend, aber andere, wie zum Beispiel Boston, glaube ich, die waren sehr deutlich. Und jetzt in New York, in Trumps Heimatstadt, ist mit Zoran Mamdania jemand, jetzt relativ neu immer noch im Amt, der das Ganze aber schon sehr engagiert angeht. Der sagt, wir wollen Tickets zur Verfügung stellen in dem Stadion, was fairerweise in New Jersey liegt, aber er möchte es trotzdem möglich machen, was für die Leute hier erschwinglich ist. Er möchte sicherstellen, dass das eben keine von Trump geprägte Wm sein wird, was natürlich sehr, sehr schwierig ist. Aber da unternimmt zumindest jemand den Versuch, mithilfe des Fußballs eine andere Art von Softpower eben darzustellen. Ob das jetzt gut ist oder nicht, ja, das ist nochmal eine andere Sache. Ich wollte es einfach nochmal kurz beschreiben und darlegen.
Wenn ich da kurz rein darf, weil gerade mit meinem Dani hat man ja auch jemanden einfach in der größten Stadt eigentlich, die mit vertreten ist, der ja auch wirklich ein Fußballfan ist. Also das ist ja auch etwas, was dann wirklich neu reinkommt. Und der ja, Arne, du hast es schon gesagt, gesagt hat, er will, ich glaube, diese $50 Tickets, wo es bis zu 1000 gibt, wo ich mich tatsächlich gefragt habe, die Vielfater ja glaube ich auch schon diese 1000 Ticket in den Supporter Categories, heißt es glaube ich. Ob die dann nochmal oben drauf kommen, das habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Also ich habe es versucht, nachzulesen und habe es glaube ich nicht ganz verstanden. Aber ja, das ist auf jeden Fall jemand, dem das auch wichtig ist, der zum Beispiel auch die, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Sichtweise von den afrikanischen Ländern, die vertreten sind, so ein bisschen reingebracht hat. Er hat eben gesagt, er hofft, dass Marokko irgendwie die Wm gewinnt und so. Da gibt es, glaube ich, ein ganz cooles Interview im The Guardian mit ihm. Aber dass er eben auch da nicht nur was seine Politik betrifft, sondern so doof wie es klingt, aber einfach seinen Ball-Knowledge, wie man so schön sagt, Hintergrund da noch mal ein bisschen mit reinbringt, weil wir das ja halt auch, also dass da jemand steht und sagt, ey Leute, also in Anführungszeichen Fußball gehört Menschen, denen gerade der Zugang da komplett verwehrt wird, da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie noch mal was tun. Und das will ich in kurzer Zeit auch tun. Und sich so natürlich auch ein bisschen inszeniert. Und man ja auch seine Antipathie gegenüber Trump sehr genau kennt. Wollte ich das nur noch kurz ergänzt haben dazu.
Zum Thema Ball-Knowledge, glaube ich, kann ich jetzt meinen Pokal-O-Ton hier einspielen. Ich habe noch zwei O-Töne und dann erlöse ich uns aber vor, erst mal vom Thema Trump, wobei so ganz komisch leider nicht um den Osten rum.
Und vor allem von Johnny. Vor allem von Johnny, Max. Ich wiederhole mich nochmal von Montag. Ich habe diesen Mann dauernd in meinem Kopf.
Es wird ein bisschen erträglicher, wenn einem auffällt, dass Donald Trump konsequent schon seit Jahren Johnny nennt und Johnny Infantino ihn aber noch kein einziges Mal korrigiert hat. Aber bezüglich Ball-Knowledge hören wir uns mal kurz an, wie er sich, er hat was bekommen von Invertino.
Das hier ist die Trophäe der Siegenehrer. Die Trophäe, die die Siegenehrer der FIFA World Cup gewinnt. Nur die Vizepräsidenten der FIFA, die Vizepräsidenten der Länder, und dann diejenigen, die gewinnen, können es nicht fassen, weil es nur für Siegenehrer gibt. Und da du ein Siegenehrer bist, kannst du es auch nicht fassen, Das ist ziemlich schwer, das ist die Trophäe der Gewinnerin. Das letzte, das wir aufgelistet haben, ist Leo Messi, Leonardo Messi aus Argentinien. Und hier ist es, in der Oval Office, in der White House. Kann ich es behalten? Für dich. Na gut, du kannst es behalten.
Wir behalten es nicht.
Das ist ernsthaft.
Das passt sehr gut hier.
Das geht sehr gut auf die Wiese, direkt da drüben.
Wir legen es direkt unter den Echelon. Das passt gut hier.
Das ist wunderschön.
Ich war vor den Augen von Donald Trump. Donald Trump war davon so begeistert, weil Gold glitzert, alles toll, dass er sie ja tatsächlich bis zur Austragung des Turniers bei sich, auch bei anderen offiziellen Anlässen auf dem Schreibtisch stehen hatte. Und es gibt nach wie vor so die Verschwörungstheorie, dass er eigentlich sogar das Original dieses Pokals noch hat oder dieser Trophäe und Chelsea damals dann ein Replikat bekommen hätte, weil es ihm wohl wirklich sehr, sehr gut gefallen hat. Das Ganze hat aber neben der humoristischen und etwas schmerzhaften Seite aber dann doch noch eine weitere Implikation. Also wir alle haben mitbekommen, den Peace Prize, den Gianni Infantino als Nobelpreisersatz erfunden hat, als Friedensnobelpreisersatz, um ihn Donald Trump zu verleihen. Aber es gibt eigentlich so etwas wie ein Neutralitätsgebot, das nicht nur FIFA-Präsidenten, sondern der FIFA generell als Institution. Und darauf haben sie sich auch schon berufen. Ihr erinnert euch zum Beispiel an die One Love-Bindendiskussion 2022. Und dahingehend ist es dann schon interessant, wie Gianni Infantino, der eigentlich schon immer ganz gut darin ist, auch rhetorisch dann den richtigen Punkt zu treffen, der gerade noch okay sein sollte, in seiner Beziehung zu Donald Trump überschreitet er diesen Punkt immer wieder. Also von diesem FIFA Peace Prize zum Beispiel wusste, das 37-köpfige FIFA Council, der FIFA Rat wussten nichts von dieser Vergabe. Sie wurden einfach darüber informiert. Also das gibt es jetzt und wir machen das bei der WM-Auslosung der Gruppen. Und ich spiele euch noch einen letzten Gianni Infantino Ton vorerst nochmal ein. Der ist vom America Business Forum. Das hat im Winter 2025 stattgefunden, kurz vor der Gruppenauslosung. Und wir haben es vorhin schon mal in Schnipsel im Intro gehört. Deswegen will ich jetzt auch den ganzen O-Ton nochmal einspielen. Da hat sich Gianni Infantino so geäußert.
Ich habe eine tolle Beziehung. Ich bin sehr glücklich. Ich habe eine tolle Beziehung mit dem Präsidenten Trump, der ich wirklich als künftiges Freund kenne. Aber natürlich ist er sehr, sehr hilfreich in allem, was wir für die Weltcup tun. Er war der Präsident. Er hat es heute erwähnt, als die USA zusammen mit Kanada und Mexiko die Weltcup gewonnen haben. Er ist wirklich engagiert. Er hat eine so unglaubliche Energie. Das ist etwas, das ich wirklich erfreut. Er macht Dinge. Er tut, was er sagt. Er sagt, was er denkt. Er sagt auch, was viele Menschen denken, aber vielleicht auch nicht so gerne sagen. Deshalb ist er so erfolgreich. Ich muss sagen, dass ich manchmal etwas überrascht bin, wenn ich etwas negative Kommentare lese. Denn ich bin nicht amerikanisch, aber sobald ich es verstehe, war Präsident Trump in den USA gewählt. Er war ganz klar gewählt.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt das Wichtigste mitgenommen. Er lobt Donald Trump, ein ganz fantastischer Typ. Auch immer schon sehr, sehr gut. Und dann, hinten raus, wird es aber wirklich interessant. Er verteidigt Donald Trump gegen negative Kommentare. Er sagt, er wurde gewählt. Und er sagt, er wurde auf Basis eines Programms gewählt, das auf dem Fuß, was er sagte. Und er setzt einfach um, was er zu tun versprochen hat. Ich denke, wir sollten alle unterstützen, was er tut. Denn ich glaube, er macht ziemlich gute Arbeit. Und für die FIFA, er ist recht. Und sollte Gianni Infantino noch mal irgendwann stolpern, in der Zukunft, es wird ja weitere Wahlen zu FIFA-Präsidenten geben, er versucht gerade alles hinzudeikseln, dass er noch eine dritte Amtszeit bekommt, die erste sei er nicht vollständig gewesen, und so weiter und so fort. Über ein solches Zitat, wenn er stolpert, dann stolpert er darüber. Denn da hat er die politische Neutralität deutlich verlassen, und es ist auf Kamerabildern und in O-Tönen nachrückbar. Und deswegen wollte ich nämlich diesen O-Ton hier nochmal mitbringen, auch wenn es ein bisschen schwer zu ertragen ist, wie er sich da anbietet.
Man kann ja hoffen.
These von mir wird nicht passieren.
Danke, Arne.
Ja, aber also gehe ich tatsächlich mit, war auch mein erster Gedanke. Einfach weil gerade traut sich, glaube ich, auch niemand trotzdem so richtig gegen den Verdino Stimmung zu machen, oder innerhalb der Fieber, außer was man so hört. Und also haben wir zum Teil auch monatliche Panels schon besprochen. Aber meine Hoffnungen gehen da, ehrlich gesagt, auch gegen Donald Trump.
Es gibt einen, also nur ganz kurz, weil ich glaube, das ist eine Diskussion, die führen wir wahrscheinlich dann in zwei, drei Jahren auch eh nochmal. Alles entscheidet sich über Geld in der FIFA. Derjenige Präsident, der glaubhaft den Mitgliedsverbänden versichern kann, ihr bekommt mehr Geld, wenn ich an der Macht bin, der wird FIFA-Präsident. So einfach ist das. Und derjenige, der das glaubhafter machen kann, der gewinnt. Gianni Infantino läuft hier auf ein Problem zu. Schon jetzt war es so, dass er alle möglichen Dinge machen musste, um Geld zu generieren. Er wollte die kompletten Rechte an allen FIFA-Bildern verkaufen. Mit dem Einstieg der Softbank, das war so eine kleine Geschichte, wir haben es damals im Rasenfunk auch mal kurz angesprochen, hat damals auch alle überrascht im FIFA Council und ist damit aber gescheitert. Warum hat er das gemacht? Weil er eben einen Geldstrom gebraucht hat. Die TV-Rechte zur Club-Wm. Er ist sie auf Gedeih und Verderb nicht losgeworden. Wer hat ihm geholfen? Saudi-Arabien. Haben sie für eine Milliarde gekauft und der Zone gegeben, dass da das Ganze versendet wird. Natürlich auch, um die Wm zu bekommen. Aber auch die Club-Wm war nur deshalb ein Erfolg, weil er diese Milliarde noch irgendwie herbekommen hat. Und jetzt haben wir ein Drei-Länder-Wettbewerb, das von seiner ganzen Infrastruktur her gemacht ist für Geldverdienen. Eben auch, weil solche Dinge wie Dynamic Pricing möglich sind auf dem US-Markt. Schon bei der nächsten Weltmeisterschaft Spanien, Marokko und dann Uruguay, Paraguay, Argentinien wird es schwieriger werden, hier so viel Geld zu erzielen. Er wird aber immer mehr Geld brauchen. Und irgendwann wird aber dieser Zyklus, wird es mal nicht so einfach sein. Irgendwann hat er alles Tafel, Silber, verschabelt der FIFA und vielleicht lassen sich auch nicht mehr alle so über den Tisch ziehen. Und dann, wird sowas, glaube ich, virulent. Es wird immer übers Geld laufen. Aber es kann sein, dass das passiert. Und Gianni Infantino, der musste schon ganz schön, also er musste schon so Verzweiflungsschritte gehen. Es wird eben nur noch nicht ihm so ausgelegt. Ich würde es aber so durchaus interpretieren. Sorry, war doch ein längerer Monolog als ich wollte. Wollen wir mal kurz über Gianni Infantino schweigen? Ja, ich sehe Erleichterung in euren Augen und ich höre jetzt auch eine Stimme. Dann würde ich doch sagen, Gianni Infantino, gehen wir mal beiseite. Als nächstes schauen wir uns die politische Seite genauer an. Denn auch die Politik hat ja wirklich eine Rolle bei dieser Weltmeisterschaft. Und da wollen wir jetzt draufblicken. Vielleicht können wir hier sogar den USA-Part mal ein bisschen kleiner halten, denn ich glaube, darüber wisst ihr und wir schon am meisten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, kurz zur Einleitung noch mal eine etwas allgemeinere Hinführung. Also bei der WM-Vergabe damals, also im Jahr 2018, da nannte die Washington Post das Turnier noch den NAFTA World Cup, denn das NAFTA, das ist das nordamerikanische Freihandesabkommen, das eben zwischen Mexiko, den USA und Kanada schon seit Anfang bzw. Mitte der 90er existierte. Und das war auch deshalb eine treffende Bezeichnung, weil es so ein bisschen den Geist dieser Bewerbung wieder gespiegelt hat oder ihn geatmet hat, wenn man es so ausdrucken möchte. Denn diese Bewerbung hatte ja auch deshalb Erfolg, weil man sich eben zusammengetan hat, weil man nicht solitäre Einzelinteressen vertreten hat, sondern eben als eine, ein Anführungszeichen zumindest, Gemeinschaft aufgetreten ist. Was steht in diesem NAFTA-Protokoll drin? Wir müssen da, oder in diesem Freihandesabkommen, wir müssen da nicht tief reingehen, keine Sorge, aber es ist eben wichtig zu wissen, dass Freihandesabkommen in der Regel die Abschaffung oder Senkung von Zölle zwischen Ländern meint. Oft sind damit auch die Öffnung von Märkte betroffen und gleiche Standards, die angelegt werden sollen, im Patentrecht, im Sicherheitsrecht, im Lebensmittel- und Produkt-Sicherheit. Und dieses NAFTA-Agreement zwischen eben Kanada, den USA und Mexiko, das ist aber alles andere als unumstritten. Es war im Geist des Neoliberalismus entworfen, dementsprechend viel Privatisierung und so weiter und so fort, hat aber logischerweise auch Vor- und Nachteile für alle Beteiligten. Man schließt da einen Kompromiss. Also Kanada ist zum Beispiel durch dieses NAFTA auch, durch dieses NAFTA zu einer Exportnation geworden, hat aber dafür einige Umweltprobleme und einen ganz schönen Druck der Ölindustrie bekommen. Könnte man euch über Fracking und so weiter informieren in Bezug auf Kanada. Mexiko zum Beispiel wurde mit billigem Fleisch und Weizen aus den USA regelrecht überschwemmt. Und die sehr, sehr große Mais...
Und mit Handfeuerwaffen.
Und mit Handfeuerwaffen? Da weiß ich allerdings nicht, wie die Auswirkungen sind. Was ich bei den Agrarprodukten weiß, ist, dass die vorher wichtige Maisanbauindustrie, da wurden wirklich viele Maisbauern arbeitslos. Und auch einige davon sind dann sicherlich auch in den Drogenhandel mit reingekommen. Und die USA aber wiederum hatten auch zum Teil eben negative Auswirkungen des NAFTA-Abkommens. Also viele Industrie-Arbeitsplätze sind nach Mexiko abgewandert. Und generell wurde das Lohnniveau gedrückt, wobei das aus Sicht der Unternehmer nicht unbedingt etwas Schlechtes sein muss. Aber was ich damit eben sagen will, ist, es gibt dieses Freihandelsabkommen. Es war allerdings umstritten und das wurde auch neu verhandelt dann in den Jahren 2017 bis 18. Es hat einen neuen Namen bekommen. KUSMA kann man es nennen. Man kann es USMCA nennen. Aber es ist im Grunde nur ein andere Name für etwas sehr Ähnliches. Es geht jetzt um andere Produkte und um andere Zollregelungen. Aber dieses Abkommen besteht seitdem. Allerdings gibt es einen Termin, der innerhalb dieses Turnierliegs, und das ist nämlich der 1. Juli, und bis zu diesem Termin müssen die Handelsminister der drei beteiligten Nationen entschieden haben. Wollen wir dieses Abkommen, so wie es jetzt besteht, 16 Jahre lang noch weiterführen? Oder wollen wir es neu verhandeln? Dann muss jedes Jahr dieses Abkommen auf den Prüfstand kommen. Im Grunde würde damit der Sinn eines solchen Freihandelsabkommens nur ein bisschen unterwandert. Denn eigentlich möchten die beteiligten Industrien, die wollen ja Planungssicherheit haben. Und das ist alles noch überhaupt nicht klar, denn inzwischen hat sich die Lage zwischen den drei Ländern ganz eindeutig verschoben. Und das ist jetzt der Punkt, wo wir auch mit der WM ansetzen können. Wir wollen jetzt nacheinander mal auf die drei Gastgeber blicken und uns die Frage stellen, welche innenpolitischen und außenpolitischen Themen gibt es denn da aktuell? Und da werden wir eben feststellen, das bezieht sich immer auch so ein bisschen aufeinander und macht eben diese drei Länder WM wirklich zu einer besonderen WM. Und wir wollen da beginnen, Arne, mit Mexiko. Du hast dich den Mexikanerinnen und Mexikanern mal angenommen. Wir haben vorhin schon im Intro gehört. Donald Trump hat sich da logischerweise auch schon eingemischt. Wir wissen auch aus seiner ersten Amtszeit. Schon damals hat sich das Verhältnis zu Mexiko verschlechtert. Er wollte diesen Grenzschutzwall bauen lassen und sein Diktum war ja immer, Mexiko wird dafür bezahlen, wie auch immer er das genau dann umsetzen wollte. Jetzt haben wir Trump-Amtszeit 2 und eine alles andere als stabile Lage in Mexiko. Was ist denn da wichtig zu wissen?
Also innerhalb dieser drei Konstellationen, die jetzt die Wm ausrichten, ist es ja so, als würde man zu einer Geburtstagsfeier kommen und die Stimmung ist schon komplett im Keller. Also niemand kann mehr mit irgendjemand anderem was anfangen, alle haben irgendwie Stress untereinander und das ist, glaube ich, die Metapher dafür, um zu erklären, wie da die Stimmungslage gerade ist. Also die Wm wird daran nicht viel ändern, nicht in dem Verhältnis der drei Staaten miteinander. Und wenn wir auf Mexiko schauen, dann sind da natürlich erst mal oberflächlich so Dinge in Erinnerung, wie zum Beispiel, dass Trump angefangen hat, den Golf von Mexiko, Golf von Amerika zu nennen. Das war ja etwas, was natürlich auch Wellen geschlagen hat, aber was jetzt nicht direkt erst mal politische Konsequenzen nach sich gezogen hat. Ich glaube, der Kontinent an sich, Nordamerika, der steht genauso unter den Eindrücken dessen, was da jetzt passiert in der zweiten Amtszeit von Trump. Und das ist natürlich dann auch in Bezug auf Mexiko so. In dieser Amtszeit ist glaube ich ganz klar festzustellen, dass er die Daumenschrauben schon sehr stark angezogen hat im Verhältnis zu Mexiko. Also er hat immer wieder mit Strafzöllen gedroht. Er hat immer wieder zum Thema gemacht, dass er auf mexikanischen Terrain die organisierte Kriminalität bekämpfen möchte. Und das sorgt natürlich dann erst mal für ein schwieriges Verhältnis aus politischer Sicht. Und dementsprechend ist auch die mexikanische Präsidentin Claudia Scheinbaum von einer linksgerichteten Regierung da unter Druck, weil sie natürlich versuchen muss, ein halbwegs funktionales Verhältnis aufrechtzuerhalten, aber gleichzeitig in ihrem Land eben vermitteln muss, dass Mexiko souverän bleibt. Und ich meine, wir hatten ja in der Vergangenheit schon erlebt, dass es ein Problem ist, wenn Trump einen Militärschlag in einem fremden Land durchführen lässt, Beispiel Venezuela auch, da hat das ja auch stattgefunden. Und das auf mexikanischem Terrain ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Es zieht sich jetzt seit Monaten eben schon hin. Und das Hauptaugenmerk liegt für Trump tatsächlich darauf, dass er einerseits dafür sorgen möchte, dass die organisierte Kriminalität in den Griff bekommen wird. Und andererseits eben das, was du eben schon angesprochen hattest, dass er seine Migrationspolitik umsetzen kann, eben mit Hilfe dieser Mauer, mit Hilfe The Wall, mit Hilfe der ganzen hybriden Möglichkeiten, die es gibt, um da einen Grenzübergang eben zu verhindern. Und grundsätzlich, was auch in Erinnerung geblieben ist, jetzt aus den letzten Monaten ist ja eine Festnahme eines Drogenbosses, der gesucht war, El Mencho. Vielleicht erinnern sich noch einige daran. Ich glaube, bei dem Thema Drogenkartelle, da ist es meistens so, dass viele das erstmal so mit Popkultur assoziieren, so ein bisschen mit Breaking Bad vielleicht, was an der Grenze zwischen den USA und Mexiko auch teilweise gespielt hat oder bei Narcos auf Netflix. Das sind dann so Dinge, die da immer in Erinnerung kommen. Aber in Mexiko ist es tatsächlich so, dass die organisierte Kriminalität sehr, sehr viel bestimmt. Man geht davon aus, dass das so zwischen 180.000 und 190.000 Personen sind, die in diesem Bereich tätig sind. Da geht es natürlich um Drogen, um das Schmuggeln von Drogen, eben weil Mexiko da ein Transitland ist in die USA. Und dementsprechend taucht das Ganze dann natürlich auch immer wieder im politischen Kontext auf, weil die Macht des Kartells eben so groß ist, dass man in Mexiko nicht darum umhinkommt. Also, die Macht des Kartells ist quasi der erste Großaspekt, mit dem man sich auseinandersetzen muss. Und ich glaube, du hast ja da auch tatsächlich einen O-Ton dabei, wenn ich mich richtig aneinander...
Ja, er ist ein bisschen schwer auszuhalten, aber er zeigt in der Art und Weise, wie hier Donald Trump spricht, wie schwierig auch die Lage für die Präsidentin Scheinbaum ist. Und ich habe leider keine O-Töne von ihr, weil ich davon ausgehen muss, dass nicht so viele Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer Spanisch verstehen. Deswegen... Aber wir hören mal, was Donald Trump gesagt hat. Er rambelt dann irgendwann so vor sich hin. Es ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Wir müssen den Epizentrum der Kartellwahl in Mexiko erinnern. Die mexikanischen Kartellwahl sind füllen und viel Blutsched und Chaos in dieser Hemisphäre. Das United States-Germany wird alles tun, was es notwendig ist, um unsere Nationalsicherheit zu verteidigen und die Sicherheit der amerikanischen Menschen zu verhindern. Es kommt alles durch Mexiko, und ich mag den Präsidenten sehr viel. Sie ist eine sehr gute Person. Sie hat eine schöne Stimme, eine schöne Frau, aber eine schöne Stimme. Präsident, Präsident, Präsident. Ich sagte mir, dass ich die Kartellwahl erraten.
Das meiste werdet ihr verstanden haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Also, Mexiko wird von den Kartellen regiert, sagt Präsident Trump. Und er sagt, das ist zu nah an uns dran. Die ganzen Probleme, sie kommen aus Mexiko. Und deswegen werden wir unsere Sicherheit in Mexiko verteidigen. Und dann imitiert er noch die Präsidentin in einer wirklich erniedrigenden Art und Weise. Aber das zeigt ja auch Arne gleichzeitig dann zusammen genommen mit eben dem Wissen, dass dieser Schlaggeben, Mencho, ja auch unter anderem mit Geheimdienstinformationen der USA durchgeführt sein soll, worden soll. Zumindest hat Scheinbarm auch gesagt, dass sie darüber mit Trump auch telefoniert habe. In welcher absurden Situation eigentlich sie als Präsidentin steckt. Denn die Probleme sind da und sie sind wahr. Ob sie so sind, wie Donald Trump sie darstellt, ist dann eine Interpretationsfrage. Gleichzeitig müssen sie adressiert werden und bringt sie aber dann auch in eine Zwickmühle zwischen den Interessen einmal die Kartelle im eigenen Land und einmal der US-Präsident über die Grenze hinweg.
Wie schwierig das ist im Verhältnis mit den USA. Das weiß die EU, das weiß Deutschland, das weiß Friedrich Merz. Das ist immer ein Lavieren zwischen dem, was möglich ist und dem, was dann irgendwann gefährlich werden könnte. Ich glaube, die innenpolitische Doktrin von Shane Maum ist es zu sagen, wir regeln unsere Probleme hier selbst als souveräner Staat. Wenn hier irgendwas zu tun ist, dann machen wir das. Es waren ja auch mexikanische Streitkräfte und Behörden, die das Ganze letztendlich umgesetzt haben. Die Festnahme und dann auch die Tötung, die da mit einherging von diesem Drogenboss. Der Druck aus den USA sorgt natürlich dann gleichzeitig dafür, dass man da immer nicht ganz sicher sein kann, was als Nächstes passiert. Denn das Außenpolitische Handeln von Donald Trump ist erratisch und kann plötzlich Dinge auf einmal hervorrufen, mit denen keiner so richtig gerechnet hat. Aber trotzdem ist eine Einmischung in die Politik eines Staates, natürlich eines anderen Staates, noch mal was ganz anderes. Fakt ist aber auch, das hattest du ja gerade schon erwähnt, das Thema lässt sich nicht vom Tisch weisen. Es ist Fakt, dass gewisse Städte in Mexiko, gewisse Regionen, da schon ziemlich stark in der Hand von Kartellen sind oder Syndikaten oder kleineren Gruppen, ich glaube, über die genauen Organisationsstrukturen des organisierten Verbrechens und der organisierten Kriminalität. Da kenne ich mich jetzt A, selber nicht so gut aus und B, würde das auch, glaube ich, den Rahmen sprengen. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall jeden Tag irgendeine Form von Schreckensnachricht aus Mexiko. Es gibt jeden Tag Ermordungen, es gibt jeden Tag Gewalt und das war ja dann auch Ende Februar der Fall, als El Mencho getötet wurde, gab es ja innerhalb des Landes dann viele Blockaden, angezündete Autos. Das ganze Land kam mehr oder weniger zum Stillstand. In einzelnen Städten und Regionen waren die Schulen und Unis zu eben auf Grundlage dieser Vergeltungsmaßnahmen des Kartells. Und das hat dann natürlich im Februar schon die Frage aufgeworfen, ob Mexiko überhaupt in der Lage sein würde, eine sichere Weltmeisterschaft mit den 13 Spielen, die in dem Land stattfinden sollen, zu garantieren. Und dafür ist es natürlich auch wichtig, sich erst mal anzuschauen, wie ist denn die Situation selber in den Städten, die dann die Spiele austragen. Also grundsätzlich ist es so, Mexiko Stadt als Hauptstadt, mit dem, denke ich, bekannten Azteken-Stadion, das ist natürlich eine andere Lage als jetzt beispielsweise in Guadalajara, wo eben das Kartell von El Mencho quasi in rechtsfreien Räumen agieren kann. Und dort in der Region Jalisco, oder Jalisco, ich muss mich entschuldigen für mein Schuhspanisch, da ist die Lage eben anders als jetzt in einer Großstadt, wo ohnehin mit vielen Touristen immer zu rechnen ist, also in dem Fall der Hauptstadt. Und dementsprechend ist es jetzt nicht davon auszugehen, dass die Kartelle die Wm für ihre Zwecke nutzen werden, um da auf sich Aufmerksamkeit, auf sich heranzuziehen oder eben dafür zu sorgen, dass sie selber mehr scheinwerferlich bekommen. Davon geht eigentlich von den Sicherheitsexperten dort niemand aus. Es ist eher so, dass sie das für ihre wirtschaftlichen Zwecke nutzen, denn es geht ja nicht nur um Drogen, es geht ja auch noch um andere Art und Weisen, um an Geld zu kommen und dementsprechend erwartet da die drei Vertragungsstädte, Verzeihung in dem Fall auch noch Monterey. Eine große Herausforderung mit vielen Sicherheitskräften, die das eben umsetzen sollen, weil es für Claudia Schembaum und ihre Regierung eben auch wichtig ist, zu zeigen, das kann bei uns stattfinden. Unsere Städte sind sicher und wir können hier die anderen Länder mit ihren Gästen, mit ihren Spielern empfangen, mit den Fans. Aber gleichzeitig weiß man nie so genau, was macht das Kartell, was macht eine bestimmte Gruppe, ein bestimmtes Syndikat an einzelnen Orten. Das heißt also, in dieser Gemengelage möchte Mexiko diese Weltmeisterschaft ausrichten. Und das ist ja grundsätzlich schon mal im Vergleich zu den USA nicht ganz unähnlich, weil dort weiß man ja auch nicht genau, was ICE während des Turniers in einzelnen Städten machen wird.
Das ist aber vermutlich noch mal eine andere Art der Bedrohung. Und natürlich, wir sind jetzt nicht die Mexiko Expertinnen und Experten, auch wenn wir uns eingelesen haben. Ich werde auch noch meinen sehr guten Weltspiegel-Podcast dazu verlinken, den ich erst heute dazu noch gehört habe. Aber was ist denn so deine Einschätzung, wie wackelig ist denn die Durchführung dieses Turniers und kann dann die Wm auch tatsächlich einen positiven Effekt für Mexiko haben? Denn die Bilder nach der Ermordung von El Mencho, die wären auch so um die Welt gegangen, wahrscheinlich ohne die Weltmeisterschaft. Jetzt gibt es aber ja die Möglichkeit, andere Bilder zu senden. Jürgen hat offenbar da auch eine Meinung zu.
Keine Meinung zu dem, was jetzt gerade von Max kam, sondern nur wollte die Frage reinwerfen, ob du auch bei deinen Recherchen auf den Kontext Drogenkartelle und Fußball in Mexiko geschaut hast. Ich habe gerade mal nur eine ganz sporadische Google-Suche gemacht und festgestellt, es gibt einige Anhaltspunkte dafür, wie die Fußball benutzen als Geldwäscheinstitution oder auch vielleicht als wie auch immer einflussnehmend auf irgendwelche anderen Zwecke. Ich glaube, dass das gerade auch für Rasenfunk-Hörer interessant wäre zu hören, wie nah das auch am Fußball dran ist.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich kann jetzt nicht tief drauf eingehen, weil das glaube ich den Rahmen sprengt, aber gewiss ist es so, dass im Vereinsfußball, das kennen wir auch aus anderen Ländern tatsächlich, organisierte Kriminalität immer präsent sein kann, wenn es das denn möchte. Und der Fußball an sich ist jetzt aber nicht der größte Hebel, so meine These für die Kartelle, also jetzt auch die Weltmeisterschaft an sich nicht. Und ich glaube, die Herangehensweise von einem Land wie Mexiko ist dann logischerweise zu sagen, wir wollen uns nach außen hin so präsentieren, dass wir garantieren können, alles hier ist sicher, alles hier ist gut. Dafür werden jetzt, das liest sich eigentlich überall, ungefähr 100.000 Sicherheitskräfte mobilisiert, teilweise staatlich, teilweise eben auch privat durch Sicherheitsfirmen. Und das ist schon eine ganze Menge. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es sind nur 13 Spiele, die in Mexiko stattfinden werden. Am 5. Juli ist die Party auch schon wieder vorbei, weil dann glaube ich kein Achtelfinale mehr dort stattfinden wird. Oder ein Achtelfinale ist es glaube ich nur und danach ist auch schon wieder Ende. Und ich habe viele Berichte mir angeschaut im Vorfeld, wo gezeigt wurde, welche Technologie da verwendet wird. Drohnen und irgendwelche Roboterhunde, die dann sich in gewisse Gebiete fortbewegen können und so. Also da wird schon sehr, sehr viel unternommen. Und das ist ja natürlich auch auf eine gewisse Art und Weise die Pflicht der Regierung zu zeigen. Wir sind dazu in der Lage, ob das jetzt einen positiven Effekt haben wird, lässt sich heute nur schwer beantworten. Ich denke mal, was das Verhältnis zu den USA angeht, wird sich jetzt auch durch die Weltmeisterschaft nicht viel ändern. Die Gräben, die da existieren, die werden dadurch nicht zugeschüttet werden. Und auch die Probleme innerhalb des Landes werden sich dadurch nicht lösen. Ich denke mal, was auch thematisiert werden wird und was man jetzt auch gerade in der Berichterstattung schon häufiger mitbekommt, ist so die soziale Lage im Land. Es gibt Proteste, die auf dem zentralen Platz in Mexiko stattfinden von unterschiedlichsten Gruppen. Dann gibt es Lehrkräfte, die mehr Lohn fordern und dementsprechend dort protestieren. Dann gibt es ein sehr, sehr großes Thema, was ein riesiges Trauma auch ist für Mexiko. Und zwar sind das die 130.000 verschwundenen Personen. Also zu großen Teilen eben aus den Drogenkriegen sind diese Personen verschwunden und niemand weiß so richtig, wo diese Personen sind. Seit Jahren suchen Angehörige da nach den Gebeinen der Personen und kümmern sich eben darum, dass sie dann nochmal würdig trauern können. Und auch da gibt es zahllose Beispiele. Das lässt sich auch googeln über solche Berichte, sich das anzuschauen. Wenn dann ein Vater seinen Sohn sucht, der vor sieben, acht Jahren mal irgendwo gesehen worden ist und dann eben abtransportiert wurde von irgendwelchen Schergen eines Kartells und der Vater sucht die Knochen quasi immer noch, dann gibt es immer wieder neue Hinweise und der Vater geht dem Ganzen nach. Jetzt, wie gesagt, schon seit Jahren und der Vater sagt dann in dem Beitrag, es war vom ZDF jetzt kürzlich, dass er mittlerweile erkennen kann, wenn er einen Knochen findet, zu welchem Teil des Körpers dieser Knochen gehört und ob das vielleicht ein tierischer Knochen ist oder ein menschlicher Knochen. Auch die Personen, die da suchen nach ihren Angehörigen, schon seit langer Zeit, das sind ja erstmal sehr, sehr viele. Und zweitens haben die natürlich auch einen sehr, sehr großen Drang, dass die Regierung sie dabei unterstützt. Aber das ist weder durch Polizei noch durch Staatsanwaltschaft großartig der Fall. Da gibt es in vielerlei Regionen auch dort konkrete Verbindungen zur organisierten Kriminalität, sodass da von staatlicher Seite aus auch nicht viel aufgearbeitet wird. Und dementsprechend kommt es dort auch immer wieder zu Protesten in Mexikostadt, weil das ebenso die größte Bühne ist im Rahmen der Hauptstadt. Sodass ich glaube, dass solche Sachen sich während der Weltmeisterschaft schon wiederholen werden. Das haben wir jetzt auch in den vergangenen Tagen gesehen, dass dort immer wieder das Augenmerk auf diesen Platz gerichtet ist, um zu schauen, wer protestiert denn da gerade. Aber gleichzeitig ist natürlich die Frage, in welche Art von Protesten und welche Art von Demonstrationen, auch in welchem Umfang, werden denn dazugelassen. Weil das ist ja auch bekannt aus der Geschichte der Weltmeisterschaften, dass das jetzt in den einzelnen Austragungsorten nicht immer unbedingt so der Fall gewesen ist. Von daher ist das eine interessante Frage, wie viel dann letztendlich an Protesten stattfindet und was sich dann daran auch ändern wird nach der WM.
Von mir kommt noch ein kleiner Aspekt. Eine Besonderheit ist, und vielleicht lässt sich das hier anschließen, dass wir, ich habe gerade mal nachgeschaut, mindestens zehn Millionen in Mexiko geborene Menschen, die in den USA leben. Das ist auf jeden Fall die größte Einwanderergruppe, also aus denen, die nicht in den USA geboren sind. Das hat kulturelle Einflüsse, aber natürlich auch gilt im Fußball die Besonderheit, dass Mexikaner eben sehr fußballaffin sind, im Unterschied zu den anderen in den USA lebenden Menschen. Sodass man eigentlich bei diesem Aspekt drei Länder auch noch dieses Brückenphänomen hat. Es ist schwer, in den Griff zu kriegen, weil man würde ja sagen, die Menschen leben in den USA. Also ist das eigentlich eher ein USA-bezogenes Thema. Aber ich glaube, das überlappt sich auch ganz eigenartig. Und es gibt ein interessantes Detail, dass in den letzten Jahren, also ich habe das damals, als Deutschland gegen Mexiko gespielt hat in den USA, auf der ersten Auslandsreise von Nagelsmann, habe ich das mal recherchiert und darüber geschrieben, dass die überwiegende Teil der mexikanischen Nationalmannschaftsspiele, die sie frei irgendwie stattfinden lassen können, die Hauptsächlich in den USA stattfinden. In größeren Stadien, als man sie in Mexiko haben kann. Und wo man natürlich auch, weil die Tickets in den USA zu höheren Preisen verkaufen kann, auch der mexikanische Verband in den USA erstaunliche Einnahmen generiert hat. Und noch als weiterer Aspekt, es gibt auch ein sehr starkes spanischsprachiges Fernsehen in den USA, das sich auch total auf Fußball und auch Mexiko-Themen eingeschossen hat. Also diese, und das wird von Leuten wie Trump nicht nur ignoriert, sondern quasi weggeschoben, dass es da eben noch andere Facetten gibt, die also eine über die Grenzen gehende Veranstaltung irgendwie auch auch rausarbeiten könnte und positiv darstellen könnte. Völkerfreundschaft, Völkerverständigung. Etwas, was wir aufgrund dieser Trumpschen Politik ja gegen Ausländer, gegen Einwanderer und so natürlich nicht haben. Also wir grenzen gerade das ab. Na ich wollte nur sagen, Sonderfall. Mexiko und USA sind auch nochmal anders irgendwie aneinander angedockt. Nicht nur über die Drogen und über Kartelle und so weiter.
Ja, da hätte Trump nur mal die eigene Bewerbung lesen müssen. Also macht er natürlich nicht viel zu viele Worte und Seiten, viel zu wenige Bilder. Aber da wurde das natürlich rauf und runter strapaziert und zeigt ja aber auch nochmal, Arne, wie schwierig eben auch das Navigieren in diesem Verhältnis ist. Also wir haben jetzt über, wir sind über innenpolitische Themen gekommen. Dazu kommt sicherlich auch noch, dass die FIFA WM auch in Mexiko ein Symbol ist, nämlich ein Symbol der wirtschaftlichen Ungleichheit. Also die Tickets sind so teuer, das können sich normale Mexikanerinnen und Mexikaner gar nicht mehr leisten. Da geht zum Teil der Preis eines Tickets ist dann ein Jahreseinkommen. Also es ist dort auch ein Festival der Reichen. Vielleicht muss man auch da vor diesem Hintergrund verstehen, dass Scheinbaum eben nicht beim Eröffnungsspiel im Stadion sein will, sondern eben auf dem Platz in Mexiko-Stadt, auf dem Fanplaza. Zumindest aktuell sagt sie, dass da mit den normalen Fans feiern möchte. Aber das andere eben neben diesen innenpolitischen Dingen sind ja dann auch ein außenpolitisches Navigieren. Also wir haben den Fall des iranischen Fußballteams, das eben nicht einreisen darf in die USA. Und Scheinbaum akzeptiert dann, dass dieses Team in Mexiko sein neues Basecamp aufmachen darf. Gleichzeitig haben wir im Fall von Kuba eine andere Nation, die von Trump ganz offensichtlich bedroht wird, die wiederum Hilfslieferungen aus Mexiko bekommt. Also immer wieder so ein Navigieren am Rand zwischen quasi Souveränität und aber auch Appeasement gegenüber Donald Trump.
Ja, Appeasement ist das eine. Das andere ist eben aber auch die politische Realität, die harte politische Realität eben auch im Verhältnis zur Administration von Donald Trump, weil ja dort, das hatten wir eben auch schon, quasi seit zehn Jahren mit dieser Mauerpolitik gemacht wird. Also Mexiko soll die bezahlen und wir bauen die jetzt hier über, ich weiß nicht, wie lang die Grenze ist, tatsächlich auf dem Landweg und über Wasser wahrscheinlich schon so dreieinhalbtausend Kilometer oder so. Wir bauen das jetzt und da kommt niemand mehr rüber und es ist natürlich klar, dass das in der US-amerikanischen Geschichte schon mal der Fall war, dass ein US-Präsident dafür gesorgt hat, Mexikanerinnen und Mexikaner zurückzuschicken. Das war vor 70 Jahren Dwight D. Eisenhower, weil der hat auch dafür gesorgt, dass Menschen, die in die USA gekommen sind, um zu arbeiten, das teilweise jahrelang getan haben, die wurden dann auch deportiert zurück nach Mexiko. Das heißt, es ist jetzt nichts Neues in dem Sinne, was Trump da jetzt auch mit Hilfe von ICE umsetzen kann, weil sich da auch heute tausende Menschen mit mexikanischem Hintergrund in Abschiebehaft befinden und dann wahrscheinlich zeitnah abgeschoben werden sollen. Das zieht sich so ein bisschen durch das ganze Verhältnis zwischen den USA und Mexiko. Jürgen hatte das eben schon richtigerweise gesagt. Viel an Fußballkultur, was existiert in den USA, ist eben durch Migrantinnen und Migranten gekommen. Das betrifft natürlich die lateinamerikanischen Länder, das betrifft natürlich Mexiko. Und trotzdem ist es innerhalb der US-Außenpolitik gerade so, dass da einfach mal, mir nichts, dir nichts, der Kongress beschließt, weitere 46 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung zu stellen, um eben die Grenzübergänge zuzumachen zwischen Mexiko und den USA. Währenddessen eben Millionen Menschen mit mexikanischem Hintergrund, teilweise in den USA geboren, das Land am Laufen halten in den USA. Und vor dem Hintergrund auch nochmal zu sagen, wir richten gemeinsam eine Weltmeisterschaft aus, das ist natürlich schon ein sehr schwieriges Feld, auf das sich beide da begeben haben. Aber gleichzeitig ist natürlich dann immer die Frage, wie geht die Regierung in Mexiko damit um? Das ist ja jetzt auch für Scheinbaum nicht das erste Mal so. Oder ihre Regierung ist mit dem Thema nicht zum ersten Mal konfrontiert. Da geht es natürlich immer um dieses Abwägen, welchen Schritt gehen wir auf die USA zu? Wo ziehen wir einen Strich? Das ist wie gesagt im ganzen transatlantischen Verhältnis zwischen Europa und den USA schon schwierig genug. Und dann vor Ort an Orten wie Tiroana zum Beispiel, wo jetzt das iranische Nationalteam unterkommt, das ist eben die harte Realität dort. Und die Propaganda der US-Regierung, die ist natürlich da teilweise wirklich erschütternd und schockierend, weil vor einigen Tagen da eine Webseite veröffentlicht worden ist, in erstmal einer Form und dann in einem Text, der wirklich einen schaudern lässt. Ja, das kann ich gar nicht anders sagen. Da ging es darum, dass eben die US-Regierung seit 60 Jahren, ich zitiere mal eben, seit 60 Jahren ein streng gehütetes Geheimnis bewahrt, Außerirdische sind unter uns gewandelt, haben in unsere Nachbarschaften gelegt und mit uns in unserem Alltag interagiert. Mit diesen Außerirdischen, auf Englisch Aliens, sind nicht die Aliens gemeint, die man jetzt erstmal mit ET usw. assoziieren würde, sondern Migranten. Und das ist eine Art und Weise der Auseinandersetzung, die wirklich schon, ja, menschenverachtend ist, die da so ein bisschen der ganze Nährboden und quasi der Grundstock ist an dem Verhältnis zwischen Mexiko und den USA.
Und was wäre jetzt dann deine vorläufige Bilanz dieser ganzen Situation? Also wie reagiert da der Fußball darauf? Und was erwartest du dir jetzt dann eben von diesen drei Wochen, die wir da Fußball in Mexiko sehen werden?
Es hilft sicherlich, Polizeipräsenz zu zeigen. Es hilft sicherlich, Sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu präsentieren und umzusetzen. Also es hilft jetzt nicht mir, aber es hilft im Verhältnis zu Donald Trump. Und natürlich dann auch zur Weltöffentlichkeit generell, um eben zeigen zu können, wir sind sicher, wir haben die Lage hier im Griff. Beispielsweise gab es Anfang März auf dem zentralen Platz in Mexiko statt ein riesiges Konzert mit Shakira. Das war kostenfrei. Da waren auch hunderttausende Menschen. Und danach hat sich Scheinbaum hingestellt und gesagt, schau doch mal, es gab keine Vorfälle, alles ist sicher, alles ist gut. Sich als vorbereitet zu präsentieren und das dann auch durchzuführen, wird sicherlich dafür sorgen, dass es sicher für Gäste ist. Aber es wird weiterhin riskant für die Einheimischen sein. Viele Orts, ob das jetzt in Guadalajara ist oder in Gegenden auf dem Land. Ich glaube, das wird die Realität bleiben, dass Drogenkartelle da eine große Rolle spielen. Gleichzeitig die sozialen Probleme, Ungleichheit, die Verschwundenen, die wir eben erwähnt hatten, dass da weiterhin Protestaktionen stattfinden werden. Die Frage ist natürlich, was ändert sich dann langfristig? Weil solange der Staat, vertreten durch Kommunen, Staatsanwaltschaft, Polizei nicht den Problemen auf den Grund geht, ändert sich auch durch 13 Spiele einer FIFA-Weltmeisterschaft nichts ändern.
Dabei gäbe es ja auch die Positivgeschichten. Mexiko ist immer noch ein Land des Tourismus. Das funktioniert ja auch in diesen Regionen sehr gut. Mexiko hat eine Fußballkultur. Mexiko hat eben auch diese breite Geschichte an auch Menschen mit mexikanischen Wurzeln, die nicht mehr in Mexiko leben. Donald Trump sieht das natürlich anders, aber du kannst das ja auch als eine schöne Geschichte erzählen. Jürgen hat ja vorhin schon darauf hingewiesen, welche ungeahnten Folgen das dann eben hat, dass du eben in den USA mit Ländern spielen mehr Geld verdienen kannst als in Mexiko selbst. Also es ist schon, man würde sich wünschen, dass was Danitin Fantino und so manche andere im Fußball immer vom Fußball behauptet, es wäre ein bisschen wahrer, denn dann würde man es ja in so einer Situation wahrscheinlich bei Mexiko sehen. Vielleicht werde ich aber auch genau davon überzeugt. Vielleicht werden das jetzt einfach drei unbeschwertere Wochen für die dort lebenden Menschen. Sicher bin ich mir da allerdings nicht. Wir werden sehen. Also das ist die Situation in Mexiko. Jetzt wollen wir mal nach Kanada blicken. Eva, jetzt geht es ein bisschen um andere Themen. Wie ist denn dort die Lage mit Blick auf die Innen- und Außenpolitik eben in Zusammenhang mit der WM?
Ich dachte, ich hole euch erstmal alle so ein bisschen ab, weil ich bin ehrlich, als ich mich angefangen habe, damit zu beschäftigen, dachte ich erstmal so, ah perfekt, ich weiß sehr wenig über Kanada und was da eigentlich gerade so los ist. Ich dachte, ich bringe euch einfach am Anfang mal so ein paar einführende Facts mit, auch im Vergleich vielleicht zu den anderen beiden Ländern. Prinzipiell ist Kanada als Land bekannt, dass politische Rechte und bürgerliche Freiheiten achtet. Also mit politischen Rechten ist nicht Rechtspartei genannt, sondern wirklich die Rechte von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern. Laut Freedom House im Global Freedom Point System liegen die bei 97 von 100 Punkten. Deutschland zum Beispiel im Vergleich 95 von 100. Die USA bei 81 von 100 und Mexiko bei 58 von 100. Freedom House ist ein US-amerikanischer Think Tank. Also da ja auch nicht ganz unkritisch zu sehen, das nur zur Einordnung, aber trotzdem vielleicht einmal, weil es per se trotzdem ein System ist, was immer wieder genutzt wird. Es gibt eine parlamentarische Demokratie und gleichzeitig aber eben auch eine konstitutionelle Monarchie mit King Charles III als Staatsoberhaupt. Kurz ins Gedächtnis rufen. Aber er ist natürlich nur nach außen, sag ich mal, und hat innen, also gerichtlich oder gesetzlich einfach nichts zu sagen. Es gibt halt eben noch einen Generalgouverneur, das ist Mary Simon, als Vertreterin. Genau. Und sonst ist Prime Minister ist Mark Carney. Den Namen haben wir heute schon mal gehört. Er ist Mitglied der Liberal Party of Canada, wurde 2025 Nachfolger von Justin Trudeau, ebenfalls Liberal Party. Ich bringe kurz noch mal mein Pop-Culture-Wissen hier rein. Er ist der Freund von Katy Perry.
Nein. Oh nein.
Ich dachte, ich draw einfach mal. Ich bin ja heute so ein bisschen für die Pop-Culture-Elemente verantwortlich. Vielleicht Trudeau.
Verbringe meine Katy Perry Platten.
Hast du dich nicht schon nach ihrem Jeff Bezos Flug ins All verbrannt mit der Bekanntgabe der Tracklist ihres neuen Albums?
Also, ja.
Jürgen. Gut, wieder zurück nach Kanada.
Genau. Also nur vielleicht da auch als Hintergrund. Trudeau, der tritt 2025 zurück, nach fast zehn Jahren als Premierminister. Der war seit 2013 Chef der Liberal Party, gab dann zum Schluss in seiner eigenen Partei, aber auch in der Bevölkerung immer wieder Stimmung gegen ihn. Die Liberal Party hatte lange vor allem die Stimmen der jüngeren Kanadierinnen verloren. Und zum Beispiel in Trumps erster Amtszeit, ich bin zu mir leid, auch hier muss dieser Name leider auftauchen, war zum Beispiel Trudeaus Regierung vor allem darum bemüht, das NAFTA-Agreement, von dem wir eben schon mal was gehört haben, aufrechtzuerhalten. 2017 war Trudeau erst noch sehr bekannt für seine offene Migrationspolitik und so eine sehr Welcoming Culture, sag ich mal. Hat dann aber die Einschränkungen an der US-Kanada-Grenze erhöht, auch weil es Druck von rechtsregierten Bundesländern gab. Kommen wir wieder zurück zu Kani. Der hat inzwischen ein ganz gutes Approval-Rating, wie man so sagt, liegt bei 61 Prozent. Ein Approval-Rating, von dem Friedrich Merz nur träumen kann im Vergleich. Generell sagt er zum Beispiel, dass Kanada einer der europäischsten, aller nicht europäischen Staaten sei. Und zum Beispiel gibt es eine Umfrage der Tageszeitung in Kanada von The Globe and Mail. Da wollen knapp 60 Prozent der Kanadierinnen, ganz oder eher, dass ihr Land der EU beitritt. Also es wäre, tatsächlich gibt es so Gedankenspiele, komme ich gleich vielleicht noch mal zu. Wir hatten eben bei den USA schon mal das Thema, dass ja beziehungsweise viele EinwanderInnen, auch das ist in Kanada der Fall, 23 Prozent der kanadischen Bevölkerung sind Einwanderer, Großteil davon aus Asien. Ich kann in dem Zuge vielleicht schon mal empfehlen, es gibt von The Globe and Mail eine ganz schöne Geschichte zur Wm und vor allem auch zu den beiden Spielorten, Vancouver und Toronto. Gerade Toronto gilt als sehr offene Stadt, als sehr multikulturelle Stadt. Da haben sie beispielsweise The S-Planet, also es ist so ein Bezirk, ganz viele Geschichten von den unterschiedlichen Teilnehmerländern und immer mit Menschen, die aus diesen Teilnehmerländern kommen und in Toronto leben gemacht. Also so Fotos einfach mit denen und da irgendwie ein Zitat runtergelegt, also um eben da diese Willkommenskultur und auch diese Multikulturellität in Kanada und Toronto zu beschreiben. Zu Innenpolitik vielleicht, ganz interessant, weil das tatsächlich schon so ein bisschen zur Außenpolitik überleitet. Im November hat Albertas Ministerin, Jenny Smith von der United Conservative Party einen Gesetzesentwurf vorgelegt, der die Notstandsklausel nutzen soll, um drei verschiedene Gesetzesvorlagen vor rechtlichen Anfechtungen zu schützen. Und da geht es vor allem um die Rechte von Transgender Jugendlichen. Und die sollen eben, ja, sollen das eben einschränken. Und mit dieser Notstandsklausel soll eben das dagegen im Prinzip nicht geklagt werden können, beziehungsweise die nicht eingeschränkt werden können. Das wird nicht so wahnsinnig gut eingenommen in in Kanada, vor allem eben bei queeren Gruppen. Das vielleicht dazu, dass auch das ein Problem in in Kanada ist, was man vielleicht eher nicht so mitbekommen hat. Aber das größere Thema ist tatsächlich, dass auch in Alberta BewohnerInnen im Oktober darüber abstimmen, ob sie weiterhin zu Kanada gehören wollen. Oder ein zweites Referendum darüber entscheiden wird, dass sie das Land verlassen. Und das wird vor allem von Separatisten unter der Bewegung Stay Free Alberta nach vorne getrieben. Die hatten die nötigen Unterschriften oder sehr viel mehr, über 300.000 für eine Referendung mal eingereicht. Und da kommt jetzt der Punkt, der so ein bisschen zur Außenpolitik überreicht. Diese Separatisten stehen vor allem der Trump-Regierung nah und gelten immer als rechtskonservativ. Und es gibt aber eben aus Alberta vor allem von First Nations, also das ist einer von drei indigenen Völkerstämmen in Kanada. Ja, dass die da sehr viel protestieren, weil sie sagen, sie wollen diese Referendung verhindern, also dass gar nicht erst drüber abgestimmt wird, weil sie das als Vertragsbruch sehen. Also man muss schon sagen, im Gegensatz vielleicht zu Amerika, erkennt Kanada schon an, dass man mit den indigenen Völkern jetzt nicht so ganz sauber mitgespielt hat. Also da versucht man eben durch Treaties und Co., da mehr reinzugehen und mehr auf Abstimmung zu gehen. Aber so ganz sauber ist das Verhältnis logischerweise noch nicht. Und das sind dann natürlich so Punkte, die das Ganze ein wenig mehr in Unstimmigkeiten bringen.
Ich möchte mich da aber kurz zu einer Zeitwort melden, weil der letzte Stand, ich weiß jetzt nicht von wann deine Informationen sind, ist das also über eine gerichtliche Entscheidung, der versucht, dieses Referendum auch nur auf die Tagesordnung zu bekommen, also anzusetzen, ist also von dem Gericht, das da angerufen wurde und von den indigenen Gruppen hauptsächlich, aber auch von anderen Kanadier angerufen wurde, ist gekippt worden. Also es wird kein Referendum geben. Und die Logik ist, dass man um solche politischen Projekte wie ein Referendum überhaupt nur auf die Tagesordnung setzen zu können, die indigenen Menschen auch fragen muss vorher. Also da gibt es einen Prozess, in dem das alles stattfinden kann. Das ist jetzt zu schwierig, das zu erklären. Aber das heißt also, die Recht, du hast das ja in einer Richtung ja schon angeregt, also der rechtliche Status für die indigenen Menschen in Kanada ist deutlich stärker. Und wird auch, wenn ich jetzt richtig informiert bin, sogar in der Verfassung, die ja relativ frisch ist in Kanada, weil das Land erst sehr spät wirklich in diese volle Selbstständigkeit gekommen ist, erst vor ein paar Jahrzehnten ist das auch mit eingearbeitet worden. Und das nur jetzt als kleiner Hinweis. Ja, die die die die Separatisten in Alberta Nummer eins sind nicht konservativ. Das sind wirklich rechte, neo-naziartige White Supremacists. Zweitens, die hatten ihre eigene Partei. Aber diese Frau, die jetzt dort als sogenannte Premier die Regierung führt in Alberta, versucht diese politischen Beströmungen in ihrer Politik rein zu holen. Das heißt, die spielt also doppelbödig Spiele. Und noch als letzte Anmerkung für die Kanadier ist die Frage der Selbstauflösung existenziell. Sie haben also mit dem französisch-sprachigen Teil Quebec jahrzehntelang zu tun gehabt. Die Quebecois wollten aus Kanada raus, haben dann aber auch selber in Abstimmungen sich dann dagegen entschieden. Aber es ist immer auch ein sehr wackeliges Thema gewesen. Und wenn jetzt woanders noch wieder was aufbricht, wie jetzt in Alberta, macht das die Leute, die nicht in Alberta wohnen, sehr nervös. Das ist ein Druck auf diese innere, was ist Kanada, wer ist Kanadier, wie fühlt man sich als Nationalbewusstsein, das wird quasi dauernd in Frage gestellt, während parallel jemand wie Trump das auf seine Art auch in Frage stellt. In dem er also halb Scherz, halb ernst sagt, da wäre doch schön, wenn ihr eigentlich hier der 51. Staat würdet, also vereinnahmt würdet in die USA. Und damit wird auch das Selbstverständnis und das Nationalbewusstsein der Kanadier in Frage gestellt und Canys Politik reiten, right now, Entschuldigung, Canys Politik in diesem Augenblick ist sehr geschickt auch in der Art und Weise, wie er dieses Nationalbewusstsein anspricht und nutzt und positioniert gegen die Angriffe aus den USA. Aber Heckenschützen, wie Frau Smith oder so, die sind gefährlich und die werden auch entsprechend kritisch gesehen.
Also kurz, dass die Infos, die ich jetzt zuletzt gelesen habe, waren von dieser Woche, also vom Wochenende, dass es da eben immer noch stark Stress gibt und dass vor allem also die First Nation wollen halt so in so Civil Disobedience, heißt das, eben einkehren, wenn es eben zu diesem Referendum kommt. Aber mein letzter Stand von den letzten Recherchen war, dass das durchaus schon noch auf dem Tisch ist. Also wenn darüber abgestimmt wird, ob es dieses Referendum gibt. Also das ist dann das, was im Kopf steht. Aber wenn du da neuere News hast, dann...
Weil ich verfolge das auch die ganze Zeit. Also Frau Smith glaubt, sie hat noch andere Winkelzüge, wie sie das trotzdem irgendwie weiter betreiben können. Aber die erste große Erleichterung war diese Gerichtsentscheidung, die das Ganze vom Tisch gezogen hat. Also diese Separatisten, die sagen, wir geben jetzt nicht einfach auf.
Genau und warum, vielleicht einfach nochmal, warum Alberta überhaupt und warum das vielleicht auch interessant ist, ist einfach eine sehr reiche Ölprovinz. Und deshalb eben auch beispielsweise für Donald Trump gar nicht mal so uninteressant. Und Jürgen, du hast es ja eben schon angesprochen, auch hier müssen wir eben über Trump sprechen. Du hast eben schon gesagt, wir wissen es alle, Canada zum Fifty-first-State war auch in der letzten Zeit auch wieder viel. Generell ist zum Beispiel Kanye hat in seiner Davos-Rede, auf die wir gleich noch kommen, davon gesprochen, dass die Zeit der gut nachbarlichen Beziehung vorbei ist. Also es gibt auch einfach in Kanada so banale Sachen wie, muss ich ein bisschen rüberlassen, das in Cafés, zum Beispiel in British Columbia, heißt der Americano jetzt nicht mehr Americano, sondern Cane Antiano, das man ihn so nicht mehr nennt.
Geht einem ja auch genauso leicht von der Zunge.
Ja, klar. Dass zum Beispiel kein Bourbon aus der USA mehr in British Columbia verkauft wird.
Kein Wein, kein Alkohol.
Ja, genau, aber es ist halt trotzdem immer noch so, dass 75 Prozent aller kanadischen Exporte in die USA gehen. Man hat eben dieses USMCA-Treaty, wo wir eben darüber gesprochen haben. Und Kanada ist ganz klar dafür, das für weitere 16 Jahre zu verlängern. Mexiko eigentlich auch, da ist vor allem die USA das große Fragezeichen. Aber es ist eben auch so, also ganz einfach ist es eben nicht, sich da irgendwie von den USA abzuspalten. Und Kanada geht da eben auch ein gewisses Risiko ein, weil es einfach da immer noch, es ist eng verwoben. Und ja, gleichzeitig möchte Trump ja sowas wie Süßwasser aus Kanada in die USA umleiten und so. Aber gleichzeitig muss man eben auch sagen, durch Trumps Politik ist die liberale Partei der Kanis überhaupt erst wieder so stark geworden. Also davor, bevor Trump eben auch seinen Kurs gefahren hat, galten eigentlich die Konservativen als mögliche Wahlsieger. Aber im Gegenzug kam es eben dazu, dass die liberale Partei eben wieder mehr dafür gekommen ist. Gleichzeitig gibt es eben, versucht man gerade sich eben, Jürgen, du hast es eben schon mal so ein bisschen angesprochen, diese kanadische Identität irgendwie aufzuleben, so ein bisschen, ich sag mal, vorsichtig positiver Nationalismus, wie man das so sagen kann, beziehungsweise Patriotismus.
Weil die das brauchen. Das ist eine Jungen Nation. Wenn die sich nicht daran, wenn die sich nicht mit, und die haben eine wunderbare, also der Text zu der Nationalhymne ist wunderbar, also O Canada. Die haben einige Stützpfeiler für das, aber sie haben auch so Wackelpunkte und wollen aber jetzt nicht, also das sind keine Menschen, die jetzt versuchen, sagen wir mal, den Italo-Faschismus oder die nazipatriotistische Art oder so, oder jetzt die russische Entwicklung nachzuahmen. Sie wollen eigentlich nur ihr eigenes Leben selber bestimmen. Und das kann man eben nur in einem solchen Land, wenn man sich friedlich miteinander beschäftigt, und das wollen die Kanadier auch, sie wollen ja gar nicht sich gegenseitig an den Hals greifen oder so. Das ist schon ein Stimmungsaspekt. Und da ist natürlich auch, wenn wir jetzt von diesem Turnier sprechen, die Leistung der kanadischen Fußballer könnte da auch relativ wichtig sein. Also, dass sich darauf was projizieren lässt. Wahrscheinlich spielen sie nicht so gut, aber...
Jetzt sei du nicht so pessimistisch. Sie können sich alle wieder vereinen.
Aber sie können... Ja, sie haben ein weiteres Thema, um sich zueinander zu... Und da passieren auch Dinge, also zum Beispiel der Premier in Ontario ist ein Konservativer, der also auch ganz stark gegen Trump dann angetreten ist und so weiter. Also der hat nach dem Motto, ey, was willst du eigentlich? Ich hab hier zu sagen und so. Also der kann das auch rüberbringen, körperlich, dieses auch Dominanzverhalten. Aber er ist politisch eigentlich relativ nahe bei Trump. Aber nicht, wenn es darum geht, Kanada irgendwie zu destabilisieren. Und da passieren jetzt einige Sachen. Also die werden wahrscheinlich sogar Flugzeuge, also Militärflugzeuge aus Schweden einkaufen und nicht aus den USA. Und die ganze Hinwendung der Wirtschaft Richtung Asien und Europa ist voll in Gange. Und da werden dauernd Handelsabkommen abgeschlossen. Deshalb, die sind cool, wenn da jetzt die USA kommen, zu dieser nächsten, ab 1. Juli, dann sind das ganz kompetente, coole Leute, die sagen, okay, wenn ihr uns nichts zu bieten habt hier, dann tut uns leid, dann kümmer wir ja auch nichts zusammen. Und die Amerikaner sind ja völlig versessen darauf, eigentlich die Grenzen zuzumachen, sich abzuschotten vom Rest der Welt oder so. Ja, die Kanadier machen richtig auf. So, ja, okay, gut, Juli.
Nee, aber ich wollte noch sagen, wegen kanadischer Identität, also es gibt sogar in Ottawa beispielsweise einen extra Minister für kanadische Identität, der ist Steven Guilbault. Ich hoffe, ich habe es nicht komplett gebutchert. Und der hat zum Beispiel in einem Interview mit dem Spiegel davon gesprochen, dass man schon so ein bisschen Liebeskummer verspürt, also unter den Kanadier-Innen. Man hat aber auch das Gefühl, man wurde verraten. Und man sieht es eben als Attacke auf die Souveränität und Identität Kanadas. Man sieht aber vor allem, also der Unterschied, wo Kanada sich eben auch selber sieht, ist, dass man in Kanada eine, die Gemeinschaft spielt mehr eine Rolle. Es ist halt ein gemeinschaftsbasiertes Zusammenleben, im Gegensatz zu den USA, wo man eher als, ja, von einem Individuum geprägten Lebensstil bespricht. Beispiel auch medizinische Versorgung, das ist weitgehend staatlich organisiert. Oder wie sie sagen, wir können uns hier eine ärztliche Versorgung, könnte man sich leisten. Aber das sind alles so Punkte, wo man da eben auch schon immer so ein bisschen der Gegenpart, ich habe es eben schon mal angesprochen, die Ausfindung mit der indigenen Bevölkerung, wo man eben auch schon immer, oder auch vor allem in den letzten Jahren, schon aktiv auch einen Gegenpart zu der USA gebildet hat. Und das eben auch rein in diese kanadische Identität spielt. Und Jürgen, du hast es angesprochen, dass die kanadische Fußballmannschaft vielleicht da nur einen Satz zu, das ist gerade der größte Mitgliedersport, glaube ich, in Kanada tatsächlich. Gerade unter jungen Menschen, das ist der schnell wachsendste Sport momentan des Landes. Und durch die, ja doch sehr gute Rolle, die man zuletzt gespielt hat, durch die Copa America. Da war man nämlich in einer Gruppe mit Argentinien, Chile und Peru und man start schon mal zweiter geworden und hinter einem Halbfinale gegen Argentinien ausgeschieden. Im Elfmeterschießen hat es leider auch nicht für Platz drei in Uruguay gereicht. Aber deshalb ist schon so, dass so ein bisschen die Erwartungen gestiegen sind auch an die Mannschaft. Also man sagt vor allem, es wäre schon ein großer Erfolg, wenn man eben ins 16. Finale kommen. Auch, weil ja noch zwei Partien des 16. Finales auf kanadischem Boden stattfinden. Und halt vor allem wichtig wäre für die Weiterentwicklung des Sports. Und es wird immer ganz viel darüber geredet, ja hier eine Independence Day am 4. Juli. Aber es ist auch Canada Day am 1. Juli und das ist während des 16. Finales. Also das sei auch noch erwähnt. Und ich würde sagen, Max, bevor ich jetzt hier noch weiter monologisieren, ich habe es eben schon mal angesprochen. Es gibt diese Rede von Mark Kerney vor, in Davos beim Weltwirtschaftsforum. Und die ist ja durchaus, war ja sehr polarisierend. Und ich würde einfach mal sagen, wir hören da mal rein, was er so gesagt hat.
Das machen wir. Also kurz zum Rahmen dazu. Das Weltwirtschaftsforum ist, ihr kennt die Veranstaltung wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Man muss grundsätzlich wissen, die pitchen sich da gegenseitig, wie geil sie als Wirtschaften sind, weil sie wollen, sie wollen damit Investoren anlocken. Und am Rande davon wird aber auch immer wieder eine politische Botschaft gesetzt. Und das hat Mark Carney aber auf eine Art und Weise gemacht, die viele als Anti-Trump-Statement bezeichnet haben. Und da habe ich jetzt mal zwei O-Töne hier mitgebracht, die das ganz gut orchestrieren. Wir hören mal in den ersten Reihen. Wird. Wir sollten hier nicht nach trauern, Nostalgie ist keine Strategie. Aber wir glauben, dass wir aus dieser Zäsur etwas Größeres, Besseres, Stärkeres und Gerechteres aufbauen können. Und die alte Ordnung ist natürlich die enge Verknüpfung an eben einen Hegemonen, wie die USA. Und vielleicht wollen wir...
Übrigens, Zäsur klingt ein bisschen zu lieb. Er hat das Wort Fracture benutzt.
Ja, stimmt.
Und das heißt Bruch.
Ja, hast recht.
Ja, das ist ein Bruch. Und das ist auch in der englischen Sprache eine starke Wortwahl. Während also unser Begriff von Zäsur, das ist so ein bisschen akademisch, irgendwie, ja, da gibt es so Probleme oder so. Denn man hat wirklich das Fenster aufgestoßen und gesagt, das läuft hier nicht so weiter. Wir machen das noch jetzt.
Ja, also er begann zum Beispiel seine Rede damit. Heute werde ich über den Bruch in der Weltordnung sprechen, über das Ende einer schönen Geschichte und den Beginn einer brutalen Realität, in der die Geopolitik zwischen den Großmächten keinen Beschränkungen unterliegt. Also, ja, er hat wirklich, er hat das wirklich sehr, sehr deutlich gemacht, um was es ihm geht und letztlich eben ein Statement dahingehend, die USA sind kein verlässlicher Partner mehr. Das ist das, was darunter stand. Und daraus erwächst für die sogenannten, er nennt das immer die Middle Powers, also ich sag mal so die mittelgroßen Nationen, wirtschaftlich, ökonomisch, auch Verteidigungs- und militärisch, sicherlich auch gemeint. Für die erwächst daraus eine besondere Folge. Da hören wir mal noch kurz rein, weil dann kann man nicht alles erklären, was Kanada seitdem und nicht nur seitdem außenpolitisch macht.
Ich frage mich, ob die Mittelpower zusammenarbeiten müssen, weil wenn wir nicht am Tisch sind, sind wir auf dem Menü. Aber ich würde auch sagen, dass die Großmacher jetzt nur auf eine Lohnung gehen können. Sie haben die Marktseite, die Militärkapazität und die Bewertung, Termine zu diktieren.
Also er sagt, unser Gebot ist es, dass die Mittelmächte zusammenhandeln müssen. Denn wenn wir nicht am Tisch sitzen, sind wir auf der Speisekarte. Aber ich würde auch sagen, dass die Großmächte sich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt leisten können, alleine zu handeln. Sie haben die Marktgröße, die militärische Kapazität und den Hebel, um die Bedingungen zu diktieren, die Mittelmächte eben nicht. Aber wenn man eben nur bilateral mit einem Hegemon verhandelt, dann verhandeln wir aus der Schwäche heraus. Wir nehmen, was angeboten wird. Wir konkurrieren miteinander, also jetzt eben die Mittelmächte, wer am entgegenkommsten ist. Das ist keine Souveränität, es ist die Inszenierung von Souveränität. Bei gleichzeitiger Akzeptanz von Unterordnungen. Arne, du wurdest dazu was sagen.
Ja, das ist ja schon wahnsinnig spannend, weil wenn man sich jetzt diese Rede nochmal anschaut oder anhört und dann das in Kontext setzt, mit dem, worüber wir jetzt bisher gesprochen hatten, gerade bei Mexiko, das ist ja eine ganz ähnliche Konstellation. Das ist ein ganz ähnlicher Bezug. Das ist ein ganz ähnliches Verhältnis. Und wenn wir über Souveränität sprechen, im Umgang mit den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika heutzutage, das heißt im Jahr 2026, dann geht es ja immer darum, dass man selber zusieht, dass man sich bestmöglich schützt, aber gleichzeitig am besten vernetzt ist mit denen um sich herum, die so grob noch zur selben Wertegemeinschaft gehören. Und das ist ja insofern dann mit Fußballbezug noch spannender, weil die FIFA ist ja von der Anzahl der Mitgliedsinnen nachher größer als die UNO. Ja, da sind ja teilweise Verbände dabei aus Ländern, die teilweise gar nicht akzeptiert werden. Das heißt, es ist auch etwas, mit dem Infantino immer hausieren geht. Wir sind ja eine ganz große weltweite Bewegung und wir sind gefühlt genauso wichtig wie sauberes Wasser. Und was ich immer komisch finde, in dieser Übertragung von der harten geopolitischen Realität auf die FIFA, ist, dass es selbst da der EU nicht gelingt, dass man mit einer Stimme spricht. In dem Fall wäre das ja die UEFA oder es wären die Nationalregierungen, die da sagen würden, hör mal zu, lieber Gianni Infantino. Sorry, dass ich jetzt wieder den Namen hereinwerfe, aber der Gedanke geht mir jetzt eben durch den Kopf. Bei uns spielt der Großteil der Profis, der bei deiner WM mitspielt. Bei uns wird auch wahnsinnig viel umgesetzt und ohne den europäischen Fußball geht nicht viel im Weltfußball. Das passiert aber nicht. Das passiert nicht, weil eben auf Ebene der FIFA-Mitgliedsländer und Mitgliedsverbände diese Form des Miteinander koalieren, auch wenn man unterschiedliche Hintergründe hat und wenn man vielleicht unterschiedlichen Kontinentalverbänden angeht. Das gibt es ja gar nicht. Das existiert nicht. Und bevor ich da jetzt so weit weggaloppiere, finde ich das trotz allem nach wie vor spannend, weil innerhalb einer sportlichen Organisation, die auf globaler Ebene agiert, da zeichnet sich natürlich auch immer ab, was in der Regierung des Landes passiert.
Ja, das Ganze wurde auch im Nachhinein als Kani-Doktrin bezeichnet, eben als Antwort auf die Don-Roe-Doktrin. Falls ihr davon noch nichts gehört habt, das steht für Donald und Monroe. Ja, muss ich immer kurz wirklich einen Kopf rufen, das ist wirklich real. Und da geht es halt eben um diesen Hegemonie und Machtanspruch der USA, also deswegen als Gegenpart. Aber es gibt tatsächlich, wenn wir jetzt nochmal auf das, auf generell strategische Partnerschaften gucken, weil das leitet dazu ja schon ein bisschen über, außer ich nehme Max jetzt irgendeinen wichtigen Punkt, mit dem er vorne ansprechen wollte.
Nö, also er wurde danach vom Friedensrat ausgeschlossen von Donald Trump und Donald Trump hat gesagt, Canada existiert dank der Vereinigten Staaten. Denken Sie daran, Mark, wenn Sie sich das nächste Mal äußern, also eine Mischung aus Mafia-Boss-Drohungen und beleidigtes Kind. Aber lass uns dann zu dem kommen, was außenpolitisch dann passiert ist, nämlich die strategischen Partnerschaften.
Trotzdem einmal vielleicht so als News, weil wir jetzt eben schon immer wieder drüber gesprochen haben, die USMCA. Ich habe eben schon mal gesagt, Canada will da ja schon weiter Teil von sein. Und ich finde tatsächlich, die veröffentlichen dann so eine Joint Review heißt das. Und ich würde einmal gerade tatsächlich draus zitieren, was sie eben dazu geschrieben haben, zu, ob man eben dieses Agreement, dieses Treatment weiter macht. Also da steht together we can compete globally, drawing on the incredible resources and people that make up our integrated economic space. This joint review process provides us an opportunity, bla bla. Das ist vielleicht nicht so wichtig. Aber dann steht am Ende zum Beispiel noch sowas. Canadian, American and Mexican farmers, businesses, workers and consumers are counting on the timely completion of this work to provide the certainty and stability that is essential to maintaining the conditions that not only secure their economic futures, but allow them to prosper. Also wir hatten vorher in dieser Davos-Rede ja eigentlich, dass er immer wieder von diesem Mittelpower spricht und dass man da zusammenarbeiten muss und eben auch gegen die Großmächte. Und dann, halbes Jahr später, in diesem Statement zu betonen, ja, ja, ne, aber wir hier als Dreier-Konglumerat, wir müssen auch zusammenhalten, weil das und das und das sind die Vorteile und ist ja auch schon besser, wenn wir drei so zusammenarbeiten, fand ich auch in dem Kontext. Und Jürgen, du hast es eben schon mal gesagt, der Menge an wirklich Vereinbarungen, die Kanada zuletzt geschlossen hat und wo sie ehrlich gesagt überall gefühlt ihre Löffel in der Suppe haben oder so. Wie sagt man das?
Eisen im Feuer.
In verschiedenen Töpfen rühren. Ja, genau, Eisen im Feuer, in verschiedenen Töpfen rühren oder so. Sehr spannend. Ich fange einmal kurz mit der EU an, weil ich das eben schon mal gesagt habe. Ich würde tatsächlich auch davon absehen, jedes einzelne Freihandeskommen einmal aufzudrehen, weil ich glaube, das... Aber einfach so, wo ich mich jetzt auch am meisten eingelesen habe und weil ich es eben schon mal angesprochen habe, dass in Kanada durchaus die BewohnerInnen gar nicht mal so viel dagegen hätten, Teil der EU zu sein, was sich als sehr merkwürdig liest. Aber erst mal hat im Februar Kanada ein Abkommen zur Beteiligung am Security Action for Europe unterzeichnet, also kurz SAVE, ganz toller Name. Dabei geht es um unter anderem Waffenexporte. Einfach perfekter Name dafür, also beziehungsweise gemeinsame Waffenkäufe, also offiziell EU-Finanzierungsinstrument für Sicherheits, Beteiligungs- und Resilienzprojekte. Und warum beispielsweise Kanada für die EU gar nicht so uninteressant ist. 24 der 34 in der EU als kritisch eingestuften Rohstoffe sind eben in Kanada zu finden. Sowas wie Lithium, Nickel, Kobalt und so weiter. Ursula von der Leyen hat Kanada schon als Perfect Match bezeichnet, generell für die EU. Und es gibt eben eine Zunahme von Handel mit Waren und Dienstleistungen zwischen EU und Kanada zwischen 2016 und 2014 um etwa 72 Prozent. Vor allem unter anderem Käse. Fand ich sehr schön. Generell ist Kanada auch ein sehr wichtiger Partner in der Arktis. Der Vollständigkeit halber juristisch gesehen ist ein Beitritt schwierig, weil Artikel 49 des EU-Vertrags sagt, nur ein europäischer Staat kann Mitglied der Union werden. Geografisch ist dieser Aspekt eben ganz klar nicht erfüllt. Ich glaube, darüber brauchen wir nicht diskutieren. Aber natürlich muss man eben sagen, man hätte dann eben ein direktes Land an der Grenze zur Amerika. Aber zum Beispiel haben sie eben auch keine Mitgliedschaft im Europarat. Aber ich kann die Kanadierinnen beruhigen. Vielleicht darf man nochmals ESC nächstes Jahr teilnehmen. Das wäre doch schon mal der erste Schritt zur EU-Sierung.
Weitere Zusatz. Kanada und Deutschland planen Flüssiggas oder wie das heißt LNG, heißt es auf Deutsch, Flüssiggas. Aus einer Hafenanlage auf der Westküste, British Columbia, was relativ nahe an Alberta liegt, sodass also die Pipeline-Bedingungen für den Transport zu einem Hafenort relativ leicht innerhalb von zwei bis drei Jahren oder so zu bauen sind. Und ich glaube sogar, dass dieser Hafen schon existiert für Exportgeschäfte und dass halt diese Schiffe dann durch den Panama-Kanal fahren müssen, also einen längeren Weg haben. Aber der Pragmatismus hier ist der, dass man erstens Alberta daran erinnert, dass man also weiterhin auf den Geldzuschuss dann wird. Dass man zweitens, natürlich auch beim Blick auf die Landkarte, die Distanz von Alberta an die Ostküste, was war auch mal irgendwann im Gespräch, dass man also für die USA das Resort erklärt hat, weil das dauert auch ewig. Das dauert vielleicht fünf bis acht Jahre, um in der Pipeline darüber zu ziehen, um dann näher an dem europäischen Markt zu sein. Was Teil für mich, aber ich lese das nur aus dem, was ich mitkriege, die EU ist, glaube ich, sehr stark daran interessiert, diese ganze Russlandverbindung, also was ja auch nur ein Bodenschatzimperium ist, ein Militärimperium, da gibt es sonst nicht viel zu holen. Aber dass man sich da besser abnabeln kann, ist eher stärker und aus Kanada sehr viel mehr bekommen kann, als man bisher von Kanada bekommen kann. Und gleichzeitig den Kanadiern auch ihre Wirtschaftsaktivität erhöht. Und ein Hinweis, vielleicht hätten wir da eh noch drauf zu sprechen gekommen, der kanadische Nationaltrainer im Fußball ist ein Amerikaner. Jesse Marsh, der sicherlich gehofft hat, er würde der Nachfolger, also der Vorläufer oder von Pochettino oder so, da wurde er nicht berücksichtigt. Den kennt man in Deutschland als Spieler, aber auch als Trainer in Leipzig und vor in Salzburg. Und dann war er noch kurz in Lied. Und das ist so eine Person, da kann man so ein bisschen auch das Problem neu dran personalisieren, dass der Eiertänzer, der nun durchaus kritisch denken kann und auch nicht jetzt sagt, oh Amerika ist großartig und Trump ist großartig, aber auch darum weiß, dass er nicht auch noch irgendwelche Bohlen aufbrechen möchte oder so, dass also irgendwas kaputt geht, nur weil er plötzlich was Falsches sagt oder so. Also die weitere Komponente jetzt rund um die Wm, die man vielleicht zumindestens wissen wollte. Und noch ein letzter Gedanke, einer der Gründe, weshalb ich glaube, dass die Kanäle ja einfach nicht von den Amerikanern wegkommen können, ungefähr 80 Prozent der kanadischen Bevölkerung von 35, 36 Millionen Menschen lebt in relativ großer Nähe zur amerikanischen Grenze. Das heißt also, das sind Ontario zum Beispiel, also Toronto liegt ja auch relativ nah an der Grenze, aber dann selbst, also Montreal liegt nah an der Grenze zu Vermont zum Beispiel, das ist also eine kürze Stunde entfernt mit dem Auto. Und dann eben bis hin zur Westküste, Vancouver liegt auch an der Grenze. Also die Verzahnung, die auch da stattgefunden hat, diese wirtschaftliche, der wirtschaftlichen Aktivität, hat auch was mit dieser, nicht was damit zu tun, dass wir da zwei Nachbarländer haben, die eine Grenze haben, sondern dass wir da wirklich auch Bevölkerungszentren haben, die sehr nahe aneinander sitzen und die kann man auch gar nicht so einfach auseinanderschrauben. Der Warenaustausch zwischen West-Ontario, Windsor, auf der anderen Seite von Detroit, wo die Autoindustrie auf beiden Seiten massiv zusammenarbeiten, ist enorm und das kann man nicht einfach entpflichten. Aber Teil des Gesamtbildes nicht mehr.
Vielleicht kurz noch zu diesem LNG-Deal, den du eben genannt hast. Also es ist nicht nur die EU, sondern speziell eben Deutschland, die hinter diesem Deal stecken. Und auch da gibt es tatsächlich Kritik aus der indigenen Bevölkerung, also vor allem First Nation, weil das halt bisher, also dieses Xilis, Lysimims oder so heißt das, das habe ich jetzt auch wieder komplett gebotchat, naja. Das ist eben ein Terminal, so ein LNG-Terminal, der eben in Nord-British-Colombien, vor allem von halb indigenen Völkern besetzt wird bzw. gehört. Und die haben halt einfach aus Umweltgründen ein bisschen Schiss, was da passiert. Aber ja, also es ist eben genau das. Es soll eigentlich eben Karnes, ja, das, was er eben mal bei Davos gesagt hat, dieses Wegkommen eigentlich und was sie eigentlich für eine tolle Wirtschaftsmacht sind und so, das sollte das eben auch nochmal bestärken. Und eben, wie du schon gesagt hast, für, gerade für Deutschland, dass man eben von Russland wegkommt, was eben dieses Likofyte Natural Gas betrifft, das noch als Ergänzung.
Und das wird eben garniert durch jede Menge strategische Partnerschaften. Also mit Indonesien, mit dem südostasiatischen Raum. Interessant dabei ist.
Indien neuerdings auch.
Mit Indien, da wäre ich jetzt gleich noch zugekommen.
Entschuldigung.
Alles gut. Was übrigens ehrlich gesagt, und ganz wichtig, also Indien und China nämlich auch. Und da sieht man nämlich, und den Teil habe ich nämlich deswegen jetzt auch weggelassen, bei dieser Davos-Rede, für die er ja Standing Ovation bekommen hat, da hat er auch ganz viel über eine wertebasierte Ordnung gesprochen und dass man eben für Menschen und Völkerrecht und so weiter eintreten würde. Und wenn man sich dann aber anguckt, was er über Xi Jinping sagt, ich hätte es hier auf dem Soundboard, aber ich erspare es uns. Xi Jinping, Supertyp. Und was er über Modi sagt, könnt ihr mal gucken, was gerade so mit den Muslimen unter der Regierung Modi so passiert in Indien. Auch Modi, laut Kani, Supertyp, 25 Jahre, kein einziges Mal krank gewesen, echt Töfte. Das zeigt eben, also das mit dem Wert basiert, das ist Quatsch, das ist einfach genau dasselbe, was alle Staaten vorher auch schon gemacht haben. Aber es ist eben eine Loslösung vom großen Hegemon USA, in dem man immer noch sehr, sehr dranhängt, mit dem man sehr verflochten ist. Aber gerade diese Hinwendung zu China, die ja als Antagonist zu den USA verstanden werden müssen, das ist ein deutliches Signal und das zeigt eben, welchen Weg hier Kanada einschlägt. Und das Ganze hat genuin mit der Weltmeisterschaft nichts zu tun. Wir werden aber wahrscheinlich im Rahmen dieser Weltmeisterschaft die Themen, die wir gerade angesprochen haben, eben sehen. Also zum einen die Selbstvergewisserung als Nation, die man vielleicht gerade auch ein bisschen nötiger hat, als noch vor zwei, drei Jahren. Und zum anderen aber auch die Abgrenzung durchaus zum Turnier in den USA. Also das, was du erzählt hast, Eva, von so Eindrücken von den Fanfesten, die eben an den kanadischen Spielstätten stattfinden. Das kann man auch, wenn man möchte, lesen, jetzt eben, so ist dieses Turnier auch möglich. So wäre es auch möglich, denn in den USA haben die meisten Städte ihre Fanfeste stark verkleinert oder ganz abgesagt, weil die da Finanzierungsprobleme haben. Auch deshalb, weil Bundesmittel eingefroren sind und gerade nicht an die Städte ausgezahlt werden oder zumindest eingefroren waren, weil es da eben einen partiellen Shutdown gab.
Und das ist auch, weil die Kanadier, die also als Touristen in den USA ein Wicht- und Wirtschaftsfaktor sind oder gewesen sind, sehr stark, sehr viele von denen Reisenden in die USA einfach gestrichen haben. Das wird nicht unbedingt offiziell als Boycott bezeichnet, aber es hat natürlich diese Komponente. Und das ist, weil sie eben auch grenznah leben. Die würden ja vielleicht auch nach Seattle fahren, um dort ein Spiel zu sehen oder die Stimmung von Seattle einzusammeln oder woanders hin reisen, vielleicht nach New York oder nach Boston. Also, da kommt auch eine Schwächung der amerikanischen Umsetzung des Turniers her. Also alles feine, kleine Eruptionen oder Teile der Entwicklung. Aber weil wir ja versuchen, so ein bisschen ein gutes, dichtes Bild zu zeichnen, sicherlich auch zu erwähnen.
Und vielleicht baut uns das dann auch schon die Brücke zu den USA, Jürgen. Denn eigentlich alles, was wir hier jetzt hier besprochen haben, bei Mexikum, bei Kanada, haben wir auch als Antwort oder Reaktion auf Dinge, die von Donald Trump oder den USA eben kamen, verstanden. Weil die USA sind eben die Weltmacht, die in Nachbarschaft zu diesen beiden Nationen liegt. Und bei den USA haben wir natürlich ein breites Feld an innenpolitischen und außenpolitischen Themen. Ich glaube, die außenpolitischen Aggressionen, zum Teil verbaler Art, zum Teil aber auch militärischer Art. Also Venezuela zum Beispiel. Wenn wir die südamerikanischen Fischerboote, die also stand April, waren es 174 Menschen, die da bei uns lebend gekommen sein sollen. So genau weiß es aber eigentlich keiner, weil man muss sich da auf die US-Angaben verlassen. Aber eben auch rhetorische Dinge, wie eben wir haben es vorhin mit Mexiko angesprochen, wir haben es mit Kanada angesprochen, wir alle haben mitbekommen, was mit Grönland los war. Wir hätten auch 50 First State werden sollen oder sollen es eigentlich immer noch. Also ich glaube, das haben wir alle ganz gut so halbwegs auf dem Schirm. Und ich könnte die Liste jetzt natürlich mit Iran, Nigeria und so weiter noch länger machen. Mich würde aber interessieren, gerade weil du ja auch vor Ort sitzt, welche innenpolitischen Ambivalenzen und Risslinien gibt es denn aktuell, die vielleicht dann eben auch bei dieser WM sichtbar werden oder vielleicht durch die WM auch übertüncht werden können, zumindest für diese paar Wochen.
Also ich glaube, dass die Tendenz so sein wird, dass man übertüncht und dass man versucht, also daraus so ein Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen-Event zu inszenieren und dass die Art und Weise, wie die Medien insgesamt und natürlich auch stellenweise die Sportmedien insgesamt mit Trump umgehen und wie sie ihn zu Unrecht respektieren als Formalpräsident, aber als völliges Faktotum, der also nicht mal, der lügt und der nichts Gescheites von sich geben kann und der nur sein Dominanzverhalten auslebt und seinen Narzissmus und seine Mafia-Instinkte. Das wird, glaube ich, dieses Turnier in keiner Weise beeinflussen. Im Gegenteil, also eher darüber wegtäuschen. Trotz der vielen Detailnachrichten, also die Nachrichtenlage ist nicht so weiß, dass man also alles wegdrückt und alle Geschichten, über die wir jetzt ja auch schon oft gesprochen haben, Einreiseverbote und so weiter, das wird hier auch alles abgebildet. Aber es wird eben nicht eingeordnet. Was wir hier heute machen, ist der Versuch, all unsere vielen Informationen und Quellen irgendwo dahin zu bringen, wo man ein Bild erzeugen kann, wo man das besser versteht. Warum ist das so? Dass diese Arbeit wird in diesem Land so gut wie nicht geleistet, sie wird zersplittert, versucht, auch in den sozialen Medien. Aber das erzeugt ja keine Massenbewegungen. Das, was in diesem Land fehlt, klar Ansage, sind Generalstreike, um all das zu attackieren, was hier schiefläuft und falsch läuft. Und es gibt nicht das Potenzial dieser sozialen Bewegungen, die Gewerkschaften, große, starke Gewerkschaften getragen haben, in Ländern wie Frankreich oder Italien, wo dann wirklich alle Räder stehenbleiben. Sodass all das Gerede, was ein Typ wie Trump oder seine, ich sehe es schon als legionäre Bezeichnung, davon sich geben, dass das einfach entlarvt wird. Es gibt Gegenkräfte. Und das findet hier nicht statt. Die Medien werden attackiert, auseinandergenommen. Also die Einkäufe bei CBS, bei Fernsehsendern, jetzt CNN, da gehen weitere in halbwegs unabhängig arbeitende Journalisten in den Ruhestand oder so. Da ist so viel los, ja. Und wir hatten jetzt zum Beispiel diese Situation am Sonntag, die dann live und dann aber auch in Aufzeichnung mit dieser Kollegin Chris Welker und Trump in Wisconsin das Interview, wo er versucht hat, diese Frau zu beschimpfen, einzuschüchtern und im Grunde ihre Arbeit zu verunmöglichen, indem er einfach weggegangen ist. Und meine Position zu sowas ist, wenn Journalisten nicht in der Lage sind, in solchen Situationen zu sagen, du hast schon viele Leute bedroht und ihnen Zivilklagen wegen Verleumdung angedroht oder auch sogar beantragt oder eingereicht, wir können das auch. Wenn das hier nicht zu einem anderen Niveau im Gespräch führt, kommt hier eine Klage wegen Verleumdung. Ich lasse mich nicht als dumm bezeichnen oder als crooked, würde man etwas vager übersetzen müssen, was ist das beste deutsche Wort, also als betrügerisch, also die Bedeutung ist wirklich betrügerisch. Link ist eine gute, ja. Und das sieht man nicht, wir sehen immer nur jetzt Echoes auf diese Geschichten. Wir sehen nicht, dass die, die Agency haben, die wirklich auch, also die haben, die arbeitet bei NBC, das ist eine riesige Firma, die gehört Comcast, das ist eine noch größere Firma. Die könnten wirklich was unternehmen. Und die sind alle eingeschüchtert oder ängstlich oder so. Also solange es keine Anzeichen gibt, dass diese Form von Widerstand gezielt passiert und alle nur darauf hoffen, dass die Wahl im November irgendwelche Veränderungen produziert. Solange kann man eigentlich nicht annehmen, dass wirklich was massiv passiert. Wenn die Wirtschaft weiter schlechter läuft, als sie das, also über die Ölpreise, über Preise für Lebensmittel, andere Verbraucher, klar, es gibt einen Unbehagen, die Umfrageergebnisse sind ja völlig klar. Trump hat nur noch 35 Prozent an Unterstützern. Aber das hebt ihn ja nicht aus dem Abend. Und die Leute, die das könnten, im Kongress oder im Kabinett, die das hier verfassungsmäßig könnten, werden einen Teufel tun, das zu probieren. Wo bin ich jetzt? Wo bin ich gelandet? In so einer Form von Ratlosigkeit, die ich hier artikulieren muss. Und wenn ihr einen klareren Ansatz oder Gedanken habt, bitte versucht mal.
Ich denke, was in den USA passiert, das nehmen wir ja alle wahr, das bekommen wir alle mehr oder weniger mit. Es gibt ja jeden Tag quasi Meldungen, die uns erreichen aus dem Land, ob innenpolitisch oder außenpolitisch, die uns hier beschäftigen, die die Bundesregierung beschäftigen, die die EU beschäftigen, damit wir mal so ein bisschen den Bogen vielleicht spannen können zur Weltmeisterschaft an sich, würde ich noch mal tatsächlich einen Schritt zurücktreten, weil mein Eindruck ist, dass während der zweiten Amtszeit von Donald Trump gewisse Sachen nicht mehr einfach nur gesagt werden, sondern konkret umgesetzt werden. Es ist ja häufig so, dass man Faschisten nicht glaubt, dass sie etwas gewisses tun werden, oder Autokraten nicht glaubt, dass sie etwas gewisses tun werden, bis sie es tun. Und dann ist im Prinzip schon klar gewesen, was sie vorhatten die ganze Zeit. Und jetzt ist mein Eindruck gewesen aus den vergangenen Monaten, durch die Veröffentlichung diverser Papiere, durch die Trump-Administration, was konkret wirklich Sachen sind, die dann auch messbar sind und die dann auch Wiederhall finden oder mehr Wiederhall finden müssten vielleicht auch in Einzelfällen. Also als Beispiel würde ich mal sagen, die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie, die vor einigen Monaten veröffentlicht worden ist, wo Europa danach einigermaßen fassungslos dastand und schwarz auf weiß stand, dass all diejenigen Regierungen oder Länder, die sich nicht jetzt dem Ethnonationalismus unterwerfen und die gleiche politische Linie einschlagen wie Trump, dass die möglicherweise Probleme bekommen könnten, dass von einem zivilisatorischen Zerfall Europas gesprochen wird und so in diesen Papieren. Das ist natürlich schon frappierend auf eine Art. Und in dem gleichen Zusammenhang kommt da natürlich auch Sportpolitik mit rein, weil es in dieser Amtszeit ein Papier gibt, über das aus meiner Sicht bisher viel zu wenig gesprochen worden ist. Und zwar ist das das Sports Diplomacy Playbook, was im State Department dann verteilt worden ist. Also an all die Personen, die im Außenministerium arbeiten. Das ist relativ übersichtlich. Politico hatte darüber berichtet. Link dann auch in den Shownotes. Das sind neun Seiten und da wird relativ klar, so berichtet das Politico, dargelegt, was die Strategie ist, die sportpolitisch verfolgt wird. Und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, 2026 Fußball-Wm, 2028 Olympische und Paralympische Spiele in Los Angeles und 2034 die Winterspiele, die Olympischen Winterspiele in Utah. Also da haben wir wirklich ein ganzes Jahrzehnt an großen Sportereignissen, die auf US-amerikanischem Boden stattfinden. Und dementsprechend wird das auch als The Decade of Sports bezeichnet, also die Dekade des Sports in den USA. Und aus diesem Playbook geht auch hervor, mit welcher Zielsetzung Sport genutzt werden soll, weil es geht nicht ums Sporttreiben an sich. Es geht auch nicht um irgendwelche Erfolge von US-amerikanischen Athletinnen. Das ist natürlich dann irgendwie zweit- oder drittrangig. Sondern es geht darum, wie kann man mithilfe des Sports schaffen, dass man Business Opportunities hinbekommt, also Möglichkeiten, Geld zu machen. Wie kann man es schaffen, die American Brand, für die Trump jetzt die letzten Jahre unterwegs war, also das Bild, was er von Amerika zeichnen müsste. Wie bekommt man das mittels des Sports an die Leute? Und das äußert sich dann eben teilweise recht konkret in Maßgaben für die Personen, die im State Department arbeiten. Da geht es dann zum Beispiel um Visa für Transgender-AthletInnen, also Personen, die einreisen wollen für einen Wettbewerb. Und das soll denen anhand dieses Papiers dann einfach, ja, also sinngemäß soll quasi die Sportorganisation, um die es geht, soll sich auf Trump-Linie fügen. Die sollen das machen, was er sagt. Und da kommen sicherlich noch andere Dinge mit rein. Ich konnte das Papier jetzt nicht im Detail lesen, weil das nicht so leicht auffindbar ist, bzw. wahrscheinlich liegt es nur bei den KollegInnen vom Politico. Aber was ist mit der Teilnahme der israelischen Nationalmannschaft an internationalen Wettbewerben im Fußball? Was ist mit Russland bei internationalen Wettbewerben? Ich glaube, all solche Fragen werden da beantwortet oder zumindest angerissen. Und deswegen ist Sport, Diplomatie, Sportpolitik, das ist jetzt nichts, was nach der WM vorbei sein wird. Das ist jetzt nichts, was irgendwie sich im Kontext mit Gianni Infantino abspielt. Sondern das wird weitergehen, auch in der zweiten Amtszeit von Donald Trump.
Und ich finde, dass das nämlich ein interessanter Gedanke ist, auch dahingehend, dass man vielleicht hin und wieder auch versuchen muss, bei dem Blick auf dem, was jetzt hier rund um diese WM passiert, auch politisch gesehen, eben aus unserer europäischen Sicht heraus. Also wir bekommen mit, dass der Schiedsrichter des Jahres in Afrika sich einreißen darf und in die Nähe von Terroristen gestellt wird. Wir bekommen mit, dass das Team Sennegeiss noch auf dem Rollfeld mit Sprengstoffspürhunden und Metalldetektoren und inklusive Schuhe ausziehen und so weiter kontrolliert wird. Ähnliches auch mit dem Team aus Belgien und so weiter und so fort. Und das löst auch aufgrund der Art und Weise, wie diese Bilder transportiert werden, meist kurze Clips, das löst Empörung aus und das löst einen, warum wird das akzeptiert, warum sagt niemand was dagegen, kann sich jetzt Rudi Völler mal bitte dazu äußern, was sagt eigentlich Bernd Neuendorf und von Tanni Infantino erwarten wir schon gar nichts mehr. Es könnte aber auch sein und das ist das, ich habe leider dieses Sports Diplomacy Playbook auch jetzt gerade erst durch dich mitbekommen, sagt ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen was über meine Recherche, obwohl ich da schon seit ein paar Wochen drin stecke. Aber könnte es nicht vielleicht auch sein und dann gebe ich mal die Frage an Jürgen, der ja dann vielleicht noch am ehesten die nicht europäische Sicht darauf hat. Kann es vielleicht sein, dass Donald Trump und die Regierung möchte, dass genau diese Bilder transportiert werden, um eben das Signal zu senden, das ist unsere Politik, das ist unser Umgang mit Fremden, die in unser Land kommen?
Das ist teilweise tatsächlich in einigen politischen Aktivitäten zu erkennen, dass das bewusst in Kauf genommen wird. Also zum Beispiel die Attacken gegen Menschen in Minneapolis oder in Chicago mit Hilfe von ICE oder auch mit Hilfe der National Guard, speziell auch in Los Angeles und so weiter. Da nimmt man bewusst in Kauf, dass das auch vielleicht sogar Empörung auslöst. Aber es ist eine verkappte Nachricht an alle anderen, die vielleicht denken, sie könnten ihre Rechte nutzen oder ihr Selbstbewusstsein weiter pflegen oder so. Das sind Einschüchterungsstrategien. Oder ein anderes Beispiel, wie man mit Familien umgegangen ist, vielleicht immer noch, die illegal über die Grenze gekommen sind und dann festgenommen wurden. Wie die behandelt werden, nach dem Motto, okay, ihr wisst, wie schlecht ihr behandelt wird, also bleibt bitte zu Hause, wenn ihr rausgeschmissen werdet, sonst geht es so weiter. Also das ist bestimmt diese grausamen, wir betrachten das als grausame Art und Weise, Politik umzusetzen und dachten, das hätte man vielleicht spätestens in den 60er-Jahren mit bestimmten Gesetzen überwunden, aber das ist eben nicht der Fall. Und die Frage ist natürlich immer auch, was ist der Wirkungsgrad davon? Das hängt aber dann auch wieder davon ab, in Amerika jetzt speziell, wie die Bundesjustiz, also die Richter, die da angerufen werden, wie die reagieren und wie schnell die reagieren. Und da gibt es also einige Beispiele, also inzwischen eine ganze Latte von Niederlagen dieser Trump-Schergen vor Gericht, in Einzelfragen, wo Richter sich auch Zeit nehmen, das wird also gar nicht so spontan entschieden, wo aber auch eine ganze Reihe von Stops und Bremsen reingehauen worden ist. Dann ist immer noch die Frage, wie wirkungsvoll ist das dann am Ende? Weil wenn diese Leute in der Trump-Regierung sich dann nicht daran halten, dass die Richter von ihnen verlangen werden, kommt das ja wirklich zu einer bürgerkriegsartigen Ausgangslage. Also ich weiß nicht, wohin das geht, aber die Ur-Idee von dem, was die da machen mit ihrem Verständnis von Nationalismus und diesem Ethnonationalismus, wie Arne das gerade auch gut genannt hat, das wird ja nicht durchdacht. Also Immigranten sind essenziell für dieses Land, für den Reichtum und für die Weiterentwicklung dieses Landes. Es ist essenziell, egal wo die herkommen. Wir haben viele Asiaten, die also fast die schlausten Asiaten, sind irgendwie in den USA gelandet und helfen diesem Land hier. Und die, die aus Mittelamerika kommen oder Südamerika, sind wichtige Arbeitskräfte für manuelle Arbeit meistens, die von Amerikanern nicht geleistet wird. Und wenn die nicht geleistet wird, dann sind die auch wie in Deutschland dann Hilfskräfte im Gesundheitswesen und so weiter und so weiter. Also das ist ja völlig verkorkst. Und die Verkaufe der Idee, dass wenn man Zölle erhebt, dass man damit nur die Länder bestraft, gegen die diese Zölle verwenkt werden, das ist ja der absolute Bullshit. Das ist eine Steuer auf das, was die Amerikaner bezahlen müssen. Aber das ist ja nur ein Teil dieses Playbooks von ich mache sowieso, was ich will und ich zeige, dass ich Macht habe und dass ich irgendwas durchsetzen kann. Also das gehört alles in diesem Topf.
Und ich bin wieder an einem Punkt, wo ich sage, bitte klärt das mal mit, ja jetzt für mich, weil ich auch nicht genau auf einer klaren Linie bin hier. Ich schmeiße nur Beobachtung oder Neuigkeiten oder wie auch immer mit rein. Also Arne hat jetzt was zu sagen. Bitte.
Ich glaube, wovon wir uns verabschieden können, damit wir, meine ich jetzt Personen, die sich für Fußball interessieren oder die sich für Politik im Allgemeinen interessieren, die These, dass sportliche Großveranstaltungen stattfinden, um von anderen Dingen in einem Land abzulenken. Da gab es in der Vergangenheit genügend Beispiele, wo das angewendet worden ist, Russland, diverse andere olympische Spiele, paralympische Spiele und so weiter, wo quasi das ganze Spotlight ausgerichtet ist auf die Wettbewerbe und alles andere lassen wir mal jetzt gerade links liegen und kümmern uns da gar nicht drum. Oder auch die Idee, dass während einer solchen sportlichen Großveranstaltung Gesetze erlassen werden, die dann vielleicht so ein bisschen untergehen, wo man das vielleicht so ein bisschen jenseits der Öffentlichkeit machen kann. Davon können wir uns in Bezug auf die USA komplett verabschieden. Das ist Bullshit, das jetzt zu behaupten, weil seit Jahren ist dort die Strategie flood the zone with shit und zwar das ganze Jahr. Ob jetzt ein Fußball-Wm ist oder nicht, ist völlig egal. Da passieren Dinge, die vor Jahren noch undenkbar gewesen wären. Und dass jetzt gleichzeitig eine Fußball-Wm noch stattfindet, ist okay. Aber das wird nichts daran ändern, dass sich die grundsätzliche Strategie, die grundsätzliche Doktrin in allen verschiedenen Politikbereichen, diese Administration, die werden sich nicht ändern. Und es ist vorher schon zu Vorfällen gekommen. Januar, Februar, Minerpolis, du hast es eben erwähnt. Auch schon beim Club World Cup im vergangenen Jahr ist jemand im Umfeld des Stadions festgenommen worden und war dann lange Zeit in Haft und ist am Ende sogar deportiert worden. Jemand, der sich da einfach ein Spiel anschauen wollte. Und da hätte er eigentlich schon, ich glaube, Human Rights Watch hatte darüber berichtet. Und da hätte er eigentlich schon klar sein müssen, auf was für ein Terrain man sich jetzt begibt mit dieser Weltmeisterschaft. Und das hat jetzt noch nicht mal angefangen. Und Max hat jetzt eben schon mal kurz erwähnt, was alles passiert ist. Iranische Nationalmannschaft, der Schiedsrichter und so weiter und so fort. Das wird jetzt in einem, in einer Taktung weitergehen. Das ist schwierig sein wird da überhaupt, ja, auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben. Es wird jeden Tag irgendwas sein. Wir werden unsere Feeds anschauen und werden sagen, das ist doch jetzt alles nicht wahr, was hier passiert. Aber es fehlt dann auch so ein bisschen aus meiner Sicht so an der, an der Reflexion und auch an der, an der Übertragung dessen, was man da sieht, eben einzuordnen in die größeren Zusammenhänge. Und da sind eben dann die Doktrin an sich, so eine nationale Sicherheitsstrategie oder das Sports Diplomacy Playbook. Das sind Dinge, die kann man, die sind greifbar, die kann man einigermaßen dann nachvollziehen. Man muss sie nicht verstehen, aber man kann es zumindest von der Argumentation her in einer gewissen Art und Weise verknüpfen mit Dingen, die man vorher schon gehört hat. Und von daher ist jetzt diese Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft sicherlich nur ein Baustein. Und ich kann nur appellieren, dass man wirklich versucht, jetzt, wenn man alles Sportliche sowieso mal zur Seite schiebt, dass man sich nicht treiben lässt von von vielen kleinen Dingen, die ohnehin passieren und die einen empören, aber dass das gebündelt wird auf eine Art, dass Strategie auch demaskiert werden kann und dementsprechend auch aufgezeigt werden kann, dass das jetzt nicht die Weltmeisterschaft ist, mit der jetzt diverse Hebel betätigt werden können von Donald Trump und so. Das glaube ich nicht. Ich hatte ja vorhin auch schon erwähnt, dass es ihm in Sachen Midterms auch nicht helfen wird. Aber ja, bei diesem erratischen Präsidenten und seiner seiner Crew um sich herum, da werden uns jetzt sicherlich spannende Wochen erwarten und auch danach wird es nicht langweiliger.
Ja, wobei ich dann schon noch die eine Unterscheidung machen würde, dass es, glaube ich, einen inszenatorischen Rahmen gibt, in dem diese Weltmeisterschaft stattfindet, in dem die Hoheit über Bild, über Besetzung und über Drehbuch bei zwei Akteuren liegt und zwar bei der FIFA und bei den Gastgeberländern. Wir sprechen jetzt eben hier in diesem Fall von Spielen in US-Staaten, die dort stattfinden. Und ich glaube, dass es schon wichtig ist zu unterscheiden, wann blicken wir auf eine Inszenierung, die auch genau eine solche sein soll. Also Donald Trump wird seine öffentlichen Auftritte bekommen. Wir werden in den sozialen Netzwerken dann Videos davon sehen, wie er ausgeboot wird. Wir werden es in der Fernsehübertragung nicht sehen, wie er ausgeboot wird und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist quasi wichtig bei allem, weil wir alle wollen erst mal nur Sport sehen und das ist auch völlig okay, sich von dem Sport, den man dann da gebrutten bekommt, auch begeistern zu lassen und das als Eskapismus zu verwenden. Man sollte sich aber dessen bewusst sein, dass alles, was drum herum passiert, um dieses Spielfeld, eben instrumentalisiert. Ich würde noch mal eine Unterscheidung machen, zwischen den Videos, die wir sehen, von Teams, wie sie durchsucht werden, noch auf dem Rollfeld, bevor sie überhaupt begrüßt werden, während im Kontrast dazu die Teams, die in Mexiko ankommen, erstmal ein Ständchen gesungen bekommen und jeder bekommt einen Blumenstrauß in die Hand. Das ist ein Unterschied zu diesem ganz durchchoreografierten, seelenlosen, durchkommerzialisierten Drum herum, das um dieses Spiel herum stattfindet. Und ich glaube, dass es einfach nur so eine Sache ist, die man sich jetzt hin und wieder immer mal wieder in Erinnerung rufen muss. Denn das Tolle und gleichzeitig Schreckliche am Fußball ist, er reißt einen emotional mit. Und das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht das Spiel Cape Verde gegen Jordanien sein, aber ausschließen kann man es nicht. Aber spätestens am 8. Finale oder 6. oder 10. Finale, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal die Wm durchgetippt habe, es wird tolle Partien geben, es wird tolle Tore geben, es wird viele Geschichten geben, auch lustige Geschichten werden uns mitreißen. Und dann kann man aber zumindest sich das immer wieder vergegenwärtigen. Das ist auch okay, sich mitreißen zu lassen. Aber das Ganze findet in einem Rahmen statt. Und ich habe in der Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung, also ich habe viel über die Wm in Argentinien 1978 auch noch mal nachgelesen und so weiter. Das war sieben Jahre vor meiner Geburt. Ich habe da keinen Bezug zu, aber ich weiß jetzt viel darüber. Und ich habe mir immer wieder die Frage gestellt, wie werden wir in zehn Jahren auf dieses Turnier zurückblicken? Denn ich weiß ganz genau, wie ich jetzt auf Russland zurückblicke. Und da bin ich nicht mehr ganz happy damit, wie ich das damals hier im Rasenfunk so begleitet habe, obwohl ich damals schon versucht habe, nach rechts und nach links zu gucken und auch Monate vor dem Turnier anzufangen mit den Gesprächen mit Katrin Scheib und nach dem Turnier auch noch mal zurückzublicken. Bei Katar dann war meine Entscheidung, okay, ich mache gar nichts, aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen. So, das ist jetzt Versuch Nummer drei. Und ich versuche immer wieder darüber nachzudenken, wie guckt man in zehn Jahren drauf. Und ich finde, dass das manchmal hilft, so eine leichte Kalibrierung des eigenen Kompasses vorzunehmen. Weil ich glaube, manche Aufregler, die sind in zehn Jahren kein großes Thema mehr. Vielleicht ist es in zehn Jahren aber viel wichtiger, dass Rudi Völler jetzt eigentlich gar nichts gesagt hat auf die Frage nach, wie finden sie dann, dass das hier ein Schiedsrichter einfach nicht rein einreisen darf. Und das wäre einfach nur so ein Gedanke, den ich gerne mitgeben wollen würde. Egal, was dann jeder Einzelne da draus macht, so versuche ich jetzt aber zumindest öfter so auf dieses Sportereignis zu gucken.
Ja, Thema Inszenierung, da hast du natürlich vollkommen recht. Das ist eine Sache, die im Rahmen eines solchen Turniers dann natürlich extrem wichtig ist. Das führt mich zu der Annahme, dass es ja sein kann. Deutschland qualifiziert sich über die Vorrunde, Frankreich macht das genauso. Und am 4. Juli treffen die dann aufeinander. Das müsste dann das 8. Finale, glaube ich, schon sein. 4. Juli, Spielort wäre Philadelphia. In diesem Ort wurde die amerikanische Unabhängigkeitserklärung unterschrieben vor dann genau 250 Jahren an diesem Tag. Und jetzt stellt euch vor, in dieser Stadt treffen bei dieser riesigen Feier zum 250-jährigen Jubiläum, was natürlich von Donald Trump ausgenutzt wird wie nichts anderes. Mit riesigen Events und Feuerwerk hier und da und was weiß ich nicht auch, was da noch alles passiert. Wir sind in Philadelphia, 4. Juli und da spielen Frankreich und Deutschland gegeneinander. Wirklich die beiden absoluten Säulen der Europäischen Union, die sich in den vergangenen Monaten wirklich schwergetan haben, die Zähne ausbeißen, um irgendwie noch ein halbwegs vernünftiges transatlantisches Verhältnis aufrecht zu erhalten. Wobei das aus meiner Sicht sowieso schon gerissen ist. Und dann treffen die in diesem Stadion an diesem Tag theoretisch aufeinander. Das ist für mich das Maximum an Absurdität, was da tatsächlich stattfinden könnte.
Und am Vortag könnten die USA gegen den Iran spielen.
Das ist ebenfalls so. Siehst du, ja.
Jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage. Wir haben eigentlich noch ein komplettes Kapitel in dieser Sendung. Wir sind allerdings auch schon in Aufnahmestunde 6. Das merkt ihr nicht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir aber glaube ich schon. Wir wollten doch über die Finanzen sprechen. Das war jetzt aber gerade fast schon so ein Fazit. Sollen wir die Finanzen abkürzen, ganz schnell drüber hudeln?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, wir können da mal kurz über, also weil wir jetzt ja schon die ganze Zeit auch in den, ich würde vielleicht einmal kurz sagen, was die FIFA generell vor hat oder wo das Geld, dass das Geld eigentlich für eine Rolle spielt. Vielleicht einmal ganz kurz auf die Lage der Host-Cities gucken, weil das ja vielleicht auch noch etwas interessanter ist, wenn das für dich in Ordnung ist. Aber zum Beispiel so was wie über den Fox-Deal, hört da doch einfach in das Panel rein, da hast du das ja auch kurz zusammengefasst. Darf ich so Cross-Episonen mäßig, da würde ich sonst einfach kurz einen schneller Durchlauf machen, Max.
Mach.
Also generell, wir haben es jetzt glaube ich schon 50.000 Mal gehört, das wird die tollste und größte Wm aller Zeiten und bringt so viel Geld ein wie noch nie. Jetzt mal einfach kurz als Reality-Check, natürlich bringt eine Wm mit mehr Teilnehmern und mehr Spielen dadurch, also im Vergleich, wir hatten vorher 64 Spiele, jetzt sind es 104. Natürlich gibt es dadurch mehr Inhalte und dadurch kann ich eben mehr Inhalte an Broadcaster verkaufen. Generell Anstoßzeiten, zum Beispiel für Nordamerika und Europa, trotzdem noch lukrativer als in Katar, etc., pp. Das heißt, wir haben am Ende eine Rechte die FIFA eben in diesem Zyklus, 23 bis 26 mit 13 Milliarden US-Dollar Einnahmen, die Wm jetzt selber soll 9 Milliarden bringen, das sind 50 Prozent mehr als die Wm 2022. Ich würde jetzt gucken, dass ich nicht so wahnsinnig viel mit Zahlen um mich schmeiße in dieser fortgeschrittenen Stunde, weil ich glaube, ich kann da nicht folgen und ihr auch nicht. Aber ich habe euch noch ein Zitat mitgebracht von einem Menschen namens Ricardo Ford, so ein Sponsorship-Consultant, aber der hat gesagt, und was ich einfach, ich finde es ein perfektes Zitat, ich übersetze es direkt nur auf Deutsch, wenn man den ganzen Trubel und die politischen Spielchen immer außer Acht lässt, ist die Arbeit des FIFA-Vertriebsteams wirklich beeindruckend. Gerade angespielt auf die ganzen Verträge, die da eben im Sponsorship geschlossen wurden, dass man da eben gerade im Vergleich zu 2022, das waren 20 zu viel, gemacht hat, also gerade so Hospitality Rights, Ticket Sales, auch da wieder, natürlich, wenn ich mehr Spiele habe, kann ich auch mehr Tickets verkaufen. Wir haben am Montag, glaube ich, auch schon mal so ein bisschen über diese ganze…
Und größere Stadien.
Genau, und größere Stadien. Wir haben ja am Montag schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, wie teuer diese Tickets sind. Auch das würde ich vielleicht jetzt nicht noch alles mal auflisten. Aber ein großes Problem ist zum Beispiel, wenn wir auf die Host-Cities gucken. Und da ist nämlich, ich habe mir das zum Beispiel jetzt mal speziell in Kanada angeguckt. Also Kanada investiert 300 Millionen Dollar ins Turnier. Beziehungsweise die Bundesregierung. Ja, genau. Aber wenn wir laut The Globe and Mail mal auf die beiden Ausdrucksorte gucken, geben die eben kommuniert mehr als eine Milliarde Dollar für die 13 Spiele aus. Also 380 Millionen für die sechs Spiele in Toronto. In Vancouver über 700 Millionen. Und das führte zum Beispiel auch dazu, dass, ja, also für die manche Menschen, das war ein Schock. Also Sharon Boilenbach, die ist Geschäftsführerin der FIFA-Weltmeisterschaft 2026 für die Stadt Toronto. Die hat gesagt, so diese Gesamtausgaben, die es von Staat, Provinz und Bund für das Großartige gibt, weil es eben vor allem hauptsächlich durch Steuergelder bezahlt wird. Das hat durchaus zu Diskussionen geführt. Also anders zum Beispiel in den USA, wo es am Ende schon noch viel Private-Funding und Unternehmensponsoring gab, um das zu finanzieren. San Francisco nimmt zum Beispiel aber auch einen Ticket-Aufschlag von 6 Dollar, um die Einnahmen für die Stadt Santa Clara zu generieren, wo im BS Bay Area Stadion steht. Und zum Beispiel hat Bay Area auch abgelehnt, öffentliche Mittel für die von der FIFA vorgeschriebenen Stadion-Modernisierung einzusetzen. Und das wiederum ist ein großer Kostenfaktor in Toronto und in Vancouver. Also da sprechen wir von 150 bis fast 200 Millionen pro Stadt. Genau, und das eben, es gibt dann ganz viel, also wenn wir jetzt auf die aktuellen Zahlen zum Beispiel gucken, da gibt es neueste Berichte. Ich muss kurz gucken, dass ich die richtige Seite aufmache. Also in der USA hat jede Hosting City außer San Francisco nur eine Hotelbesetzung, wenn man so sagen kann, von 40% oder weniger. Sagt Coaster. Damit ist nicht die Astrologie-App gemeint. Kommt noch mehr Pop-Culture-Reference, die keiner von euch versteht, aber ich weiß, es werden Leute draußen verstehen. In Mexiko und in Kanada ist das ein bisschen besser, aber auch da noch unter 50%. Also wir sehen da schon Sachen, die vielleicht versprochen wurden, die werden dann nicht ganz eingehalten und deshalb sinken da zum Beispiel auch schon, was heißt sinken, also wenn wir von ich finde 300 bis 200 Dollar immer noch sehr viel pro Nacht. Aber natürlich gemessen an dem, wovon wir da reden, ist es relativ wenig.
Könnten wir an der Stelle eine Hochrechnung spekulativer Art machen, wenn wir also wissen aus Kanada mit zwei Veranstaltungsorten und nicht ganz so vielen Spielen, kommen wir also schon bei einer Milliarde an. Was man dann wohl aus den anderen öffentlichen Händen, aus den anderen Ländern aufbringt, um die FIFA zu subventionieren. Weil mehr um was anderes handelt es sich ja nicht. Die Steuerzahler in diesen Städten und Ländern subventionieren die FIFA, damit die am Ende ihre neun Milliarden, oder was hast du vorhin gesagt, verbuchen können. Und wenn die dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden, diese Kosten zu tragen, kämen die bei plus minus null raus. Das heißt also, uns wird ein Spiel vorgespielt, wonach das alles irgendwie ganz toll ist und den Fußball unterstützt. In Wirklichkeit ist das nicht mal, wenn man es fair berechnet, ist es nicht mal gewinnträchtig.
Merkt es euch für die olympischen Spielebewerbungen deutscher Städte, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, große Ereignisse rechnen sich nur in den Prognosen, in denen mit einberechnet wird, wie die Attraktivität eines Standorts vermeidlich gestiegen sei, über große Ereignisse und dann erhöhten Tourismus in den Folgejahren. Und das sind hochspekulative Annahmen, die niemand belegen kann. Und im Nachhinein hat es sich eigentlich auch noch nie so wirklich belegen lassen. Aber zum Ereignis selbst, es mag Ausnahmen in weiterer Vergangenheit geben, aber in jüngerer Vergangenheit, in diesem Jahrtausend, zum Ereignis selbst, nimmst du nicht mehr Geld ein. Und in den USA ist es besonders krass, denn die haben ja nicht mal eine Verbesserung ihrer Infrastruktur durch die Austragung von Spielen, denn da verändert sich nichts. Und die haben dementsprechend auch nicht eines erhöhtes Touristenaufkommen, sondern die Touristen, die sonst da werden, werden einfach ersetzt durch ein paar Fußballfans, die in der Regel übrigens auch noch wenig sind.
Nicht nur ersetzt, die bleiben zu Hause.
Oder die bleiben eben zu Hause.
Die fehlen dann in der Kalkulation, weil, also es gibt jetzt Zahlen aus den USA, wonach trotz FIFA-Weltcup-Besuchern die Gesamtzahl der Prozentsatz, die Hotelbetten da belegt sind oder so, ist niedriger als in einem ganz normalen Sommer. Das heißt, diese Aktivität führt gar nicht zu einem mehr. Ich meine, die führt vielleicht zu höheren Preisen, weil man da also unglaubliche Aufschläge bezahlen muss oder so. Also vielleicht kommt dann ein Hotelier trotzdem auf seine Kosten. Aber das ist so eine, wie nennen wir das? Das ist so ein Märchen, was da entzimiert wird.
Das ist das wahre Sommermärchen, dass die FIFA und auch das IOC und auch die UEFA, wir haben genau dasselbe ja auch bei der EM in Deutschland hier auch schon besprochen, die erzählen, dass Märchen, dass es eben auch wirtschaftlich ein Vorteil wäre, so ein Turnier auszurichten. Und das stimmt, aber halt nur für die ausrichtenden Verbände. Die gehen da mit Geld raus und zwar mit richtig viel Geld, aber die Kosten und auch die Risiken ehrlicherweise, die werden komplett von der öffentlichen Hand getragen, ohne dass es da irgendwann vorher mal eine Abstimmung gegeben hätte. Da sind ja die Olympia Bewerbungen in Deutschland schon fast eine Ausnahme. Arne?
Die Verantwortung liegt bei den Personen vor Ort dann am Ende, liegt bei den Kommunen, liegt bei den Betreibern auch von einem Stadion vor Ort. Und ich will an der Stelle noch mal auf eine Sache hinweisen, die ich sehr, sehr interessant finde. Und zwar, wenn jetzt die Folge veröffentlicht wird am 11. Juni, dann findet übermorgen das erste Spiel der West-Amerikanischen Nationalmannschaft statt in Los Angeles. Und dort gab es jetzt die Abstimmung einer Gewerkschaft von den Mitarbeitenden in einem Stadion, die sich da eben um Hospitality, um Gastronomie kümmern. Das sind ungefähr 2000 Personen ungefähr. Und diese Gewerkschaft, die haben sich mit 96 Prozent dafür entschieden, zu streiken. Die zentrale Forderung ist, dass Agenten von ICE, also von der US-Einwaltungsbehörde, nicht das Stadion betreten dürfen oder das Umfeld des Stadions betreten dürfen, weil sie eben sicher gehen wollen damit, wenn sie dann streiken, dass sie nicht da theoretisch verhaftet werden können. Und das ist für mich natürlich ein Beispiel dessen, dass all das, was wir besprochen haben, jetzt gerade zusammenkommt. Also wir haben einmal Migrationspolitik in Politik mit ICE. Wir haben ein Unternehmen, den Betreiber des Stadions in LA, der natürlich sicherstellen muss, dass da der Betrieb läuft, weil woher wollen die so kurz vor knapp noch 2000 Leute herkriegen, die da irgendwie die Cola verkaufen oder die Burger braten oder was auch immer die dann machen. Wir haben das, was Jürgen vorhin gesagt hat. Wir haben hier tatsächlich dann eine recht starke Gewerkschaft in den USA, was ja nicht immer der Fall ist. Aber hier sieht man ja deutlich, dass es auch durchaus was bewegen kann, wenn man sich eben engagiert, wenn man gewisse Sachen eben unternimmt. Turns out, LA hat auch eine demokratische Bürgermeisterin mit Karen Bass natürlich. Ja, ich glaube, da wurde jetzt auch gewählt irgendwie gestern oder vorgestern.
Aber waren die Vorwahlen, vorwahlen.
Vorwahlen, genau.
Letzte Woche, aber wird noch was gescheckt.
Ja, also wie gesagt, da kulminiert relativ viel in diesem Beispiel und das hat dann natürlich auch wirtschaftliche Folgen, theoretisch, wenn es zu einem Streik kommt.
Und ich würde da gerne einen letzten O-Ton noch einspielen, was nämlich, glaube ich, das alles noch mal zusammen bindet, was eben die Sicht der Host Cities angeht. Vielleicht ist es euch aufgefallen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Chicago, das bei der WM 1994 noch mit sechs Spielen ein sehr wichtiger Standort war und das ja auch als Sportstadt bekannt ist, nicht zuletzt auch deshalb haben die Deutschen da ja gegen die USA ihr letztes Hesspiel gemacht. Chicago ist keine Austragungsstadt von WM-Spielen. Und wir hören den damaligen Bürgermeister von Chicago, der uns mal erklärt, warum das so ist. Ich werde es euch natürlich danach auch nochmal übersetzen.
Wir sind auf der Bösenseite und auf der Rückseite des Gutes. Ich habe gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was der Herr oder der Herr Gouverneur noch macht, aber du erwartest, dass ich die Chicago-Präsidenten als dumme Geld für die Tafel beizutragen? Dann haben sie in der Behandlung gesagt, dass sie das Recht haben, einen Dome zu beherrschen, der über Sojur Field gebaut wurde. Und ich sagte, du musst das ausnehmen. Sie sagten, wir haben es nie verarbeitet, aber es ist etwas, was wir alle fragen. Ich sagte, ich weiß nicht, ob du noch nie ausüben kannst. Es wird immer ein Erstes sein. Nimm es aus. Und wir können auch über andere Probleme arbeiten. Und sie sagten, wir können es nicht ausüben, aber wir haben noch nie ausüben können. Ich sagte, keine Chance hab ich, dass du mir eine 50- bis 100-Millionen-Dollar-Espense erzählen kannst. Und du bist diejenige, die mich direkt mit dem Geld herunterkommt. Und das bedeutet die Bewerber.
Er sagt, wir sind quasi egal, wir sind bei den schlechten Sachen sind als erstes dran, bei den guten Sachen sind wir als letztes dran. Ich weiß nicht, was andere Bürgermeister oder Gouverneure tun, aber ihr erwartet von mir, dass ich die Steuerzahler von Chicago so behandle bei dem vielen Geld, was da auf dem Tisch liegt. Das ist ja nicht euer Ernst. Dann haben sie also die FIFA im Vertrag stehen gehabt, dass sie das Recht hätten, dem Bau einer Kuppel über dem Spielfeld zu verlangen. Jeder, der das Stadion in Chicago kennt. Es ist völlig absurd. Ich sagte Nein, ihr müsst das rausnehmen. Sie sagten, na ja, wir haben das noch nie ausgenübt, aber wir schreiben das halt bei jedem Vertrag rein. Ich sagte mir egal, ob ihr es noch nie ausgeübt habt, es wird immer eine Option sein. Nehmt es raus und dann können wir die anderen Punkte durcharbeiten. Und sie sagten, nein, wir können es nicht rausnehmen, aber wir haben es ja noch nie ausgeübt. Und ich sagte, keine Chance, dass ich zulasse, dass ihr mir eine Ausgabe von 50 bis 100 Millionen Dollar hier reinschreibt. Und ihr seid dann diejenigen, die mir sagen, woher ich das Geld nehmen soll. Und das bedeutet nämlich von den Steuerzahlern. Das war so ungefähr der Tropfen, der das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht hat. Man kann nicht etwas in einem Vertrag haben, dass die Stadt und die Steuerzahler mindestens potenziell belastet. Und dann entscheidet ihr darüber, dass ich genau darüber kein Stimmrecht habe. Also diese Knebel-Verträge der FIFA werden hier noch mal wunderbar auf den Punkt gebracht. Und es ist bei jedem Sport Großereignis gleich. Man kann nur dankbar sein, dass er das so deutlich geäußert hat. Und wenn wir...
Es gab aber einen Hintergrund dafür, weil Chicago hatte und sicher hat immer noch Steuereinnahmeprobleme. Die haben Etaprobleme. Das heißt, die hätten das draufsatteln müssen auf die Probleme, die sie eh schon haben. Und mit der angeblichen Behauptung verkauft bekommen, ja, aber ihr macht ja hier richtig Kohle oder so. Und der hat da halt durchgeblickt. Rahman Manuel wird vielleicht auch übrigens in den Präsidentschaftswahlkampf der Demokraten in einem oder anderthalb Jahren mit einsteigen. Ich glaube, der ist ganz ausgeruht und der hat eine etwas scharfe Zunge und auch einen scharfen, also der denkt auch sehr scharf. Ich mag ihn nicht wirklich, weil ich glaube, er ist politisch komplett an bestimmte Länder verkauft und wie zum Beispiel Israel und anderes. Aber den werden wir noch hören, also irgendwann demnächst. Und ich sagte ja am Montag, also Montreal wird gefeiert in Kanada, weil die auch ausgeschert sind. Und die haben nun gerade 50 Jahre olympische Spiele und 1976. Und die haben sich da damals sowas von verkalkuliert. Die haben geglaubt, nachdem, weiß ich nicht, die haben daran abgestottert, ich glaube, 20 Jahre oder so, um die Schulden, die sie da aufgehäuft haben, irgendwie abzudecken. Also die waren auch schlau genug, weil sie, die hatten schon mal auf die Herdplatte gefasst und da wussten die, dass man sich da ganz schön verbrennen kann. Diese Leute brauchen wir.
Eva, du wolltest noch was ergänzen.
Ich habe noch einen letzten popkulturellen Punkt, weil ich dafür ja heute einstehe. Ich muss noch eine großartige Sängerin reinbringen, und zwar Céline Dionne. Ich dachte dir auch nicht, dass ihr das heute noch hört. Aber es gibt eben noch...
Kaum auszuhalten, aber gut.
Hallo. Jetzt wird sie aber noch zum Ende ein bisschen schwierig. Ne, und zwar haben wir jetzt ja viel darüber gesprochen, wie große Events eigentlich überhaupt sich ökonomisch gesehen irgendwie rechnen. Und zwar sagt man eben, die Weltmeisterschaft, die macht so ein localized economic momentum, heißt es hier. Und Céline Dion's kommende 2026 Paris-Konzerte, die sind wohl so ein Beispiel dafür, welche so auf einer makroökonomischen Ebene wieder kulturelle Events eben doch durchaus ja nachhaltig wohl Geld reinbringen können. Also diese 16 ausverkauften Konzerte in der La Défense Arena sollen zwischen 570 Millionen und einer Billion ökonomischen Impact bringen. Und da eben vor allem auch Tourismus, Hospitality, Kundinnen etc. und internationale Gäste geben.
Good luck.
Ja, also ich meine, wir haben es ja auch schon anders als auch.
Bonne Chance.
Bonne Chance. Aber zum Beispiel, das war ja auch das, was zum Beispiel, also wir reden hier einmal, um es noch reinzubringen, dass die BEP halt sehr, sehr gering steigen soll. Er soll zwar steigen, ich glaube, in den letzten Jahren ist es nur einmal in Südafrika. Also bei den letzten Austrangen war es ein negativer BEP.
Also durch das Ausrichten einer WM meinst du jetzt.
Genau, genau, genau. Und ja, also wir haben es ja schon so gesehen, so gerade so Konzerte können schon immer einen anderen Impact haben als...
Frag mal Gelsenkirchen mit Taylor Swift. Aber das ist jetzt nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Genau. Taylor Swift hat Schalke gerettet.
Oder die Village People in den USA.
Ja, aber die sind ja auch schwieriger als Taylor Swift. Meiner Meinung nach.
Please don't go there.
Ich möchte bitte noch darauf aufmerksam machen, dass es bessere französischsprachige Sängerinnen gibt als Celine Dion.
Oh Gott, wir kommen jetzt wirklich noch zum Umwachs.
So where did I go wrong?
Du bist ja Fan von solchen Musikerinnen oder Sängerinnen. Lara Fabian, falls du den Namen noch nie gehört hast, eine in Belgien aufgehört.
Hab ich noch nie gehört, aber I will not take any Celine Dion slender. So.
Aber Lara Fabian gibt es auf YouTube, okay?
Okay, wenn das schon das Argument ist.
Bitte mal antesten. Wir sehen uns ja demnächst wieder. Also bitte mal antesten.
Oh ja, fair.
Hast du mir jetzt Hausaufgaben gegeben?
Nein.
Wirklich?
Aber echt?
Okay, dann will ich aber auch, also gut, wenn wir jetzt hier schon irgendwelche YouTube-Sachen droppen, dann werde ich in den Show Notes eins meiner Lieblings-YouTube-Mathematik-Videos posten. Nämlich, da erfährt man nämlich auch unter anderem, warum Chicago immer noch so viele Geldprobleme hat, weil sie nämlich schon mal so viele Geldprobleme hatten, dass sie die Einnahmen an ihren Parkuhrn an einen ja, Venture-Capital-Fonds ausgelagert haben und sie haben das Ganze mit dem Zinseszins nicht so richtig gut durchgerechnet. Und deswegen werden sie da nämlich noch, ich glaube, immer noch 10 oder 20 Jahre richtig Verlust mitmachen, weil sie das alles unterschätzt haben, wie sich das so entwickeln würde, auch inflationär und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ganze klingt nach einem ja sorry, das klingt nach einem Move, den die Stadt Köln auch hätte machen können.
Die sehen das Video und sehen es als Handlungsaufforderung.
Und da es da ja auch den Klingelpuls gibt, kann man ja das auch irgendwie namentlich irgendwie noch ein bisschen verbinden.
Wobei wir wieder bei einem Weißgeist wären.
Ja, das haben die Hörerinnen und Hörer nicht mitbekommen. Das war in unserer unfreiwilligen Stunde Pause, die wir gemacht haben, die im Nachhinein keine Pause war, weil wir dachten, jede Sekunde geht es los. Aber das ist was anderes. Ich will noch ein inhaltliches Argument machen und dann machen wir diese Sendung hier zu. Und zwar nur, falls ihr euch jetzt gefragt habt. Wir waren jetzt bei unheimlich vielen negativen Themen dieser WM. Und trotzdem bleibt ja die Frage, warum sind denn auch die Mitgliedsverbände so ein großer Fan dieses Turniers und auch große Fans dieses Turniers in den USA? Und das hängt mit dem Teil zusammen, den wir jetzt nicht mehr im Detail besprechen. Aber das ist nämlich das, was die FIFA dann wieder verteilt. Es sind 11,67 Milliarden US-Dollar, davon fast 900 Millionen über Preisgelder. Also allein der Weltmeister wird 50 Millionen Dollar allein davon bekommen. Nochmal 355 Millionen über Abstellungsprämien. Sie haben unheimlich hohe Durchführungs- und administrative Kosten. Das Bericht, das sind 2,8 Milliarden tatsächlich, die da rauskommen. Ganz interessant, auch hier sieht man, die FIFA steht da durchaus unter Kostendruck. Angeblich soll es so gewesen sein, das berichtet die Athletic, dass Gianni Infantino mehr oder weniger einfach so ohne Absprache den Mitarbeitenden vor Ort gesagt hat, ihr müsst jetzt 100 Millionen US-Dollar einsparen, und zwar in den Themen Sicherheit, Logistik und Barrierefreiheit. Egal wie ihr es macht, ihr müsst es jetzt machen. Das ist das, was ich vorhin auch andeuten wollte. Es ist nicht alles rosig, was auch das Finanzielle angeht. Aber das Ganze führt eben dazu, dass eben dann über das, Sie nennen es FIFA Development Program, das sind eben die Zahlungen, die dann an die Mitgliedsverbände gehen, die sind gestiegen. Und die sind um 30 Prozent gestiegen. Jeder Verband bekommt im kompletten Zyklus 23 bis 26 bis zu 8 Millionen US-Dollar und kann noch weitere 1,2 Millionen US-Dollar zur Deckung von Reise-, Unterkunfts- und Ausstattungskosten erhalten. Wird auch alles transparent in einem Bericht der FIFA wiedergegeben. Ihr könnt dann auch sehen, welche Fußballplätze da in San Marino und so weiter gebaut werden. Warum erzähle ich euch jetzt aber noch mal diese langweiligen Zahlen? Weil das nämlich eine Sache noch mal, finde ich, auf den Punkt bringt. Die 8 Millionen US-Dollar, die sind für den DFB nicht nichts, aber das sind gerade so viele Mitglieder, wie der DFB hat. Die 8 Millionen US-Dollar für Cap Verde, ihr könnt das selbst vervorständigen. Das ist der Grund, warum bei gleichzeitig der demokratischen Form, dass jeder Mitgliedsverband unabhängig von seiner Größe eine Stimme hat, das erklärt, warum Geld immer bei der FIFA die Entscheidung treffen wird. Und solange Gianni Infantino es schaffen wird, durch dieses Turnier und durch andere Dinge, die er sich einfallen lässt, mehr Geld zu den Mitgliedsverbänden zu schieben, solange wird er wahrscheinlich so fest im Sattel sitzen, dass es weiter quasi durch Akklamationen eine Bestätigung in seinem Präsidentenamt gibt. Und irgendwann wird Gianni Infantino aber weg sein. Auch er wird es wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen, diese Amtszeitbegrenzung von zwei auf drei zu erhöhen und dann auf unendlich. Und dann wird aber die Aufgabe des folgenden Präsidenten wieder sein. Mehr Geld, mehr Geld, mehr Geld. Denn darum geht es. Oder Arne?
Nur ein Halbsatz. Und die Personen im FIFA Council werden auch für die drei bis vier Meetings, die sie haben, im Jahr fürstlich bezahlt mit 250.000 US-Dollar ungefähr. Das heißt, von denen ist auch nicht viel zu erwarten.
Und bei Neundorf ist genauso jemand, der eben diese 250.000 US-Dollar dafür bekommt, dass er dann zumindest öffentlich keinerlei Kritik übt. Aber das, glaube ich, bindet noch mal ganz viel ab. Ihr Lieben, das war jetzt ein wilder Ritt. Es war auch wirklich, man hat es uns wahrscheinlich auch zwischendurch angemerkt, es war jetzt auch eine anstrengende Aufnahme durch die Umstände. Umso mehr möchte ich euch danken, denn ich weiß, wie viel Zeit ihr reingesteckt habt in die Vorbereitung und nicht nur jetzt in die Aufnahme. Ich danke ganz, ganz herzlich Arne Steinberg. Bitte abonniert die B-Note, schreibt uns deinen Newsletter. Und ich weiß nicht, ob du damit irgendwas geplant hast, Arne, aber solltest du da mal irgendwann ein Unterstützungsmodell mit einrichten, dann will ich, dass die Rasenfunk-Community dich unterstützt, denn wir brauchen freie unabhängige Journalisten wie dich. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr gerne. Dieses Unterstützungsmodell gibt es schon. Findet ihr auf der Seite dort.
Siehst du, ich war mir eben nicht mehr gerade zu 100 Prozent sicher.
Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich danke dir. Ich danke auch Jürgen Kalwa. Ich freue mich, dass wir uns im Wm-Panel dann schon bald wiederhören. Bitte streitet euch nicht über irgendwelche französischen Sängerin. Das möchte ich nicht. Das fühlt sich an, als würde ich das nicht.
Das ist ja nicht irgendwelche.
Also Jürgen, wenn du so anfängst, dann müssen wir aber bald über Ghost reden und woraus.
Nein, es ist keine Französin. Es ist eine Kanadierin. Ähm, die, also französisch, eine Franco-Kanadierin, also eine Frau Dionne.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel das gerade für mich ist.
Und die Frau, die ich genannt habe, ist eine Belgierin. Also das sind nicht mal Franzosen.
Okay, ich danke dir trotzdem für die Zeit, die du mit, die du hattest und für deine Einordnung. Und freue mich, dass du weiter hier die Wm mit uns begleitest. Danke dir.
Ciao.
Und natürlich herzlichen Dank an Eva-Lotta Bohle, unsere Stimme der Jugend, unsere popkulturelle Referenz.
Bitte nicht immer sagen.
Entschuldigung, du hast es doch hier so mit reingebracht. Schön, dass du mit dabei warst, Eva. Danke, dass du dich so vorbereitet hast. Sorry, dass wir jetzt an deinem Finansteil, den du so lange vorbereitet hast, am meisten gespart haben zeitlich.
Das tut mir leid. Gar nicht schlimm. Ich hätte mich wahrscheinlich spätestens bei der dritten Zahl vertan und Billionen und Milliarden und Millionen durcheinander geschmissen. Von daher gar kein Thema. Ich habe sehr viel gelernt, wirklich. Unironisch. Freue mich sehr auf unsere Wm-Panels. Jürgen, wir haben noch viele Themen zu diskutieren. Ich warte schon mal vor, also Inga und ich, wir suchen uns schon mal pro Wm-Teilnehmerland einen Taylor Swift Song aus, damit müsst ihr jetzt klarkommen.
Da müsst ihr auch noch mit Tobi rechnen. Also der könnte euch noch in die Gerätsche.
Den Tobi darf man popkulturell nicht unterschätzen. Das kann ich euch sagen. Aber das sind andere Themen. Zuletzt möchte ich euch danken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wie sind solche Mammutsendungen, die wirklich viel Vorbereitung reingeflossen sind, wie sind solche Sendungen eigentlich möglich? Ich gucke gerade unser Vorbereitungstokument. Wir haben knapp die 100.000 Zeichen nicht geschafft. Aber 57 DIN A4-Seiten bei 98.600 Zeichen. Das war unser Vorbereitungstokument. Wie ist sowas möglich? Fragt ihr ohne Paywall, ohne Sponsoren, ohne, was ist das letzte, was ich immer sage? Genau, das gibt es auch nicht. Nur durch eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de. Wenn ihr auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt, erfahrt ihr, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Auch in der Podcast und in der Videobeschreibung. Es geht ganz schnell. Es geht eigentlich auf jedem Weg. Das heißt, da ist auch keine große Hürde und macht eben Journalismus wie diesen hier möglich und ermöglicht es uns dann auch, ein Gästehonorat zu zahlen. Also vielen herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns schon unterstützt haben. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Cree, bei Ines, bei Alex, bei Martin, bei Cree und bei die Seite LED Wohles. Vielen herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de abonniert auch sehr gerne den Nationalteams Feed, denn da gibt es alle Sendungen zu den deutschen Spielen. Und zuletzt würde ich mich unheimlich freuen, wenn ihr Sendungen wie diese hier weiterempfehlt. Wenn ihr den Menschen darauf aufmerksam macht, es gibt auch diese Art und Weise diese Wm zu konsumieren. Vielleicht hat man dann mit die beste Laune, ich gebe es ja zu. Und alles andere ist ja auch völlig legitim. Aber vielleicht gibt es da draußen Leute, die genau nach so etwas gesucht haben. Helft ihnen, uns zu finden. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, werdet oder bleibt gesund und bis bald im Rasenfunk.
Ciao!
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.